are you ready to unlock the hidden
potential of devops tools and embark on
a thrilling journey into the world of
seamless software development and
deployment prepare yourself for an
extraordinary adventure with Dev Mastery
the Ultimate key to revolutionize your
business and shape the future like never
before imagine a world where software
development is a breeze where teams
collaborate effortlessly and Innovation
flows like a mighty River welcome to the
realm of devops where productivity
source and time to Market shrinks giving
you a Competitive Edge like no other but
that's not all brace yourself for a
mind-blowing revelation devops has
emerged as the Undisputed champion of
the software development landscape with
over 80 percent of organizations
adopting DeVos practices it has become
the drying force behind the success of
egg joints and startups alike the demand
for skill dams professional is
skyrocketing and the opportunity for you
to thrive is boundless now let's dive
into the numbers that hold the key to
your future times the ones that will
ignite your career like a supernova Dev
professionals are commanding Top Tire
salaries with average annual earnings in
from ninety thousand dollars to one
hundred forty thousand dollars as you
master the art of devops you will unlock
even more thrilling opportunities in
this rapidly volume field if you're
ready to embark on a career path
pulsating with excitement Innovation and
Limitless growth look no further than
simply lens get a post-graduate program
in devops this comprehensive program
equips you with the Knowledge and Skills
to navigate the devops landscape with
confidence explode the depth of
continuous integration delivery and
concur the intricacies of Automation and
orchestration fortify security like a
digital Fortress and unleash the full
potential of cloud Technologies don't
let this once in a lifetime opportunity
slip away ignite your career and join
the ranks of prime Dev professionals
click the link in the description box to
unveil the wonders of this course
immerse yourself in all aspiring success
stories from A Satisfied Learners who
have harnessed the transformative power
of devops to achieve the extraordinary
the future of software development
resides in devops and it's eagerly
waiting your arrival are you ready to
seize it and so to unimaginable Heights
business
[Music]
hey there my name is
we're actually brothers and we live here
in Alberta Canada we do a lot of things
together
and this time we decided to take a
course in devops from Simply learn the
course proved to be very beneficial for
both our careers yeah I got a promotion
after the course and I got a hired with
a new company
I'm actually a mechanical engineering
graduate and I've been working at my
company for the last four years in 2020
I came to know that my company was
starting the hiring process for a devops
infrastructure team
at the time I was working as an
implementation specialist and my
colleagues recommend that I take a
course in devops if I wanted to be part
of a team so I started doing my research
and then he came to me saying that he
was also looking for a devops course
yeah funny enough I actually found the
course through Instagram but you know my
situation was slightly different I had
been working as a geomatic field
technician for about four years but I
wanted to change my career into
something that involved more programming
and automation so when I came across
with this course I said you know what
let's take it
and caltex name was definitely a
deciding factor in July 2021 we got our
certifications and I immediately posted
that on my LinkedIn profile you know
coincidentally in November of that same
year we got the good news
and I got hired as a dis developer
which has allowed me to do way more
programming which is what I wanted to do
around that time I got promoted to the
devops infrastructure team and saw a 21
salary hike the overall course was
awesome but the part that I enjoyed the
most was a Docker certification training
you know what I also really enjoyed the
docker certification training I think
there were brothers after all
yeah the experience was amazing and
being able to study together was
definitely very nice yeah it brought us
back to those good old days when we were
going to school together we didn't go
through a number of key elements today
the first two will be reviewing models
that you're already probably using for
delivering Solutions into your company
and the most popular one is waterfall
followed by agile then we'll look at
devops and how devops differs from the
two models and how it also borrows and
leverages the best of those models we'll
go through each of the phases that are
used in typical devops delivery and then
the tools used within those phases to
really improve the efficiencies within
devops finally we'll summarize the
advantages that devops brings to you and
your teams so let's go through waterfall
so waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering Solutions not just IT
solutions and digital Solutions but even
way before that it has its history it
goes back to World War II so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then Cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage Gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage Gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project plan
so you have an understanding of what the
level of work is needed to be able to be
successful in delivering the solution
after that you've got your plan then you
start doing the development and that
means that the programmers start coding
out their solution they build out their
applications to build out the websites
and this can take weeks or even months
to actually do all the work when you've
done your coding and development then
you send it to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against the
systems and databases that integrate
with your application you'll test it
against the actual code you'll do manual
testing you do UI testing and then after
you've delivered the solution you go
into maintenance mode which is just kind
of making sure that the application
keeps working there's any security risks
that you address those security risks
now the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage Gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole Pro project
it's very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your clients and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
chance you then have is if you want to
add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback and quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that solution simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send their requirements
back to the programmer with feedback
this allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop where we're able to get
information to the clients and the
client can get back to the dab
development team much faster typically
when we're actually going through this
process we're looking at the engagement
cycle being about two weeks and so it's
much faster than the traditional
waterfall approach and so we can look at
each feedback loop as comprising of four
key elements we have the planning where
we actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and solution that
is needed for the client and then we
review with the clients the changes that
have happened but we do all this in a
much tighter cycle that we call a Sprint
and that typically a Sprint will last
for about two weeks some companies run
sprints every week some run every four
weeks it's up to you as a team to decide
how long you want to actually run a
Sprint but typically it's two weeks and
so every two weeks the client is able to
provide feedback into that Loop and so
you were able to move quickly through
iterations and so if we get to the end
of Sprint 2 and the client says hey you
know what we need to make a change you
can make those changes quickly and
effectively for Sprint three what we
have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they maybe small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple Sprints but when you go through
the Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your Sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the actual
Sprint team to ensure that everybody is
staying on track and if there's any
blockers that those blockers are being
addressed effectively and immediately
the goal at the end of the two weeks is
to have a deliverable product that you
can put in front of the customer and the
customer can then do a review the key
advantages you have are running a Sprint
with agile is that the client
requirements are better understood
because the client is really integrated
into the scrum team they're there all
the time and the product is delivered
much faster than with a traditional
water full model you're delivering
features at the end of each Sprint
versus waiting weeks months or in some
cases years for a waterfall project to
be completed however there are there are
also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the Sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their Sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their Sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production service but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an API that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these charges that the operations
team are constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works so this is where devops
really comes in and let's dig into how
devops which is developers and operators
working together is the key for
successful continuous delivery so devops
is as an evolution of the agile model
the agile model really is great for
Gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
Solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the Ops Team and the
dev team and so so with devops what
we're doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that is based on data so let's step
through the different phases of a devops
team so typically you'll see that the
devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
Agile and what I'd like to point out at
the time is that again agile and devops
are very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
Agile is that the code is actually start
coding but they typically they'll start
using tools such as git which is a
distributed Version Control software it
makes it easier for developers to all be
working on the same code base rather
than bits of the code that is rather
than them working on bits of the code
that they are responsible for so the
goal with using tools such as git is
that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as Maven and
Gradle as a way to consistently build
out your environment and then we also
use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools another Point here is
that the tools that we're listing here
these are all open source tools these
are tools that any team can start using
we want to have tools that control and
manage the deployment of code into the
production environments and then finally
tools such as ansible and Chef will
actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can just
zero in on spikes and issues that are
relevant to either the code or changing
consumer habits on the site so let's
step through some of those tools that we
have in the devops environment so here
we have is a breakdown of the devops
tools that we have and again one of the
things I want to point out is that these
tools are open source tools there are
also many other tools this is just
really a selection of some of the more
popular tools that are being used but
it's quite likely that you're already
using some of these tools today you may
already be using Jenkins you may already
be using git but some of the other tools
really help you create a fully
scriptable environment so that you can
actually start scripting out your entire
devops tool set this really helps when
it comes to speeding up your delivery
because the more you can actually script
out of the work that you're doing the
more effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this devops process so we go
through and we have our continuous
delivery which is our plan code build
and test environment so what happens if
you want to make a release well the
first thing you want to do is send out
your files to the build environment and
you want to be able to test the code
that you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production and environment if however
your code passes the scripting test it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to Agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your Sprint Cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
Google Google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great video
those on YouTube that you can find out
on how their devops teams work Netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with Netflix is that Netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and Netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on Smart TVs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for Netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from Netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver a software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to Waterfall complexity of
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment now you're improving
the communication between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted what we're going to do
is we're going to break up the tools
into eight different categories now
we're going to go through the planning
and code base tools the building tools
the testing tools the all-important
integration tool the deployment
operation and then finally monitoring
tools something we should also add is
that all of these tools are open source
this means that you can get up and
running with your devops environment
immediately without having to worry
about licensing costs so let's jump into
the very first tool which is get so git
is a distributed Version Control tool
that allows development teams to be able
to share code amongst each other in a
way that allows the creation of small to
extreme extremely large applications to
be created effortlessly if we look at
the architecture of git and the way that
it works that there are four key areas
we have the working directory the
staging area local repository and then
remote repository so your working
directory is where you actually create
all the files that you'll be working on
in your application now the staging is
the area that you get ready to commit
those files to your local repository for
Version Control and once you actually
have then put them into your local
repository then you want to be able to
push those files using a push command
out to a remote repository such as
GitHub or gitlab in addition if you have
a distributed team you can then also
then pull down the latest files so as a
team you can always be working on all
the files all the time and then go
through the whole process Again by
working on your local files you can do
this whole process really quickly and
easily get is actually a free tool that
you can download and run through command
line off your computer finally you want
to be able to merge files that you may
be working on say for instance a
different branch which is a new feature
you want to be able to merge those files
back into the master directory the
master Branch that's running on git
itself so some of the things to point
out with get what makes it really useful
is that it's absolutely brilliant at
being able to track changes in your
source code this is something that
source code tools really kind of should
be able to do but get is exceptionally
good at this having large teams working
at different phases within the project
and working on different branches within
the project is really easy to do and the
collaboration tools will then get to
make it so that your teams can work
effortlessly with each other inherently
you are creating backups with all your
code which is fantastic and probably
most important part is that the
environment itself is a non-linear
environment this means that you don't
have to work through specific gates to
be able to reach feature to actually get
a feature ready for delivery you can
actually work in a non-linear fashion so
who's using get well as you can imagine
all of the big technology companies are
using gears including Netflix left and
Intel plus many many other companies so
let's get on to our next tool which is
Maven and the focus on Maven is to
automate the build process of code
that's being checked into a repository
such as a git repository so we have a
look at the architecture here Maven
itself actually executes what are called
pom files and those Palm files actually
then look for specific dependencies that
will then go against a repository to be
able to build out the project you can
actually extend the pump files with
plugins and you can actually then create
a specific build profile for your
environments which is absolutely
fantastic because you can really
fine-tune the profile and again all of
this is scripted and this is something
that is common with all the tools that
you'll be using in a true devops
environment is that you can script all
of them which means that you could
automate the processes that are in your
devops environment and it really
accelerate the ability to be able to
build consistent high quality software
final step four I'm having Ramen is to
actually build all the software into a
in our build server so a couple of
things that are important to notice with
Maven one of the things that you'll see
that's key with all of the tools that we
have here really easy to use Maven
itself it's got a pretty simple setup
it's highly available which means that
your teams can rely on the solution
being ready for your environment and you
can actually get to it and use it very
easily and consistently you can have
multiple builds happening at the same
time which is really important
particularly if you have branched
software you want to be able to test the
branches and the other thing as well is
that it's open source so you have
instant access to new features without
any additional configuration so it
really helps your teams to get the new
code and Implement new features within
the environment itself so you're always
working on the latest and greatest as
you can imagine devops shops such as
Zillow and zens and JPMorgan Chase are
already using Maven and you'll see that
many devops shops are also using Maven
for their build software testing with
selenium is very important and being
able to automate that environment is
critical so you can actually guarantee
that your code will work and selenium
itself is designed for testing and
automating web applications it's really
good in that environment and we look at
the architecture the way that it works
is that you actually have a client
library that goes against the code
you're writing with a c-sharp python
Java JavaScript and then there are
specific drivers that go against the web
browsers to actually test out the code
that you have created so that you can
actually see whether it works in the
appropriate web browsers and all of the
popular web browsers are supported with
selenium selenium is an open source
solution it does allow you to write
scripts in multiple different languages
which is a real big bonus and you can as
well run parallel test execution so this
balances very well with Maven and as
with other tools that we have it's
really easy to use and selenium is being
used by Google HubSpot and Salesforce as
well as many other companies so let's
talk about the really important part
which is integrating all of this and
Jenkins really is the facto tool in this
space so the role of Jenkins is to be
able to merge and allow for that
continuous integration that you need to
make devops successful so allowing the
dev the development team to integrate
effectively with the Ops the operations
team and do that through testing and
management of the code that has been
created so if we look at the
architecture here we have our remote
source code repository it's going to be
waiting for a Jenkins pull to be able to
create a commit and then that Jenkins
serve Master will then push out and
distribute the work to multiple slaves
so they can actually have the actual
code being pushed around your
environment so Jenkins is really easy to
use it's very mature it's been around
for many years there are a significant
number of plugins that allowed for the
Jenkins environment to be scaled very
effectively and it is portable across
multiple Platforms in fact most of the
leading operating systems will support
Jenkins and as you can imagine Jenkins
is being used by companies such as
LinkedIn and Microsoft eBay Dell and
Cloudera so let's talk about the other
side of devops and talk about some of
the operations tool and we'll start off
with Docker so the role of Docker is to
make it easy for people to be able to
simulate full environments quickly and
easily on their desktop for building and
testing but at the same time make it
really easy to be able to Port those
environments across multiple areas so
let's let me talk a little bit about how
that would work so with the docker
engine you have a Docker client locally
that allows you to emulate the whole
Docker environment without having to
have the overhead that you would
typically have if you're doing
virtualization or dedicated servers
running specific dedicated operating
systems because you are scripting the
entire environment Docker is a very
scalable and repeatable environment for
being able to take a across the entire
Cloud Network so some of the features
are really important for Docker it's
incredibly portable across multiple
platforms the docker team have done
fantastic job on portability it does run
in isolation so what this means is that
you can actually have multiple Docker
environments running on a server
concurrently and they will not interrupt
each other they actually fully isolated
sandbox environments so the other part
to Dockers because it is stripped out of
needless operating system and and host
environments apis and services the
actual startup and boot time for a
Docker is really very fast which in turn
makes this very scalable and efficient
to run and you can actually reuse
volumes very easily so who's using
Docker just about everybody Spotify Uber
PayPal BBC really Docker is used by a
lot of people just a side note probably
something that would complement Docker
very well is kubernetes and kubernetes
is becoming a very popular alternative
to Docker and so you know really get to
know both of those tools so let's talk
about some of the operation and
management tools that you have for your
environment and the three big ones here
are chef ansible and puppet and we'll
start with ansible and ansible is a
configuration software package and
unlike the other two products here
unlike chef and puppet ansible doesn't
actually require a client to run on the
host server where you're pushing out a
configuration you can actually have a
defined operation configuration so like
a web server configuration or a database
configuration or an iot Cloud
configuration you can actually have that
running effectively from a script that
is written on a client machine and then
on your local machine and then you can
push that script that you've created out
to your remote servers and have
everything work as you'd expect quickly
on your remote servers you know just
some of the key features of and support
it's incredibly lightweight one of the
things that's really important with
ansible is that it's actually a very
easy to use there is unlike the other
two tools we'll be covering unlike um
puppet and Chef ansible actually has a
full GUI that you can use to actually
interact and build out Solutions so
there is a a visual interface that you
can actually go in so you're not just
working completely in command line
companies that are using ansible include
Twitter EA Sports Cisco and NASA as well
as Verizon so complementing ansible but
probably a little bit more popular right
now are chef and puppet and we'll have a
chef first now both chef and puppet are
somewhat similar in configuration and
both of them rely on having a client
server relationship with their
architecture the way that Chef works is
that Chef actually creates recipes and
each recipe is a server configuration
setup and what you actually do is you
create individual recipes and then for
your entire network you create what's
called a cookbook and that cookbook she
can be used to control the setup of your
entire network and this works really
well for being able to create consistent
and highly scalable environments things
that are great with Chef is that it's
actually a very flexible configuration
and you can actually do an awful lot
with it it has really good security
features which are very appealing to
particularly if you have a devsec Ops
environment where the security team are
integrated with your devops environment
and that's something that's becoming
more and more popular the chef itself is
actually pretty easy to use it is a
command line tool but it is actually
fairly easy to use and the actual
scripting of the recipes is something
that you can do even if you don't have
much scripting experiences something
there are so many recipes out and
available you can actually use many of
the templates that have already been
written and just either copy them or
modify them to your environment as you'd
expect a lot of the companies are using
Chef are the big technology companies
such as Facebook and IBM Microsoft in
particular has really invested heavily
and chef but you'll find that Chef is
probably the most popular management
tool used within the Azure environment
so a complimentary product to Chef is
puppet and if we look at puppets and as
you can imagine again another open
source configuration tool the structure
as you can see is actually very similar
in concept to a chef in which you have a
local server that actually has all the
configuration environments the templates
and the files and the manifests and it
will actually then communicate with all
of your entire environments such as and
then with puppet they refer to them as
nodes and within your node you have
multiple servers but it's similar in
concept to Chef in many ways and that
it's just another way of being able to
control your environment both are really
great Tools in fact really all three of
them ansible chef and puppet are great
tools what you have to do as a devops
team is really just decide which tool is
the one that's appropriate for your
environment so some things that are
great with puppet it's a multi-platform
compatible it's very scalable and it
allows you to push out changes to your
environment really really fast and who
are using puppets you've got red hat HP
Google leading devops teams are using
puppets today so let's get into the two
tools that we have that actually monitor
our operations environment Splunk and
negos so uh Splunk is as you're
expecting some monitoring tool and its
goal is to actually monitoring the
operations of all the environments that
you have to make sure that they're
working correctly and it does this by
going through and reviewing your entire
environment and writing the operational
information to disk and then searching
that environment to make sure everything
works correctly it does a lot of
analysis in real time it is a very easy
to set up and use tool for testing for
analysis and then be able to then
troubleshoot any failures that may come
up the thing that's great about Splunk
is that you can actually put it in a
distributed environment so that's no
single point of failure which makes it
itself inherently very very scalable so
Cisco Facebook Domino's Pizza Dubai
airports are all customers that are
using Splunk today in their devops
environments so finally let's jump into
our final monitoring tool which is uh
negios and very similar to Splunk is
nego so probably the big difference is
that it's client server setup but really
again it's all about being able to
Monitor and check the status of your
entire environment and your network and
your service in real time and give you
the appropriate visualizations whether
it's on your laptop or whether it's an
alert that sent out your phone and you
know so you're aware in real time how
your network is performing and can then
check and adjust to actually making
changes and the bottom line in this kind
of architecture with Splunk and nagos is
that it allows you as the operations
lead to be able to be ahead of any
received impact so say for instance you
are putting in specific check marks for
your environment you can actually have
alerts being sent out to your team when
certain thresholds are met and so that
means that you are aware of problems
with your environment before your
customer is there's nothing worse than
somebody emailing and saying hey your
website doesn't work or like a page is
down or it's slow or something like this
with nagias and Splunk these are tools
that really address those kind of
problems so that you stay ahead of the
curve so some of the things that are
really good with negas is negus itself
is very very comprehensive you can do an
awful lot with it and it allows you to
be able to get to the root of monitoring
and analyzing your problems within your
operations and network environment very
quickly it has a very modular
architecture which also then makes it
extremely highly available and because
the the system itself is not reliant on
on just a single launch application
actually the modular architecture allows
it to be scalable and very easy to
manage across the entire environment
companies using NOS include Uber and
hike and webedia again these are all
technology companies but there's no
reason why you shouldn't be using them
as well if you're ready to embark on a
career path pulsating with excitement
Innovation and Limitless growth look no
further than simply landscape Tech
postgraduate program in devops this
comprehensive program equips you with
the Knowledge and Skills to navigate the
devops landscape with confidence explode
the depth of continuous integration
delivery and concur the entry cases of
Automation and orchestration fortify
security like a digital Fortress and
unleash the full potential of cloud
Technologies don't let this once in a
lifetime opportunity slip away ignite
your career and join the ranks of prime
Dev professionals click the link in the
description box to unveil the wonders of
this course what are we going to cover
today so we're going to introduce the
concept of Version Control that you will
use within your devops environment then
we'll talk about the different tools are
available in a distributed Version
Control System will highlight a product
called get which is typically used for
Version Control today and you'll also go
through what are the differences between
get and GitHub you may have used GitHub
in the past or other products like get
lab and we'll explain what are the
differences between get and get and
services such as GitHub and gitlab will
break out the architecture of what a get
process looks like how do you go through
and create forks and clones how do you
have collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally I'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as GitHub all right let's talk a
little bit about Version Control System
items so you may have already been using
a version control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as Microsoft's team
Foundation services but essentially the
use of a Version Control System allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
Version Control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there will be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the the version one changes that you
had then the person would then later on
check out that code and then be a
version two and added to that code and
so you keep adding on versions of that
code the bottom line is that eventually
you'll have people being able to use
your code and that your code will be
stored in a centralized location however
the charge you're running is that it's
very difficult for large groups to work
simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a VCS system a Version
Control System demonstrate that you're
able to store multiple versions of a
solution in a single repository now
let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional Version Control Systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed Version Control so in a
distributed Version Control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed Version Control System
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed VCS server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS environment is
get now you may remember that we
actually covered get in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you've made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so you'll
get repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get get
is a distributed Version Control tool
used for source code management so
GitHub is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
clients to that remote Hub server now
git is used to track the changes of the
source code and allows large teams to
work so simultaneously with each other
it supports a non-linear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about get versus GitHub so
get is a software tool whereas GitHub is
a service and I'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software tool for get locally on your
system whereas GitHub because it is a
service it's actually hosted on a
website git is actually the software
that used to manage different versions
of source code whereas GitHub is used to
have a copy of the local repository
stored on the service on the website
itself git provides command line tools
that allow you to interact with your
files whereas GitHub has a graphical
interface that allows you to check in
and check out files so let me just show
you the two tools here so here I am at
the git website and this is the website
you would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do Version Control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
Hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with GitHub there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to GitHub gitlab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as Microsoft
Visual Studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of Visual Studio team Services
also provide likes this same ability but
GitHub it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to GitHub and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment I'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact I think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on GitHub at the moment that
number is probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project I would certainly encourage you
to start at GitHub to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available and in GitHub
certainly if you're doing anything with
them Azure you'll find that there are
thousands 45
000 Azure projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough GitHub
was recently acquired by Microsoft and
Microsoft is fully embracing open source
Technologies so that's essentially the
difference between get and GitHub one is
a piece of software and that's get and
one is a service that supports the
ability of using the software and that's
GitHub so let's dig deeper into the
actual git architecture itself so the
working directory is the folder where
you are currently working on your get
project and we'll do a demo later on
where you can actually see how we can
actually simulate each of these steps so
you start off with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you add your files to a staging
area where you are getting ready to
commit your files back to the main
branch on your git project you want to
push out all your changes to a local
repository after you've made your
changes and these will commit those
files and get them ready for
synchronization with the service and
will then push your services out to the
remote repository an example of a remote
repository would be GitHub later when
you want to update your code before you
write any more code you would pull the
latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure that that Aid the code remains at
very high quality and B that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning in kit so both
of these terms are quite old terms when
it comes to government but forking is
certainly a term that goes way way back
long before we had distributed CVS
systems such as the ones that we're
using with get to Fork a piece of
software is a particularly open source
and project you would take the project
and create a copy of that project and
but then you would then associate a new
team and new people around that project
so it becomes a separate project in
entirety a clone and this is important
when it comes to working with get a
clone is identical with the same teams
and same structuring as the main project
itself so when you download the code
you're downloading exact copy of that
code with all the same security and
access rights as the main code and then
you can then check that code back in and
potentially your code because it is
identical could potentially become the
mainline code in the future now that
typically doesn't happen your changes
are the ones that merge into the main
branch but also but you do have that
potential where your code could become
the main code with Git You can also add
collaborators that can work on the
project which is essential for projects
where particularly where you have large
teams and this works really well when
you have product teams where the teams
themselves are self-empowered you can do
a concept what's called branching in git
and so say for instance you are working
on a new feature that new feature and
the main version of the project have to
still work simultaneously so what you
can do is you can create a branch of
your code so you can actually work on
the new feature whereas the rest of the
team continue to work on the main branch
of the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in Services software the team's
working on from a remote server and git
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and restart publish a new
start from the project so you may be
working a project where there have been
many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you're kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody that's working on a separate
Branch will not be able to Branch their
code back into the mainline Branch so
going through the process of a get
rebase essentially allows you to create
a new start for where you're working on
your project so let's go through forks
and clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and Fork
the code that you're working on so this
is a scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate Fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you actually go and you
can take take the version of the
mainline Branch but then you take it
completely offline into a local
repository for you to be able to work
from and you can take the mainline code
and you can then work on a local version
of the code separate from the mainland
Branch it's now a separate Fork
collaborators is the ability to have
team members working on a project
together so if you know if someone is
working on a piece of code and they see
some errors in the code that you've
created none of us are perfect at
writing code I know I've certainly made
errors in my code it's great to have
other team members that have your bag
and can come in and check and see what
they can do to improve the code so to do
that you have to then add them as a
collaborator now you do that in GitHub
you can give them permission within
GitHub itself that's really easy to do
supervisual interface that allows you to
do the work quickly and easily and
depending on the type of permissions you
want to give them sometimes it can be
very limited permissions it may be just
to be able to read the files sometimes
it's being able to go in and make all
the changes you can go through all the
different permission settings on GitHub
to actually see what you can do but
you'll be able to make changes so that
people can actually have access to your
repository and then you as a team can
then start working together on the same
code let's step through branching and
git so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature now this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that Branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master Branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master Branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have how are on the screen
showed various different commits that
have been made so we can keep track of
the master branch and then the branches
that have come off which have the new
features and there can be many branches
in git so git keeps you the new features
you're working on in separate branches
until you're ready to merge them back in
with the main branch so let's talk a
little bit about that merge process so
you're starting with the master branch
which is the blue line here and then
here we have a separate parallel branch
which has the new features so if we're
to look at this process the base commit
of feature B is the branch f is what's
going to merge back into the master
branch and it has to be said there can
be so many Divergent branches but
eventually you want to have everything
merge back into the master Branch let's
step through git rebase so again we have
a similar situation where we have a
Branch that's been worked in parallel to
the master branch and we want to do a
get rebase so we're at stage C and what
we've decided is that we want to reset
the project so that everything from here
on out with along the master branch is
the standard product however this means
that any work that's been done in
parallel as a separate Branch we'll be
adding in new features along this new
rebased environment now the benefit you
have by going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so get rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase it you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new Master Branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single Master Branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
this talk a little bit about pull from
remote Suppose there are two developers
working together on application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers they're always working on the
latest code so you could pull any
changes that you have made to your
thought remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that command in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some the commands
that we have in git so git and it
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive git adds one or more
files to your staging area get commit
Dash M commit message is a commit
changes the git command commits changes
to head up to the get command commits
changes to your local staging area get
status checks the status of your current
repository and lists the files you have
changed get log provides a list of all
the commits made on your current Branch
get diff views the changes that you've
made to the file so you can actually
have files next to each other you can
actually see the differences between the
two files get push origin Branch name so
the name of your branch command will
push the branch to the remote repository
so that others can use it this is what
you would do at the end of your project
git config Dash Global username will
tell get Who You Are by configuring the
author name we'll go through that in a
moment git config Global user email will
tell get the author of by the email ID
get clone creates a get repository copy
from a remote Source get remote ad
origin server connects the local
repository to the remote server and adds
the server to be able to push to it git
branch and then the branch name will
create a new Branch for you to create a
new feature that you may be working on
git checkout and then the branch name
will allow you to switch from one branch
to another Branch git merge Branch name
or merge a branch into the active Branch
so if you're working on a new feature
you're going to merge that into the main
branch a get rebate will reapply commits
on top of another base tip and get
rebase or reapply commit on top of
another base tip and these are just some
of the popular git commands there are
some more but you can certainly dig into
those as you're working through using
get so let's go ahead and run a demo
using get so now we are going to do a
demo using get on our local machine and
GitHub as the remote repository for this
to work I'm going to be using a couple
of tools first I'll have the deck open
as we've been using up to this point the
second is I'm going to have my terminal
window also available and let me bring
that over so you can actually see this
and the terminal window is actually
running git bash as the software in the
background which you'll need to download
and install you can also run get batch
locally on your Windows computer as well
and in addition I'll also have the
GitHub repository that we're using for
simply learn and already set up and
ready to go all right so let's get
started so the first thing we want to do
is create a local repository so let's go
ahead and do exactly that so the local
repository is going to reside in my
development folder that I have on my
local computer and for me to be able to
do that I need to create a drive in that
folder so I'm going to go ahead ahead
and change the directory so I'm actually
going to be in that folder before I
actually create make the new folder so
I'm going to go ahead and change
directory
and now I'm in the development directory
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and let's go ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
I'm going to move my cursor so that I'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that I'm in the hello world
folder I can now initialize this folder
as a git Repository
so I'm going to use the git command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my Hello
wall folder that I've created and you'll
now see that we have a hidden folder in
there which is called dot get and we
expand that we can actually see all of
the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so we can
see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users Matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt in our folder so
here is our hello world folder and I'm
going to go ahead and using my text
editor which happens to be Sublime
I'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there the text hello
world and I'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if I go to my Hello World folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt file
actually in the folder what's
interesting is if I select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and select
foreign
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the get status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders haven't been
committed and what we can now do is we
can go and actually add the readme file
so let's go ahead I'm just going to
select at git add so the git command is
ADD
[Music]
readme.txt so that then adds that file
into our main project and we want to
then commit those files into the main
repositories history and so it's that do
that we'll hit the the get command
commit and we'll do a message in that
commit and this one will be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and I can change this so we
can go hello get
get is a very popular
Version Control solution
and we'll
we'll save that now what we can do is we
can actually go and see if we have made
differences to the readme text so to do
that we'll use the diff command forget
so we do get
diff
and it gives us two releases the first
is what the original text was which is
hello world and then what we have
afterwards is what is now the new text
in green which has replaced the original
text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on GitHub we already have one so what
we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from GitHub with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do Dash and it's
going to be a
globaluser.name and we'll put in our
username that we use for GitHub and this
instance we're using the simply learn
Dash
GitHub account name
and under the GitHub account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we called the
repository hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local GitHub account with the remote
hello world.get account and we do that
by using this command from get which is
our remote connection and so let's go
ahead and type that in open this up so
we can see the whole thing so we can
type in git remote add origin https
GitHub
.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub and you have to get this
typed in correctly when you're typing in
the location hello dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit git push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote GitHub so I'm just
going to bring up my terminal window
again and so let's select get remote add
origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub slash
hello dash world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master gesh
so get
push origin
master and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to GitHub now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and Fork a project from GitHub and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the fork tool that's actually available
on GitHub let me show you where that is
located and here is our branching tool
it's actually changed more recently with
a new UI interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that to our account using
the forks new HTTP URL address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
Fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now I'm
actually logged in with the default
primary count for this project so I
can't actually Fork the project because
I'm working on the main branch however
if I come in with a separate ID and here
I am I have a different ID and so I'm
actually pretending I'm somebody else I
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
created the fork
so you want to say clone or download
with this and so this is the I select
they'll actually give me the web address
I can actually show you what that looks
like I'll open up my text editor
just that's the correct
I guess that is correct so I'm going to
copy that
and I can Fork the project locally and
clone it locally I can change the
directory so I can create a new
directory that I'm going to put my files
in and then post in that content into
that file so I can now actually have
multiple versions of the same code
running on my computer
I can then go into default content and
use the patchwork command
20 so I can create a copy of that code
that we've just created in the college
that's a clone and we can create a new
folder that we're actually putting the
work in and we could for whatever reason
we wanted to we could call this where
folder Patchwork and that would be maybe
a new feature and then we can then paste
in the URL of the new directory that has
the forked and work in it and now at
this point we've now pulled in and
created a clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
Fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in that separate
branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin Branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to GitHub and we
can actually come in and add in our
collaborators
and we'll do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
GitHub name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes and merge it into the
master Branch now to do that you would
create a folder and then that folder in
this instance would be called test we
would then move our cursor into the
folder called test and then initialize
that folder so let's go ahead and do
that so let's call create a new folder
and we're going to first of all change
our root folder and we're going to go to
development
and I'm going to create a new folder
call it test and we're going to move
into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
call this one test one
and then we're going to do file save as
and this one's gonna be test
two
and now we're going to commit those
files
add
kit add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git commit
m
M what else
is it
make sure I'm in the right folder here I
don't think I was
and now that I'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and get commit
and it's gone ahead and added those
files and so we can see the two files
that were created have been added into
the master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
Branch we call this one get branch
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file three
into file save as we'll call this one
test three dot text
and we'll go ahead and add
that file I need to get add
test three Dot txt
and we're going to move from the master
Branch to the test round branch
kit
check
out test underscore
branch
I switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the in that Branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do get merge test underscore
branch
as well we've already updated everything
so that's good so otherwise it would
tell us what we would be merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all my merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from Master Branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore branch
and we can modify the files the test3
file that we took out
and pull that file up
and we can
now modify
right
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in and we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and now
we've seen as the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
of the workers kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future so let's switch to it back to our
test branch
which I think we're actually on we're
going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
four
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into our
branch that we're working on so we're
going to go and select get add Dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit Dash a dash m
adding
2 new files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch them to our Master
Branch we want to rebase the master
so we could do git rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
and we can go
get
check out
Master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then continue
through and rebase the test branch and
then list all the files that are all in
the same area
so let's go get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files if you're ready to
embark on a career path pulsating with
excitement Innovation and Limitless
growth look no further than simply
landscape postgraduate program in devops
this comprehensive program equips you
with the Knowledge and Skills to
navigate the devops landscape with
confidence explore the depth of
continuous integration delivery and
conclude the entry cases of Automation
and orchestration fortify security like
a digital Fortress and a list of full
potential of cloud Technologies don't
let this once in a lifetime opportunity
slip away ignite your career and join
the ranks of prime Dev professionals
click the link in the description box to
enable the wonders of this course start
by downloading and installing it on a
system we'll then have a look at the git
bash interface we'll type in some basic
git commands next we'll create a local
repository that is we'll create a
repository and a local machine we'll
then connect to a remote repository and
finally we'll push the file onto GitHub
first things first we need to download
and install git so download git for
Windows and I'll select the second link
so 2.19.1 which is the most latest
version of Kit that's the one we want
for Windows system choose your version
so mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while so
git is finally downloaded now we need to
install this on our system
click here run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path uh just so just click on in
quick launch and on desktop next next
again next nothing to change here either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash so let's just tick that and then
click on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master Branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version and as you can see version
2.19.1 on our Windows system which is
exactly what we just downloaded we'll
now explore the help command so let's
just type get help config so config is
another command and as I hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it so in case you have
any doubts regarding how a command is
used what a command is used for all the
various syntax of the command you can
always use the help command now this
another Syntax for using the help
command itself which is git config dash
dash help enter this does the exact same
thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir test now test is my
new directory I'll move into this
directory so CD test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so get init is the command for
initializing the directory and as you
can see as you can see the path here
this is the local path where a directory
is created so I'll just show you the
directory test and it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and I'll
just name this demo I'll open this and
just put in some dummy content so hello
simply learn
save this file and go back to your bash
interface let's just check the status
now so git status and as you can see our
file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is
we'll be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we'll be
applying is the commit command and when
you add certain files to the current
directory the commit command is applied
on all the above directories so git
commit minus M and a message that will
appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion I'll just clear the
screen next thing we need to do is we
need to link our git to our GitHub
account so the command for doing that is
git config Global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
GitHub account
so this is my GitHub profile and my
username is simply learn Dash GitHub so
guys before you begin this procedure
just make a GitHub account type in my
username here simply learn Dash GitHub
and enter and there you go a git is
successfully linked with GitHub next
thing we do is we'll just open our
GitHub and we'll create a new repository
give a repository name so I'll get name
it test underscore demo and create
Repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and a
local Repository
so git remote origin and then paste
the HTTP link and now that our local
repository and a remote repository are
linked we can push a local file onto a
remote repository so the command for
doing that is git push origin Master as
we are on the master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to GitHub I'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo if you have any queries
regarding this please post them in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as possible I'm going to
cover a few essential git commands and
walk you through a demonstration for
most of it I begin by installing a git
bash or the git client and configuring
it for its first time usage once I'm
done with configuring the git client I'm
going to spin up few repositories
locally and work on these repositories
using git commands once I'm happy with
my local changes I'm going to commit few
of them and then push these changes to a
git server of my choice for today's
demonstration I plan to use github.com
which is a cloud hosted free service and
it provides free account registrations
for anyone eventually I will cover few
topics regarding git brand and merging
because these two in my opinion are the
killer features of the get distributed
Version Control tool kit is one of the
most popular distributed Version Control
tools of recent times and like any other
distributed Version Control tool it
allows us to perform various Version
Control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with Git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with Git is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like Windows
all flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a git server so for user one or one user
to share his repository with another
user he would need to collaborate using
something called as a git server so in
the present Market there are a bunch of
git servers which are popularly
available some of them are free some of
them come with a cost because they are
licensed a bunch of these servers that I
can think of are GitHub which is one of
the most popular git servers that is
around in the market for a long time now
it comes with two variants one is the
cloud hosted one which is the GitHub dot
com and then the other one is an
Enterprise server which comes as a black
box that can be installed into your data
centers so typically organizations who
don't want their source code to be put
up on the cloud but go for this GitHub
Enterprise servers wherein they buy this
servers and these servers are hosted on
their data centers other popular variant
of the git server is bitbucket this is
from the famous atlasian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a gitlab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and I'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that I'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
I will register Myself by using my
username or my email ID and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication so
in order for me to share my repository
with say user 2. the first thing that I
got to do is have an access to a git
server where both user 1 and user 2 are
set up so once I have that I can push my
repository onto this server and provide
right kind of access so that user 2 or
the other developer whoever wishes to
collaborate with me on this repository
can use his credentials as long as is
registered properly on the git server he
can use his credentials and pull down
this Repository 3 and work for this
repository so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as SSH authentication as many
of you would know SSH means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while when
creative keys I will be asked for a
passphrase I need to type in a
passphrase and remember by passphrase
and then I take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever I'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as I remember my passphrase correctly I
can authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and SSH are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fight up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my GitHub credential to
connect to my GitHub server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that I can go ahead
and install it so I just type in git
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that I
find is a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
client I need this one so this is a git
client or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I may want to
use git from Windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open SSH that's fine
next card next card no I don't want any
of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the version that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good it's a git help
all right a lot of GitHub commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen hyphen Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also a global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my get demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
getting to the syllable all right as of
now this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment okay so let me create a
repository out of this how do I create a
repository of this is pretty simple I
just run and get init command
when I say kit init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it was
an empty repository so it initially is
an empty repository in this particular
folder for all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder you hold repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say git in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
Branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with the
git in it and then I have not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository so I
use a touch command touch is a Linux
command it kind of creates this
particular folder if all you're not
comfortable with the file creation by
this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so I create a file called touch
master.txt I'll open up in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm going to write inside this
I save this and I come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this tell you there's no
commit set you're in the master Branch
there is an untracked file and this
shows up in thread it also gives you all
the command that is supposed to be run
so if at all you want to add this file
you would say git add and the name of
the file and then you're going to commit
it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git and I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
comment this file if at all that's what
I want to do so let me do that
I'll do a kit commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the git status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if a to error I run the git
log command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
foreign
so what I did I modified the older file
that existed I also added a new file to
my repository now if I run the get
status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if I do git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice
I'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server I
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things I can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way I want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I log into my GitHub account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get Hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and push it
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs one is the https
URL and the other one is the SSH URL as
of now we do not have any SSH keys that
is set up so let me use this https URL
to connect my local repository with the
repository on this server
so I've done all these things I already
have the repository set up all that I
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server URL
so this would be the command that I need
to copy
with essentially links or ads and origin
with the URL of the git server I just
copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I'm all set I've
got two comments in my repository I'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen U this is for
linking the Upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
a branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username and the password with which
I've registered
I would say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text fit all I see
the commits they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my comments in this commit
the files were added this was the line
that was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually committed the code in the
client the pushing is just after we've
committed the change we have pushed it
so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the SSH
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of SSH keys and ensuring
that I connect to the GitHub server
using the SSH mechanism so for doing
that I need to First create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is SSH Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I'm
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I would click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
check for my passphrase let me enter my
passphrase I hope I remember it
correctly
all right
triggered I have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I will
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
create a repository
So Random readme file with some content
in it gets created and I can see there
are two URLs to this repository https
and SSH so this time let me copy the SSH
URL so that I will use this URL to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first repository earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text
some text file I'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
I'm Gonna Save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with a message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
I given some particular message
and this time around since I clone my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more I'll
then push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it puts the content onto the server
let me see if the contents have come in
here okay wonderful I had only one
commit now I see my second comment so
what was added as a part of the second
comment it says a new file was added all
this line that never existed got added
this is the second file the content
exactly what I pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the change changes that has happened in
the repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
files that got added all this with one
particular message get status will give
you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the commit
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the URL of the
server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however my perspective
of Version Control tool you will have to
be really cautious about the chain that
you're gonna do in case the changes are
pretty local none of the developers or
none of the other users who are
collaborating with you would be affected
by this change you're good to go ahead
and make this change however if your
repository has been pushed to the server
and you're trying to modify something
from history this would have a very bad
or adverse effect on all the other users
who will be using it you need to be
really cautious while running these
commands in case your repository
contents are local if you've not pushed
your changes to your repository and if
at all you made some changes to the
repository maybe to fix a defect or to
include a new feature and you missed few
things you can go ahead and modify this
with some of these commands let's say I
have this simple repository called undo
undo repo and if at all I look at the
logs of these I have the commit
histories which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I added the file in C3 I've
also added some file in C4 I made some
changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I have
added another file called M4 now this is
my commit history now let's say I made
these two commits but possibly I want to
Club them together along with some other
changes because whatever changes I did
did not really fix things the way I
expected you to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two comments would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the comment that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is 7 C2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to C5 it's gone back
to C3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of C4 and C5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of C4 was
some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a new
file got M4 got added if at all I do a
git status
you would see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the topmost comment
that exists as of now c4 and C5 have
been currently read off but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say one new file that was missed out
I make this change I go to a get status
all these files are still there I will
send it add dot I also get
m
C4
rewriting history
and I do a git
log
pretty
there you go so C1 C2 C3 still existed
and whatever was a part of C4 and C5 the
older ones I have gotten rid of this
along with those old changes I also
added a new file I made some changes and
it was able to comment it now if you
look at my git history it's all nice and
clean however do this activity only when
you don't push your git repository to
the server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and is not being pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a git server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so here's got C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the C3 which is a wrong thing to do
and possibly you know he could have done
a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
comment to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this commit
possibly gets rid of C3 instead of going
back in history it actually is taking
your git history ahead but as a part of
this commit you are undoing some part of
the work that was done as a part of C3
in short you're removing a comment but
to remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are your losing this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C to our
another file in C3 I've added one more
file and in C4 I made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all I see the
contents of the git folder it contains
M1 m2m3 and M4 and let's say looking at
the previous use case that I mentioned I
may want to get rid of this particular
comment
I want to get rid of the C3 which is
nothing but I've added a file called M3
dot text but I added it by mistake I
need a better way of fixing it possibly
I look at it later on but for now I
don't want this particular commit and
the changes that were made as a part of
that commit to exist so the better way
to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert and the comment ID
whatever I want to revert so if I want
to revert this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit reward at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
face this
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit It undoes
Whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention a message
which is why this window is showing up
but that message is good for me I say
write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
M3 was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into very very interesting topic
regarding git which is about branching
the topic is interesting because git
deals with branches in a completely
different way compared to any other
version control tool in most of the
Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
Git You just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right I'm navigating to this folder
and let me create a repository here I
initial as a repository a DOT get folder
is created without any files in it so
let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees dot text
plan on
has over 3K employees
I just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
first comment
so if I do a git log
I see only one commit and there are two
files here you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
and this created a branch but I don't
see any changes in the folder structure
or in the file that exists here I've
just created this Branch so if at all I
do a git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and blr
Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
blr Branch I've actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because I've
created a branch from my base branch
which is the master branch and when I
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to Bangalore branch
so I will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I see
notepad address dot text
I'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in
some arteries
I would say Bangalore
that is the content of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I would sync it add
Dot and I would say kit
commit hyphen m
angalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now I have an
address dot text which is there only in
the Bangalore branch that I'm presently
on now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout Master Branch if you remember
when I forged out or when I created a
new Branch from the master Branch I
didn't have this address dot text in it
so let me go back to git git checkout
Master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you're in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears so this particular file is only
present in the branch and git is playing
around with the file system snapshot by
moving the pointers across and ensuring
that whenever I am switching to
Bangalore Branch I see this address dot
text when I go back to my master Branch
I don't say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise so the name of the
folder needs to be exactly this one so
let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository
get Brand's demo this is what I'm going
to put in as a description I would say
public I don't want any readme files in
it because I already have a repository I
will just say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is the SSH URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it to you
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master plan so I
would say git push hyphen U origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says new Bunch Master is created so if I
go back to my server and it will refresh
if you see it is only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if we get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if at all
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this under stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the brands that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangle Branch to come back into
my master Branch so if I go to click
checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address DOT
type this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge the Bangalore
Branch changes and where will it merge
it will merge it into the current brands
that I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
will see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
foreign
branch that we had earlier which had
only one commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the Bangalore Branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I'm in two branches
apprentice's Master even if I'm in
master plans I should see this address
dot text that is there even if I'm in
the Bangalore Branch the content is all
same because we immersed these two
branches now that I've merged this
Branch I don't need this Branch anymore
so I would go ahead and delete this
locally as well as push it onto the
server so that it gets deleted from the
server as well so delete Branch locally
the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say get brands and I'm presently
in the master Branch so I can go ahead
and delete the other Branch so git
Branch hyphen D Bangalore branch
all right this got rid of our Pandora
Branch locally
if at all I don't get Branch hyphen V it
shows there's only one branch as of now
however this Branch would still exist on
the server because Server doesn't know
anything about the changes that we have
done we need to specifically push our
changes onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen hyphen delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in it go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new Branch
you issue a command git Branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
Branch from the existing Branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git Branch new underscore
Branch it creates a new underscore
Branch from the master Branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this Branch you would type in git check
out the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific Branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen U origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new Branch are pushed
onto this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git Branch hyphen AV assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master Branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
Branch into a master Branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you are on the master branch and
if you issue a command get more launch
new underscore Branch this would merge
the contents of the new Branch onto the
master Branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this Branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is git Branch
hyphen capital D and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this Branch from the server
the command to do that is git push
origin hyphen iPhone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
brands that you created on the server if
you're ready to embark on a career path
pulsating with excitement Innovation and
Limitless growth look no further than
simply landscape postgraduate program in
devops this comprehensive program equips
you with the Knowledge and Skills to
navigate the devops landscape with
confidence explore the depth of
continuous integration delivery and
convert the entry cases of Automation
and orchestration fortify security like
a digital Fortress and unleash the full
potential of cloud Technologies don't
let this once in a lifetime opportunity
slip away ignite your career and join
the ranks of prime Dev professionals
click the link in the description box to
unveil the wonders of this course now we
will be talking about that how exactly
we can make use of Maven here in
performing various kind of operations
whether it's a burial compilation with
this kind of stuff there so let's talk
about it why exactly we use Maven here
now Maven is something which is a kind
of a build tool which is there for most
of the job-based projects here so this
tool also helps us in building up the
source code by downloading some couple
of dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that the project is dependent on and he
requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a jar based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement of that project so it
simplifies the day-to-day work of a Java
developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now uh Maven also helps us in
getting the uh specific jar files for
each and every project so if you are
going you can pretty much make a jar
file bar file or your file any kind of a
package mechanism you can follow for
your Maven there so to download the
dependencies we don't have to actually
go to the official website of each and
every software you can easily get it uh
the dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnrepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific uh project over here so it
totally depends on how exactly you want
to download and you want to get together
a specific repository over here so mvin
repository.com is the one if you visit
you will be able to download and go
through all the jar files dependent jar
files as independencies which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is on Maven
all about so let's see on that part so
Maven is a popular open source Bell tool
which is uh developed by the Apache
group and the primary ownership of this
tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once Maven is
written in Java and it can be used to
build projects written in c-sharp Scala
Ruby Etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a jar
based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a Java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build perspective tasks
on the projects
right now Maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as in
Project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take care of all the following same
builds dependencies reports distribution
releases mailing list so all these uh
things are being taken care as in this
particular process here and ultimately
it's an availability inside the maven
that how the overall build process needs
to be automated and standardized here so
all these particular mechanisms is can
be followed as such over here so that we
can have a good standards and the
simplifications implemented as such here
now what exactly is an Maven repository
all about
so Maven repository is something which
is uh kind of a directory or it's kind
of a location where we have all the jar
files packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
Java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the pump files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows Maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositives from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for our specific Maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right now the local repository will be
primary present onto your PC that's the
way that how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it on till the internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is safe so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and Central repository is refers to the
maven rip Community repository there
where you will be able to see each and
and every dependency present on that
repository so Maven downloads the
repositories from here in the local
repository whenever they're needed or
whenever required all these dependencies
are cached locally from where it will be
referenced in the next or you know
whenever we want to refer that we will
be able to do that particular reference
easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or miemann
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
foreign
now what are the basic concepts of Maven
here so some of the couple of basic
concepts which is present in Maven is
like for the first time we have the
project object model so project Palm
reference to the XML file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this XML file in this particular form
reference file as such over here the XML
file is which is there in the project
home directory so Maven is something
which search for the pump file in the
current directory if it's able to find
that particular pump file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise the it will hold
there itself so this powerful is very
important because it will act as some
kind of a build script and primarily the
maven tool will be able to process each
and everything which is configured as
such in this specific XML file there and
according to that only it will function
or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
jar files so the Java libraries which we
need in our into our particular project
so while working on the project we may
be having the dependency on couple of
dependencies so these dependencies we
have to actually download or we have to
actually refer and once this is a
particular information or these details
are referred so what will happen that uh
we need to download these uh specific
dependencies from the particular Maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then Maven will try to download it from
the central repository and cache it into
your local repository but first of all
it will look on into the local
repository and if it is not present in
local then only it will go to the remote
or the central Repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to performing the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugin cm
then we have the build profile so build
profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven's build script
here
then with different uh build profiles
are added to the pump files and which
enables the different uh build as such
here so depending on these profiles we
can actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build order
missions needs to be performed here then
a build profile helps in customizing the
build for the different environments so
that also we can perform as such while
work forming or while working on the
different components and the different
management here so a build profile is
something which you can configure you
can utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to design on that
particular Factor so these are something
which we need to take here or we need to
work according to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here
now usually when we go for the uh Maven
there so we have to use some couple of
Maven plugins now the goal of using
these uh specific plugins is to automate
some of the basic stuff like compilation
creating the bar file creating the jar
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so Maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh we know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and you
can pretty much have some specific goals
executed with the help of these build
plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in Maven what happens that uh we
let's talk about the basic architecture
of Maven here so the maven executable
when it's deployed so it usually uh
reads the palm.xml file which is the
build script here now once the specific
bounded XML file is being read out so it
will process the components it will uh
you know download or it will process the
dependencies plugins life cycles phases
and goals and even the build profiles
and uh if any kind of interaction is
required so it will try to connect to
the central repository or remote
repository and according to that it will
provide the information and provide the
details as such so mu 1 repository is
something which is very important
because it's ultimately trying to
connect to the maven repository and try
to achieve the various kind of
automation here so it's very important
because ultimately it's trying to help
us to go for the complete end-to-end
build automation when we'll go for a
specific Palm based build automation
so um even is able to read the palm.xml
file then download the dependencies
defined into the power XML file and that
dependencies are cached locally from the
remote or the central repository now
then create and generate a remote a
report according to the requirement and
execute the life cycles phases goals
plugins
Etc so it will process the power XML
file then and whatever the plugins and
goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build
lifecycle is something which is a kind
of a collection of different steps there
and this is something which is followed
uh to perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the bevel level which
you can utilize to perform a various
kind of particular steps execution for
your project
right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds these are the different phases
and these stages which we normally
follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific Maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of Maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of benefits the first
one is that Apache Mi one helps manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation releasing and distribution
in project management here so the tool
simplifies the process of project
building it increases the performance of
the project and the building process all
together and the task of downloading jar
files and other dependencies is also
done automatically we don't have to
indulge in any kind of download part as
such manually over here
right and Maven provides easy access to
all the required information so Maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the particular or built onto this
Jenkins or any kind of build tool there
right in Maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the specific palm.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair right so let's talk
about the demo now so let's see that how
exactly we can go for this demo and we
can perform the various kind of
automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so Maven will be available as in 3.6.3
here now I'm going to run a particular
command called mvn archetype generate
here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
type
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will download some
of the buy entities there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so couple
of a particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
which kind of version we want to follow
so I'm going to follow like five here so
I'll press five
then a group ID which is there so it's
basically a kind of a group mechanism so
I can say like com dot simply learn so
that's a value which I'm providing here
artifact ID I can make it like a sample
project or something like that I can do
so that will be the artifact uh ID which
is there so version I'm keeping the same
only so and uh yeah so package same here
so I just want to create so I'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that our
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact ID you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the pound.xml
file now this palm.xm file when I open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group ID
you want to follow so this is a group ID
this is the artifact ID so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the J unit dependencies added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular Maven project a
power.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the Target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of Jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the Target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo in which we
have find out that how exactly we can go
for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable so
that's it for this demo things
right so that was the demo in which we
uh saw that how exactly we can go for
the maven and uh we can execute some
build uh process related to Maven there
so this is the Mac system which we have
here now in this one what we are going
to do is that we are going to open the
terminal so we are going to open a
terminal here so this is my terminal so
usually in Mac uh you don't require any
other mechanisms so the inbuilt terminal
is more than sufficient for doing this
stuff because it's similar to a Linux
based platform here so I'm going to run
the command here so first of all I'll
just double check that if my Brio
executable is working fine so I'll just
run the Brew help command to see that if
my Brew is working fine as such over
here in this one now I have the command
called preview install so that is the
command which we need to use now in this
one we have to actually give the
specific package which we want to
install so we will say like Brew install
maven
so it will download the uh specific
execute tables on the system
from the website it will download the
maven executables so it will take some
time but ultimately it's trying to
download it under the particular tar
file so you can see here that it's
downloading a 3.6.3 tar file over here
so uh I can see that the installation is
done so the 3.6.3 version should be
installed over here so when I do like
Maven uh mvn under hyphen iPhone version
over here so you can see that the
3.6.3 version is deployed as such over
here now this is something which is done
with the purely command over here called
Brew which really helps us to do any
kind of package installations not only
Maven other packages also can be
installed pretty much with the help of
this executable now in order to see the
manual stuff what we really need to do
is that we need to actually clean this
uh specific installation so that I
should I will be able to show you the
manual installation also over here so
what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to run the command called
Brew uninstall Maven so that the maven
should be removed from your system so we
are just trying to remove the maven from
here and uh you can see that the maven
executable is not working as such over
here so which means that the maven is
uninstalled in this case but why I have
uninstalled here so that I should be
able to go ahead and download some
custom Maven over here in this one so I
have opened the browser here so I'll go
for the maven executable so we'll go for
Maven download so that we should be able
to download a specific the executable
here so I'm going for this directory so
here uh 3.6.3 version same is available
here so I'm going to download the bin.z
which was the file we have so this is
also a kind of a Linux platform right so
that's the reason why uh here the tar
file should work perfectly fine so here
I'm going to the opt directory where we
can have all the optionals related
packages so if it is not there so I can
create a directory called slash opt
so I can log in with
root
so if you don't have the root access so
you can go for the applications in the
applications you can actually create a
directory called maven so here I can go
for me one
yeah
so here we will be downloading the VAR
file here so the tar.gunjab file we are
downloading over here so I'll give the
path here so once the war file or
duplicate command I am using to do the
installation but sometimes the W gate is
not available so I can go for the Brew
install wget also if that package is
available on preview the installation
will be done so we'll try to do the
installation using replicate so that we
will be able to get a tar file generated
or downloaded there are other ways also
you can download it from the browser
also yeah you can go to the browser and
here you can actually click and download
it and then you can transfer it locally
to this specific directory also so both
the possibilities are there but I'm just
trying to download the wget command so
that it will be easy for me to do the
setup and to do the download over here
so I'm going to run the same command
again
so it will download the tar file so this
is the tar file which is available over
here so I'm going to extract it over
here
so once the extraction is done so I'm
going to rename it like to Apache maven
so that I should not have any kind of
versioning or these kind of parameters
over here and the Apache dot uh Maven
hyphen the star file I'm trying to
remove as such over here so this is what
I have got as an end result over here
now this is the current directory in
which I have these uh applications and
these setups going forward over here so
if I run the mvn hyphen iPhone version
command
so that will not be giving me any kind
of output over here because uh still I
have extracted the tar file but that is
not the activity is not complete I have
to exactly set up some environment
variables so that I should be able to
run this mvn command so what I really
need to do over here is that we have to
export certain variables
application slash me one
Apache M1 so this is the home directory
which I am trying to configure over here
and then next thing is that path
variable so I'm going to have we are
going to coordinate the path variable
with the folder so I'm going to have the
folder structure here so the bin
directory we have to provide so I'm
going to copy here and paste and then
I'm concatenate it with the bin here so
now my environment variables are
established so my mvn hyphen iPhone
version command as you can see here is
that uh you know it's being picked up
over here but it's saying that the
particular Java runtime is not available
so I can go for Java Brew install Java
so that should be enough there to
install a Java package there so you can
see that it says that it's already
installed so and up to date so that's
the reason why it's not able to do the
installation so I'm going to reinstall
open jdk
because what happens that when we do the
installation some environment variables
related Java should be formatted or
should be extracted over here right so
as you can see that uh here it's saying
that if you want to really use the
executable of java you have to
concatenate the path like this so let's
run that and then we can see that the
particular executable of java will also
be
find out over here so Java hyphen
version showing that yes it's available
there and now my command
should be able to show me that yes it's
working fine the GDK was already
installed but the problem with that is
that since it's installed into a
particular location so you have to
actually override your path value so
that you should be able to see in that
directory and find out the Java
executable so that I have got by doing
the installation I got the command over
there in the output saying that this is
the installation which is done and now
you just have to extract or you have to
just you know put that bar directory
into the specified path variable and
that's how you got the maven and Java
both command lines working over here so
this is how you will be doing the maven
installations all together how the
overall installation of Maven and the
jdk really works on Mac operating system
right so before even going for Maven we
have to install the jdk onto our Windows
machine so that we can proceed with
Maven because Maven requires the jdk
installations to be there now there are
two ways of jdeck installation either
you go for the exe file or you gonna
extract the binaries of jdka to a
directory and then set up the Java
underscore home path for that but if you
are using the azq table that will
perform the path configurations for you
also so in that case you don't have to
reconfigure it again and again so that's
what we are going to see here so first
of all we will try to do the
installation of jdk so for that we'll go
to the website of jdk and then we have
to click on this one to access the maven
installations part here so that's what
we are going to do so let's proceed and
let's open the Chrome and try to go
through these two URLs so that we can do
the installations one by one
so here I have to just search for jdk8
download so it will show me the URL for
oracle.com so here you will get the jdk
for the different platforms for
different operating systems now here
what you can see here that you have the
configurations in which you have the jdk
installation so we have to so here I'll
go for the windows 64 version because
that is something I will be using to do
the installation so this is the complete
executable link so here you can download
so we are downloading the sdka
u251 so just search for Windows 64 yeah
this is the one so let me click on this
one
let me quickly log into the web page so
once the login is done you will be able
to see that it's trying to download the
exe file so that was for the jdk for the
Java now for the May one I am going to
go for the maven download over here so
in this one the maven repo link is there
maven.apache.org is the link for this
one now here we have the different
options you can see here that the binary
Ziploc archive is there then so save
archive is there so depending on the
installation which you want to perform
you should be able to download that file
and it works there so let's first
install the jdk portion and then we'll
go with this one
so we'll click on this one also anyways
because uh it's something we have to or
anyways do it so we'll click on this so
that uh this Maven is also getting
started install downloading over here so
once both of them are downloaded we will
proceed further with the setup so let's
wait for another one minute to do this
one
so the Apache movement is kind of uh
downloaded over here so we wait for the
jdk download also over here so next 5-10
seconds only left out
so first jdk will be there and then
Maven installation configurations will
be there so for Maven we just have to
extract into a directory and give the MV
in-home path into the uh properties uh
into the variables so that it can pick
it up over there okay so we have to
extract the zip file for Maven give the
path and then we will travel check with
the maven command whether it's working
fine or not so let's try to install the
executive so we'll open the directory
where the executables are there so first
of all we'll install the jdk so we'll
double click the installer for jdk it's
of around 200 MB so the complete jdk
will be installed so we have to just go
for next now when you go with the
installer so usually the Java home paths
and all that stuff is already configured
so you don't really have to change the
passwords or Java home any kind of
variable you have to put it up all those
things will be automatically cleaned up
so it's running the installation
close so then we have to extract the
maven so we have to extract this
directory because here the maven
complete executables and libraries are
there so we just have to extract it and
place into a directory so that we can
further on use it and access the path so
once the axis is done yep so this is
done there so I can rename it to like
miven so I can rename it like to ask me
one and I can cut it down and put it
into the C drive here now this is the
maven Home Path which is going to be
there right so all I have to do is that
I have to close this one and this one
and this one and this so what we have to
do is that we have to really go to the
system properties so that we can extract
it so I'm going to open the system
properties over here
properties now here the advanced system
settings now in this one we will be
setting up the paths so environment
variable will go now here if you scroll
down you will see all the different
parts which is available there as such
over here now if we want to see that if
the Java is fine or we require for jdk
also so all we have to do is that we
have to open the CMD prompt window R we
are providing so using the window R I'm
opening the Run window where I can say
like CMD now in this CMD I'm going to
say like Java
hyphen version so Java is there so which
means that we don't have any problem as
such now I'll just go here and set up a
new one called mvn underscore home so
here the same path so you can browse for
directory also but I am using the
ambient home over here in this one
now I have just added that and in the
path variable in the last we have to
actually add the
bin directory also so that uh whenever
we run the mvn command so that should
also be resolved so mvn underscore home
is not the only variable which you will
be configuring in fact you will be
configuring the path variable also that
you can go ahead and put up a new
directory entry for the CMD here so CMD
tell the CMD directory you will go there
and whatever the executable is there you
should be able to resolve that so for
that again you have to open the window R
CMD prompt Java hyphen version and then
you can run mvn hyphen version here when
you run The mvn Hyphen version it will
let you know that which particular Java
runtime you are using
1.8.0 underscore 251 that's the same one
which we have configured and it also let
us know that where exactly the
executable is there and we can now
proceed further with the execution of
the maven build so you just have to
check out your source code or go to the
directory where source code is there and
you can run the ambient clean install so
that will ultimately go for the build
process so this is the way that how we
can do the installation of Maven on the
Windows platform now since this is done
now we will go ahead with the second
installation where we are going to do
the installation of Maven and jdk onto
the Ubuntu machine so for that we will
log into the particular Cloud lab of
Simply learn in LMS so let's log into
the LMS here so now we are going to do
the installation of jdk and Maven on the
Ubuntu virtual machine here so for that
we will log into the LMS so let's log
into that so this is the uh LMS over
here here I have already started the lab
here so all I have to do is that I have
to just click on this link here so it
will open the lab into a new tab it's a
GUI mode of Ubuntu Server so which we
will be using to configure it so uh here
uh first of all I can open the Chrome
browser also so let me open the browser
here so that I can download the maven
executables as such over here so GDK we
can do it using the package installation
so uh using the APT executable we will
be doing the installation so I have to
just open the terminal here so once the
terminal is opened you have to login
through the root ID now why we require
root ID so that we should be able to do
the package installations and other
configurations so that requires root
access
now once that is done you have to run
the particular app update command next
you have to install the installer so the
Oracle installer we have to install now
uh once the setup is done so let's down
install the latest package over here for
iCal Oracle hyphen Java 14 hyphen
installation so this will install the
jdk 14 over here so for that
configurations now at the same time
we'll go for Maven download also
so here uh we'll go for download me even
so this is the tar file for executable
so I'm going to copy this URL here
and over here we'll say yes yes
so now uh the Java should be configured
and could should be set up over here in
this one so what we really need to do is
that we need to run the Java command to
see that if the installation is done
properly or not so uh let's open the
terminal again another terminal so that
I can perform these steps related to
maven so I have got the URL so I'm going
to the opt directory which is always a
optional directory where we can do the
setup and all those configurations
so I'm going to run the W gate command
and then the URL which I have downloaded
so this should uh download the tar file
over here of Maven now once that is done
so I have to extract it so uh tar hyphen
x v z f and the tar file name this is a
target zip file so I have to use tar
hyphen XP ZF parameter over here to
extract it now uh what exactly I have
got I have got the Apache Maven
directory over here so I'm going to
rename it in order to rename it what we
need to do we need to actually go for uh
the particular move command so move
whatever the existing folder you have
and then I'm going to rename it with the
maven directory now once that is done I
am going to the maven directory and this
is the path or Maven underscore Home
Path which is available as such over
here in this one so here all the bin
directories executables all this stuff
is there so now I can use it like mvn
underscore home and the same
configuration just like we did in the
window so here also it the same process
we have to follow so Java hyphen version
should be let me know that which version
is deployed so 14.01 version is deployed
over here so for Java i.net don't have
to set up the path again here because I
am viewing for the installer so I don't
have to set up the path
right so for Maven now what exactly I
have to do I have to go to the ETC
profile D now here I am going to put up
a particular file now here you can see
that we have the jdk file here which
means that uh the path variables and
everything is configured as such over
here so you can see that Java underscore
Home Path all these variables are copied
here so I'm going to also create a same
file similar to this one here but in
this case what I'm going to use it that
I am going to remove some of the values
so I'm going to have some of the
parameters added so in order to do it
effectively I can do the Eco command so
that I can copy the things from here and
I can simply put it up into the file
here so I'm going to have the path
variable added up over here now why I'm
putting up the paths because it's the
same configuration which we did over
there also so opt slash May 1
slash pin so all the bin directory
should be added to the specific path
variable so I'm just trying to create a
file called maven.sh just like a jdk DOT
sh over here I'm also creating similar
kind of file over here called maven.sh
now I'm not going in the vi mode or
other editors because I just want to
make you understand that how I am
copying it the content I'm taking the
jdk.sh as in reference and putting up
the details over here in this one and
then I'm going to export mvn underscore
home over here which is related to like
opt
slash
Maven so this is what we are going to
put up over here and then Maven in the
end Maven this is the file which you
should be having now why we are using it
because of the fact that it's being used
or it will be utilized in such a way
that you can perform the changes or
whatever configurations you want to
perform this will help you to set up the
certain parts like a path and ambient
home so that you can run these scripts
as such over here so I'm going to give
the executable permissions to this one
and that's it so now what exactly I have
to do is that I have to do the source
here
profile
dot d maven once that is done I will be
able to run the mvn hyphen version over
here and the jdk part is already open so
it's going to refer to that part so this
is the way that how we configure the
maven and the jdk specifically on the
Ubuntu virtual machine so pretty much
that's it for this demo in this demo we
probably talked about it how we can do
the installation of Jade again Maven on
Windows and how we can do the similar
task on the maven on the Ubuntu virtual
machine also here introduction let's get
into what all will be covered as a part
of this tutorial I will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing Jenkins post which I will go
ahead and install Jenkins on a Windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well so once
I have Jenkins installed and configured
properly I will get into the user
administrative part I'll create few
users and I will use some plugins for
setting up various kinds of access
permissions for this users I will also
put in some freestyle jobs freestyle job
is nothing but a very very simple job
and I will also show you the
powerfulness of Jenkins by scheduling
this particular job to run based upon
time schedule I will also connect
Jenkins with GitHub GitHub is our source
code where source code repository where
I've got some repositories put up there
so using Jenkins I will connect to
GitHub pull up a repository that is
existing on GitHub onto the Jenkins box
and run few commands to build this
particular repository that is pulled
from GitHub sending out emails is a very
very important configurations of Jenkins
or any other continuous integration
server for that matter Whenever there is
any notifications that has to be sent
out as a part of either a build going
bad or build being good or building
propagate to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contents integration servers to be
sending out notifications so I will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure Jenkins for sending out emails
I will also get into a scenario where I
will have a web application a
maven-based Java web application which
will be pulled from a GitHub repository
and I will deploy it onto a tomcat
server the Tomcat server will be locally
running on my system eventually I will
get into one other very very important
topic which is the Master Slave
configuration it's a very very important
and pretty interesting topic where
distributed builds is achieved using a
Master Slave configuration so I will
bring up a slave I will connect the
slave with the master and I'll also put
in a job and kind of delegate that
particular job to the slave
configuration finally I will let you
know how to use some plugins to backup
your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a lot of
useful information set up on it in terms
of the build environments in terms of
workspace all this can be very very
easily backed up using a plugin so this
is what I'm going to be covering as a
part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is used usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic War file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt if it
earlier on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a Ctrl C
and then bring down this prompt and your
Jenkins server would be down other older
versions of Jenkins were run popularly
using this way in which you already have
a Java based web server running up and
running so you kind of drop in this war
file into the root folder or the httpd
root folder of your web server so
Jenkins would explode and kind of bring
up your application all user credentials
or user Administration is all taken care
of by the Apache or the Tomcat server or
the web server on which Jenkins is
running this was a very older way of
running but still some people use it
because if they don't want to maintain
two servers if they already have a Java
web server which it's being nicely
maintained and backed up Jenkins can run
attached to it all right so either ways
it doesn't matter however you're going
to bring up your Jenkins instance the
way we're going to operate Jenkins is
all going to be very very same or
similar one with the subtle changes in
terms of user Administration if at all
you're launching it through any other
web server which will take care of the
user Administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration or
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is run in
Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source toolsets
when you install jdk ensure that you set
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to jdk but for
any other open source tools that you've
installed there is always a preferred
environment variable that you got to set
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you are going to use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open source projects
because the way open source projects
discover themselves is using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or a good practice always set
this environment variables accordingly
so I already have jdk 1.8 installed on
my system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so
I'm not going to do the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I've just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run Java
or Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java iPhone version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am going to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch inkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file with a generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start uh Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into C colon program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or even Jenkins installations to
get into some specific directories go
ahead and set this Jenkins home variable
accordingly before you even begin your
installation for now I don't need to do
any of these things so I've already
downloaded the installer let me just go
ahead with the default installation all
right so this is my Jenkins MSI
installer I would just I don't want to
make any changes in into the Jenkins
configuration C colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with this I don't want to change
this I would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default Jenkins Launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not great it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugin that is
required for Jenkins in order to run
properly so Jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you this is a
good combination to kind of begin with
and mind you at this moment Jenkins
needs lots of bandwidth in terms of
network so in case your you know your
network is not so good few of these
plugins would kind of fail and these
plugins are all you know all available
on openly or or mirrored sites and
sometimes some of them may be down so do
not worry in case some of these plugins
kind of fail to install you'll get an
option to kind of retry installing them
but just ensure that you know at least
most or 1995 of all these plugins are
installed without any problems let me
pause the video here for a minute and
then get back once all these plugins are
installed my plugin installation is all
good there was no failures in any of my
plugins so after that I get to create
this first admin user again this is one
important point that you got to remember
Keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and um an email ID is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case I don't so I just
given an admin and I get a password I've
got I remember my password this is my
full name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all your Java
guy you know how painful it is to write
UI in Java you will kind of appreciate
you know all the effort that has gone
into the UI bottom line you always
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough in case at any
point in time if there are multiple jobs
that kind of get triggered the same time
in case the number of executors are less
compared to the number of jobs that have
that woken up no need to panic because
they will all get queued up and
eventually Jenkins will get to running
those jobs just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of you know gets
triggered the CPU usage and the memory
usage in terms of the disk right is very
high on the Jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options have got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email ID
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test mail with
the configuration that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool says that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just give
you an example in case your source code
is a Java source code and assuming that
you know because in this a demo this is
my laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install GDK on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command Dash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
Jenkins runs it will not be able to find
these tools for building your task and
it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
managing games let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
with hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I will just say
you know first job this is good for me I
just give a name for my job I would say
it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once I save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you would see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
let's see freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
should be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me do you
really mean every minute oh yeah I want
to do this every minute let me save this
and how do I check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not I just
don't do anything I'll just wait for a
minute and if at all everything goes
well Jenkins will automatically trigger
my second job in a minute's time from
now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific role I can
have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into manage Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for it to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I have
installed the role based access plugin I
would need to just set it up and check
that you know I would go ahead and
create some roles and ensure that I
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configured configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options you can click
hover over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these uh you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
I'll check you know have read only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
managing cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer one to this
particular Global rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and this permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that had set in let me
quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
big bucket is one of the git servers has
so many plugins that is available okay
so bottom line Jenkins without plugins
is nothing so plugins is the heart of
Jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect Jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got Java and Maven
you would need to install Maven and GDK
on your Jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build and build a
job on Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube
and get sonar Cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in Jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello to Java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
Java file how do I build my Java file
how do I compile my Java file I just say
Java C and the name of my class file
which is hello.java and how do I run my
Java file I would say Java and hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here this is a git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would show up
because the plugin is already there SVN
perforce any of those additional source
code management tools if at all you
would need just install those plugins
and Jenkins connects wonderfully well to
all these particular Source control
tools okay so I would copy the https URL
from here I would say this is the URL
that I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but
alright that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I going to do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order for
me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay get job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system or
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it'll compile it will based
upon the goals that you specify it can
compile it can run some tests and it can
you can build a war file and even deploy
it into some other server for now what
we're going to use Maven is just for
building and creating a package out of
this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server and then you
can freely download I'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the Tomcat all right so download Maven
first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this my one there is
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know I'm having again is
is a one open source build tool so
you'll have to set in a few
configurations and set up the path so
mvn hyphen iPhone version if I specify
this after I set in my path my one
should work and if at all I Echo M2 home
which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my own
it is already set here so once you unzip
my oven just set this M2 home variable
to the directory where you unzip your my
one also just set the path to this
particular directory slash bin because
that is where your Maven executables are
all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I just
verified it okay next one is the Tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this way you download Tomcat server and
um I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let Tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port Clash
so what I've done I have configured
Tomcat to use a different port so if I
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloy
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go tomcatel is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
mbn
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of Market repository is
uh this guy https URL
okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this Warfare was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I will see this web application War file
that is already built so I would need to
configure this plugin to pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the Tomcat
server for deploying onto the Tomcat
server I will use the credentials of the
user that I've created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that my Tomcat server yes
configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so take the war file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
MN web app use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was in my web app so if
I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you are heavily
reliant on the Jenkins server you don't
want your Jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
Distributing the load that is there on
the Jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some of the machines or some other
sleeves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows you know Windows based.net kind
of a projects where you would need a
Windows machine to build this particular
project you also have a requirement
where you want to build Linux the next
based are systems you also have a Mac
you you support some sort of an apps or
something that is built on Mac OS you
would need to build you know Mac based
system as well so how are you going to
support all these needs so that's
wherein a beautiful concept of Master
Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that he got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I'll set up
a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guide so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I make him random I make
him you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or I made a
setting for the master so that the jnlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so I go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server and Jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to a Jenkins master so I would
say new node I would give a name for my
node I would say windows node because
both of these are windows only so that's
fine I'll just give an identifier saying
that Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86.
C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run it from here so this is the
directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they're allowed to specify this
particular label so imagine this way if
I have a bunch of Windows my system I
name it as Windows star anything that
says from Windows I can give a regular
expression and say that anything that
matches Windows run this particular task
there if I have some MAC machines I name
all these Mac agents as Mac star or
something like that and I can delegate
all tasks you know saying that start
with whatever starts with mac and this
node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web start because we're going
to
we got to use jnlp protocol okay that
sounds good directory I think nothing
else is required availability yes will
keep this agent yeah online as much as
possible that sounds good all right let
me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
but then I also want to download this
alien.jar I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by a server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 800 jar I copy this or I cut
this I come back to my folder my Jenkins
node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command prompt right here and then
lost it so I'm saying in the same folder
where there is agent.jar I am going to
launch this a particular agent Java
hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is the
URL of my server in case the server and
client are on different locations or
different IPS let us specify the IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to Connected very well so let me come
back to my Jenkins instance and see you
know if at all you see earlier this was
not connected alone Let me refresh this
guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials or the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully we've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it will
create a workspace right here all right
so good so let me just come back and let
me kind of put up a new task here I will
say that you know delegate job is good I
say freestyle project I'm going to
create a very very simple job here
I don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
Echo
relegated to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label right
so now I am going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
you know Windows node so this job will
be delegated around there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it runs
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it creates a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary Master job is in SQL
program files under Jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of Master Slave configuration or
distributed built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up the one quick way to
do that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a colon program files
colon Jenkins directory because that's
where our whole Jenkins configuration is
present but we would don't want to do
that let's use some plugins for taking
up a backup so let me go to manage
Jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use so this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens if there
are too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and if the files are being
changed at that moment is there a bit
problematic for Jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically you try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to backup all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the maven artifacts possibly I
don't want this guy I would just say
save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular configurations so how do I do
that I just come back to my managing
cans
come back to backup manager and
obviously restore her son or Jenkins
configuration if you're ready to embark
on a career path pulsating with
excitement Innovation and Limitless
growth look no further than simply
landscatech postgraduate program in
devops this comprehensive program equips
you with the Knowledge and Skills to
navigate the devops landscape with
confidence explode the depth of
continuous integration delivery and
confer the entry cases of Automation and
orchestration fortify security like a
digital Fortress and a list of full
potential of cloud Technologies don't
let this once in a lifetime opportunity
slip away ignite your career and join
the ranks of prime Dev professionals
click the link in the description box to
enable the wonders of this course first
we'll see how to install Java
development kit jtk is one of the
prerequisites you need in order to run
Chan kits then we'll set up the jtk path
in the environment variable after that
we will see how to download and install
Jenkins on Windows once that's complete
we'll run Jenkins on localhost 8080
which is the default port for running
Jenkins
then we'll have a glance at the Jenkins
server interface and look at some of
features present on Jenkins
finally we learn how to build and run a
job in jackets to download and install
jtk simply type install jdk on Google
and click on the first link which is
Java SE development kit 8.
as you can see we get a list of
downloads for jdk since I'm on Windows
64-bit system I have already installed
jdk version for windows 64. before you
install jdk you also need to accept the
license agreement
let me show you where my jdk has been
installed
first I go to my C drive program files
under the Java folder you find two more
folders that's jdk and GRE now let's set
up the path in the environment variable
go to system properties under the
advanced tab select environment
variables
under system variables there are two
more variables called Java home and GRE
home Java home contains the path for jtk
I'll show you where it is
go to jtk folder copy the path and paste
it in the value section GRE home
contains the path for GRE similarly go
to the JRE folder copy the path and
paste it in the corresponding value
one more thing you need to do is set up
the bin folder location for jdk in path
variables
let's see where the bin folder location
is
here it is
after setting up the location click ok
to finish the setup
now shall we check if Java has been
successfully installed for that go to
the command prompt and type Java hyphen
version
you can see our Java is successfully
installed and it's up and running the
version we've installed is shown here
now let's download Jenkins on Windows
simply Type download Jenkins on Google
and click on first link
here we can see that Jenkins provides
two types of releases long-term support
release and weekly release
as I'm interested in a more stable
release so I will go for LTS
now when I scroll down I'll get an
option for Windows
once I select that
a stable installer starts to download
you can see it says thank you for
downloading Windows table installer
so now what Jenkins has started
downloading this might take a few
seconds
till then maybe you can catch up if
you're left behind
okay so the download is complete
now let's go ahead and unzip downloaded
Jenkins file
after the unzipping has been done we'll
start the installation click on this
folder
click run
next
this is the default path where Jenkins
will be installed we don't need to
change it so we can just go ahead with
next install
after this your Jenkins installation is
successfully completed
select finish
yes that's all now that installation is
complete let's go and explore Jenkins go
to your web browser and search localhost
colon 8080
you can see that it says welcome to
Jenkins
so I have already created the username
and password for Jenkins
I'll enter my credentials
and that's all this is how the Jenkins
home page and interface looks like and
that's all signing in
yes so that's the dashboard and this is
how the Jenkins home page and interface
looks like so if you're installing
Jenkins for the very first time it will
ask you to install some recommended
plugins I have already installed mine so
I don't need to install them once again
now there are a lot of things you can do
in Jenkins let me run you through a few
of them there's some jobs that I've
already created and run this is new item
it allows you to create a new project so
you can create a freestyle project a
maven project a build pipeline
Etc then going back to the dashboard
there is build history so this section
shows you the status of your build here
you can see what's the built name the
time since the build is running and
what's the status of your build
there is another very important section
called manage Jenkins
here you can configure your system you
can configure Global Security
credentials then there are some Global
tool configuration you can also download
and manage your plugins
here you can see there are four tabs
where you have some updates you have
some available plugins you have the
plugins that you've already installed
and then there is Advanced plugin as
well now let me show you how to create
and run a job in Jenkins
it's coming back to the dashboard let me
select new item we can name our job here
let me name the job as Jenkins demo I
will create a freestyle project so
select that and click ok
this might take a few seconds
so when we have created that here we
have a number of options that we can go
ahead with you have a source code
management building triggers building
environment and then of course some post
build actions
so that's about creating and running a
job in Jenkins let's give some
description to our job so we have create
the job we give description something
like this is my first Jenkins job
so we will not use any source code
management tool in the build section as
you can see there is an option to
execute Windows batch command
click on that and here you can give your
command
let's use the echo command
I will write something like hello this
is my first Jenkins demo
and then I'll also give the date and
time parameters so that I can track on
what date and time this job was built
that's it so click apply and then save
okay so this job is created now let's
build it go to build now
once you click it you can see a build
history has been created click on that
in the console output you can see the
output of your very first Jenkins job it
says hello this is my first Jenkins demo
would you give in the command box you
can see that and you can also see the
date date and time when this job was
created
so we've successfully created our
[Music]
hello everyone today we will be taking a
look at Docker it is one of the hottest
Technologies in the devops space right
now
okay let's take a look at the agenda
we'll answer the question what is Docker
we will discuss why we need Docker
Docker versus VMS we'll look at uh
Docker Hub and we'll go over the docker
basic commands we'll discuss Docker
images and we'll see the docker demo
so what is Docker Docker is basically a
container engine and it allows you to
run your applications inside containers
now until now we've been running our
applications in Virtual machines every
virtual machine used to be the base of
our application but now with the Advent
of Docker and containerization
Technologies each application is run in
a container like logical space
so to define a container it is a logical
grouping of all the binaries and all the
dependencies that each application
requires and then bundling it into a
single hole and running it on top of a
Docker engine Docker is typically used
to run applications typically like micro
servers which are single bundled
applications now they don't really
depend on a lot of external factors
now the benefit of having applications
in containers is that you don't really
need to worry about the base
infrastructure you just need to make
sure that you have the docker engine
running and that will make sure that the
container is running in the same way on
any platform Docker is open source so
you don't need to pay to use Docker at
least the open source version or the
Community Edition the Enterprise version
has been recently launched and it is a
few more features but I have seen many
projects implemented with the open
source version and it is more than
enough for what you need to get your
basic applications containerized when we
talk about Docker it's kind of like a
mini platform as a service so in a
normal platform as a service offering
what you guys just the actual thing that
you need to run so let's say you're are
using elastic Beanstalk on Amazon web
services and you get a ruby platform on
which you can run your application now
with Docker you get a real platform but
just the platform required to run your
application and uh that is more than
enough to get yourself into production
Docker integrates easily with other
tools so it integrates with other
ecosystem tools like swarm which is a
cluster management system it integrates
with monitoring systems you can monitor
things on the user ports using nadios or
any other monitoring system you've been
using within your existing
infrastructure
you can monitor the base hosts in Docker
on which Docker actually runs uh using
your normal monitoring tools
so why do we need it what is the benefit
of using Docker we're really good on VMS
and we've been running them for the last
decade so what's the real need to go to
Docker well the first thing is you get
really efficient utilization of your
resources now let's say I've got 10 VMS
and I'm running 10 applications on VMS
and things are good but the only problem
is VM number four is at 50 utilization
so I'm actually wasting half of capacity
on VM number five and I'm VM number six
say I'm just using 40 of the entire
power I have so in that case a lot of
the provision of capacity goes to waste
now in order to use that space and
capacity in a more efficient way you
need to have some sort of mechanism
which abstracts The Base Hardware
allocation in the application now Docker
forms the best combination for that so
it allows you to run your applications
in containers and at the same time it
allows you to optimize your resource
utilization so let's say you're on 10
VMS earlier and you're running 10
applications and when you move to Docker
and you've dockerized your applications
you can use those same 10 VMS and on top
of those VMS run a cluster of docker
containers and those 10 VMS now will be
available as a whole to Docker swarm or
any other cluster management system and
you can run all your applications across
those 10 containers so in effect those
10 VMS would be available as a whole for
the containers to easily run anywhere
you can actually bump in more containers
on the same number of VMS so let's say
you're on 50 utilization and you want to
increase the utilization and you can
actually run more containers so you
could actually get up to 90 utilization
of the same Hardware so with this you
easily get scalability since you can
scale up or scale down any cluster
management system so if you're running
dock or swarm for example you can scale
up your containers to any number just by
a single command
you get the portability of the cloud as
well as Docker containers let's say you
are on AWS cloud and you want to move to
Google Cloud you can import your
containers to Google Cloud just by
running a swarm cluster there and then
porting the image and that's it you
don't need to worry about any networks
for anything else you just run your
application on top of dock or swarm or
Docker engine now with this portability
you get the advantage of having multiple
environments and with those multiple
environments you can have Disaster
Recovery in place Disaster Recovery will
give you a high availability and your
business will never be down that's one
of the biggest advantages of a Docker
and you can easily set up Dr zones in in
your environment
now let's compare Docker with VMS
Dockers fast you can run a Docker
container like in 120th of a second
whereas a VM takes almost three minutes
to boot up if it's a GUI VM if it's a
CLI VM it takes almost a minute and a
half to boot up so Docker containers are
lightweight since they follow the layer
file system approach any Docker
container which is like a base image
would be around 120 to 150 megabytes now
if you look at a vmovf file or a vmdk
file from VMware you'll find that it's
almost 2 gigabyte for the CLI version
and uh for the GUI version it's more
than four gig
Docker containers are portable you can
easily Port them by committing them to a
Docker Hub and then importing them
elsewhere VMS are not that portable so
let's say you've got a VM in a VMware
sphere in your house and you really have
to import that entire image using a Pim
drive or some sort of network share and
it takes like four or five hours to do
the transfer so the portability aspect
for the VMS is less desirable
let's talk about Docker Hub just like
you have GitHub for code there is Docker
hub for Docker containers now Docker Hub
is used to store Docker images and share
them as well with the community Docker
Hub has both open source and pay
repositories so it's an open repository
managed by Docker inclusive so they have
it for the community so you can get one
private repository and unlimited public
repositories for free on the docker Hub
you've got official images of almost
every software on earth like ingenix
Apache 2 Enterprise Edition images
it's a hosted solution for private repos
so if you pay Docker hub for private
repositories you can get a cloud hosted
solution there so you don't need to
manage a local repository in your
infrastructure there are some Docker
basic commands which we will take a look
at in the demo there is Docker PS that
is used to show how many containers are
running Docker pull which allows you to
see and pull images from the docker Hub
Docker run is used to run Docker
containers Docker images will show you
the images you have in your local
repository Docker attach will attach to
the Shell however running container
Docker stop will stop a running
container and will start a stopped
container
let's take a look at the demo so I've
got a Linux machine here on Ubuntu 16.04
command line version machine ready set
up it's running on a virtual box and
I'll be using the terminal on my MacBook
to access the machine
we'll proceed with the installation of
Docker on that machine first of all then
we'll pull some images from the docker
Hub we will also try to run some
containers and then we will look at the
usage of some normal commands then we
will try to make some changes in the
image and commit to the local repository
and push it to the docker Hub so that
will be all for the demo
[Music]
so this is my Ubuntu 1604 image so you
see LSB underscore release hyphen a you
see it's a Ubuntu 16.04 code named
zenial and it's the latest LTS release
we'll be using apt first of all to
install a couple of dependencies which
Docker has so I'll say apt get install
apt hyphen transport
hyphen https
CA hyphen certificates
curl
software hyphen common hyphen properties
hyphen y
EP The Hyphen Y is used as a yes to
automatically accept the agreement
pretty much all of these are there by
default in the installation of Ubuntu so
you don't really need to worry about
those but just as a security check we
did that
now the next step we are going to
download the gpg key of Docker from the
official repository so they host it at
download.doccer.com the reason we need
to have that is that we want to make
sure we don't get any spoofed packages
so we do a curl hyphen f
so I'm doing it in the silent mode using
these switches because I'm going to pass
that the APT hyphen key add command
it's hosted on https
download.doctor.com
forward slash Linux forward slash Ubuntu
forward slash gpg
and I'll pipe it to the APT key command
so I'll say apt hyphen key add hyphen
so what this will do is get the gpg key
from the docker repository and add it to
the local apt cache
okay
okay have pressed it it should say okay
so this means the key is added now
now I want to add the repository for the
docker installation there's a remote but
my local installation doesn't know
there's a remote repository so I'll be
using the add hyphen apt hyphen
repository command to do that so I'll
say add hyphen apt iPhone repository to
do that
and then I'll say Deb
Arch equals AMD 64.
https
download Dot
docker.com slash Linux slash Ubuntu
then
uh dollar LSB
release hyphen CS
and then stable
this command will add the repository to
my Etc apt sources.list so if I open the
file and Etc apt
if I open the sources.list file you'll
see
so I've added the amd64 which is the
64-bit version since my machine is
64-bit so if I do a u name hyphen a it
says
x8664. so I want a 64-bit machine and
that's why I've added a 64-bit
repository of Docker next step I want to
do is update my apt caches because I
want to get the latest package indexes
so I'll say apt hyphen get update hyphen
y
after updating the local cache I need to
restore the docker Community Edition so
I'll use the APT command again apt-get
install
Docker hyphen c hyphen y
this will install the docker Community
Edition on my local machine
it will fetch all the repository
packages
now Dockers installed on this machine
let me check and see what version of
Docker I have so I'll do Docker hyphen
hyphen version so you see I have Docker
version
17.03.1 Community Edition
build c6d412e
next thing I need to do is I need to go
and run a hello world container because
that's like a health check
so I'll say Docker run hello hyphen
World we'll do a couple of health checks
in the background now you see it says
unable to find the image locally pulling
file system layer from Docker Hub and it
gives me this nice clean output that
says hello from Docker this message
shows that your installation appears to
be working correctly to generate this
message Docker took the following steps
so basically it did a whole lot of
health checks in the back end to contact
Docker Damon then the docker Hub was
contacted the image was downloaded so
everything seems to be fine now now I'm
going to download a couple of images
there so the first thing you do is you
search for those images so I'll search
for the Ubuntu image so I'll say Docker
search Ubuntu
so you see a lot of images are out there
of which only the first one is an
official one so you see this is official
okay so I'll download all four major
versions so I'll say docker
pull
Ubuntu this will pull the docker Ubuntu
image
so you see it's pulling down the layers
I'll pull the Fedora image
these are the four most popular versions
so I'll say docker
pull
fedora
Docker pull Debian
and then Docker pull Centos
that's the fourth one
so all of these images have been pulled
from the docker Hub now let me give you
a quick look at the docker Hub so if you
go to hub.docker.com
if you go to explore you'll see almost
every major software is in there
in Gen X redis busy box Ubuntu Alpine
registry MySQL classes search log
stash node hello world swarm httpd
everything so I've pulled four Images
here so if I do a Docker images it will
list out all the so in addition to the
hello world I've got four more images
which I've pulled down so you see it
shows me the tags which is the latest
there's an image which corresponds to a
unique image ID on the docker Hub it
shows me they've created date six days
ago 12 days ago whatever date image was
created and the size so you see the size
is considerably small 119 Meg 100 Meg
the hello world is just one KB Centos is
just 193 MB Fedora is 231 MB the next
thing we're going to do is I want to run
the containers so let me run the kubuntu
container so I'll say Docker run hyphen
TI Ubuntu so this will run the docker
Ubuntu image in interactive mode so I'll
be able to switch to this container so
you see the prompt will change now to
root at 480. so I'm inside the container
now so I'll do a free hyphen m and the
container has the same amount of memory
as the base machine so let me go to the
base machine so I'll open up a session
to the base machine here
okay now in this image
root at this this is the container if I
do a free hyphen here in the base
machine you see almost the same amount
of RAM is free
so this means Docker containers use the
same Ram that is available on the base
machine now I'm going to do a Docker PS
hyphen a here it shows me that there are
two containers running one has the hello
world container which I ran four minutes
ago
and was used just as a health check
and then you see there's a Ubuntu
container running and its uh name has
been given randomly by the Dr Damon as
happy Pasteur
so this container is running in the
background and it's up in this VM
now we're going to stop this container
using the docker stop command so I'll
say Docker stop and then the container
ID this will stop the containers so if I
do a Docker PS hyphen a you see it shows
that it has exited but I can restart
this container by doing a Docker start
and then I can attach the command line
of that container using the doctor
attach command
you see I've restarted it and I was able
to attach it
now let me exit from this container and
let me remove all the containers so the
command to remove all the containers is
Docker RM and then the container ID now
uh you can see I have one container
remaining I've removed all of them at
once by just doing the docker RM and
then in Brackets I'll be placing Docker
PS hyphen AQ which will get all the
container IDs now if you run it as a
standalone you'll see Docker PS hyphen
AQ gives you all the container IDs now
let me run one container in the
background once I do Docker run hyphen
TI hyphen D Ubuntu
so you see it's running in the
background so if I do a Docker PS hyphen
a
there's a container agitated Euler
running in the background I can attach
to that container by using the docker
attach command
docker
attach and then the container ID
now let me update this container and
make some changes so I can commit to the
docker Hub so I'll say apt-get update
hyphen y this will update my Docker
container to have the latest package
indexes from the Ubuntu repositories
now I'll do an app to get so I'll
install the Apache web server on this so
I'll say apt-get install
Apache to hyphen y
EP this will install the Apache 2 web
server actually on this container I'm
doing this because I want to save the
state of this container on the docker
Hub so this is downloading
the Apache 2 from the remote
repositories
then I'll start the Apache service
so I'll say service
Apache to start
so if I do a service Apache to
status you will see it is running now
the next thing I want to do here is exit
from this container and then try to
commit it so I'll use the docker commit
command and to save the state of this
container so you see Docker PS hyphen a
this is the container for which I'll
save the state for so I'll say Docker
commit hyphen m
this is the commit message so I'll stay
installing uh
Apache web server
and then I'll say author name Amir and
then container ID and the name which I
won't put now there's one thing which we
need to take care of here uh you have to
make sure that your image has the
following formatting it should be your
username on the docker Hub Amir Ahmad
170 slash whatever your container has so
I'll say Ubuntu hyphen Apache 2. now
when I commit this container it comes
into the local images list so if I do a
Docker images you can see it's here now
I've got to push this to the docker Hub
so I'll say Docker login hyphen U log
into the docker hub from the command
line using my username so I'll say
Docker hyphen you amerimed 170.
I'll give it my password so I'm logged
into the docker Hub now it says Docker
login succeeded
now I can commit that image so I'll say
Docker push I've already committed it so
I'll push it now so I'll say Docker push
and then the image ID so if I just do a
push here it's doing this but in the
meantime if I go to my dashboard I
already have two things here
and in a moment you'll see one more here
so it's pushing all the layers of the
image
and then once you push this I can just
remove my local thing so when I refresh
this here you'll see a third image
coming up here
actually it has over it in the one I
already had so let me just delete and
re-push this
I'm going to clean out my Docker Hub
here
delete
now delete this one as well
okay now if I push again you'll see it
will create a new image here in my
Docker Hub it will take some time to do
that but that would be a confirmation
that the image has been pushed from my
Docker machine here so it's pushing 137
MB of the image layer the top layer
so you see this is pushed so now the
basic idea behind this pushing was I
really wanted to keep this saved in the
remote Docker Hub so I'm going to remove
all my local images so I'll say Docker
images
okay I'll remove all of them so I'll say
docker
first I'll clean up my container so I'll
say Docker RM
so there's no container running so I'll
remove all the images locally so I'll
say Docker images and then I'll do a
docker
RMI hyphen f
so I'm removing it forcefully
but I'll do the single command removed
so I'll say Docker images
hyphen AQ
this is a single command remove it
basically gets all the image IDs in this
command so let me show you this
right now there is no image but it will
put all those image IDs here and
forcefully remove all those images so if
I do a Docker images no Docker images
there if I do a Docker PS I have an 8 no
container is there now let me run the
container from here so I'll pull the
image first using this command so the
beauty of Docker Hub is that it gives
you a command for pulling the container
so I'll do Docker pull amerimed 172
slash Ubuntu hyphen Apache 2. so it
statically goes to the docker Hub it's
pulling the layers from there next row
for Windows so you can go for the stable
or you can go for the edge right so you
also have the comparison that what is
the difference between these two
versions right so um the particular Edge
version is something which is getting
releases every month and the stable
version is getting the releases every
quarter so they are not doing much of
the changes to the stable version as
compared to the edge there so you just
have to double click on the installer
and that will help you to do the
installation of the process so let's get
started so you just click on the get in
stable version so when you do that the
particular installer is going to install
now it's going to take like around 300
MB there so that's the kind of install
which is available so once the installer
is downloaded so what you can do is that
you can actually go ahead and you can
proceed with the doing the double click
on this installer when you double click
on that you have to proceed with some of
the steps like you know from the GUI
itself you are going to proceed with
these steps so we'll wait for 10 to 20
seconds more and then the installer will
be done and then we can do the double
click and the installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of Unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a GUI is also
involved and there are a lot of binaries
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the huge size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
Windows 10 professional or Enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous uh version of operating
systems like Windows 7 and all you have
the older version called Docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like Docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as in Docker desktop with the new
Docker Windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so I'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a GUI component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay I'm going to
click on OK so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
Docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any Docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that Docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like Docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then add that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker demon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a Docker installation and we can go
on that part so before we begin let me
give you an intro to Docker so what is
Docker Docker is a tool which is used to
automate the deployment of applications
in lightweight containers so when I say
containers I mean a software package
that consists of all the dependencies
required to run the particular
application and when you deploy
containers you're basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in any kind of environment so
Dockers have multiple features some of
which are that multiple containers can
run on the same Hardware it has very
high productivity when compared to
Virtual machines it maintains isolated
applications and has a very quick and
easy configuration process so now let's
begin with the demo we'll be installing
Docker on an Ubuntu system so this is my
system I just open the terminal so the
first thing you can start with is
removing any Docker installation that
you probably already have present in
your system if you want to start from
scratch so this is the command to do so
sudo app get removed docker
dock engine Docker dot IO enter your
password
and Docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install Docker
once again before that I'll just clear
my screen
okay so before I install Docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo app get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type Docker install
and that by itself will give you the
commands you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install doc
dot IO is a command that we will need to
execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the sudo
snap install Docker so sudo apt install
Docker dot IO first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have sudo snap
install Docker so snap install Docker
installs a newly created snap package
they are basically some other
dependencies for Docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire Docker i o it
will take some time
great so our Docker is installed the
next thing we do as I mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install talk
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
insulation process for Docker but we'll
perform a few more stages where we will
test if the installation has been done
right
so before we move on with the testing
for Docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see Docker version
17.12.1 CE has been installed next thing
we do is we pull an image from the
docker hub so Docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a Docker image which
is present on the docker Hub Docker Hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
if pseudo Docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository this is present on our system
currently so the image has been
successfully pulled onto the system and
this means that our Docker is working
now we'll try out another command
pseudo Docker PF minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so I did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for Docker PS
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running State you can
simply execute sudo Docker PS
pseudo docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running State and with that we come to
an end of our Docker installation so
we're going to go through a bunch of
things today around kubernetes we're
going to cover what kubernetes is and
why you should be using it along with
the features of kubernetes we're also
going to take a little bit of a look at
kubernetes versus Docker swarm as the
two technologies do tend to get referred
to quite frequently and then we're going
to do a deep dive into the actual
kubernetes architecture itself and how
kubernetes runs and operates within your
network and then finally we're going to
look at some kubernetes use cases of how
you can actually apply best learnings
that other companies have used with
kubernetes we'll finish everything off
with a demo where we actually step
through and use some of the actual codes
that you can actually use to run from
your terminal window to actually
activate kubernetes itself so with that
said let's jump in so why kubernetes
well kubernetes is really being built
from allowing you to be able to have a
more reliable infrastructure the tool
itself is designed to manage the
containers you have within your network
it's very modular in architecture which
allows it to be very easy to be able to
maintain and to be able to scale and
meet the demands that your current
customers are offering you today the
actual ability for you to be able to
deploy and update software at scale is
really at the heart and center of
kubernetes it's really well the one of
the reasons why kubernetes was created
was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into tens of
thousands of networks and servers within
a Data Center and then finally when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building Cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and container
authorized solutions that you're really
building out an infrastructure that's
designed for cloud-centric solution
delivery so let's dig into why what
kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by Google Google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the data structure and data
infrastructure that they had within
their Network they really liked it and
one of the big benefits that kubernetes
that Google provided is that they
converted their code into an open source
program that they released as kubernetes
in 2014 and made an open source this
means that any company can use
kubernetes there's no charge for it all
you have to do is know how to use the
command lines to actually get up and
running the benefit of kubernetes being
open source is that most Cloud providers
now support kubernetes so whether you're
using Microsoft Azure you're using
Google cloud or AWS you'll find that you
can actually use kubernetes and
kubernetes and a core really helped
eliminate manual processes so it allowed
for deploying and scaling your
container-based Solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of Step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 it doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes is
also will manage the actual containers
themselves including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great benefit of
working with kubernetes is that not only
is it a cloud-centric solution but it
was really built from a core need of a
secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing which really helps benefit any
teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored so that when you
have nodes that have your containers the
health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to uh the
kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment has always been
managed and checked so if you have any
additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes if
something does go wrong you can actually
set up your kubernetes environment to do
an automatic rollback again this is just
allowing you to have that confidence
that when you're deploying a solution
that everything is going to work within
that environment and then finally
kubernetes will allow you to mount and
add the storage needed to run your apps
so whether you have storage such as a
local SSD storage device physically on
the hardware or if you're connecting to
storage fire the cloud kubernetes will
allow you to access the storage you need
how you're accessing it so let's look a
little bit into the differences between
kubernetes and Docker swarm so if we
just step back a little bit kubernetes
and Docker often get connected with each
other and largely because kubernetes
manages containers and Docker is really
famous for creating the most popular
container management solution which is
called Docker if you're a developer
you're probably already using Docker
today so one of the things that
kubernetes is really really good at is
that it manages containers at scale and
just massive volume of containers Docker
swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes it's a tool that allows you
to also manage large number large
numbers of containers
um there are differences between the two
of them and right now without doubt the
most popular
um open source solution out there is
kubernetes from Google it just has a
massive Community behind it and uh the
community uh really have embraced um
kubernetes and yes the original product
was by developed by Google but Google
has been great stewards and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
Docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by Docker um there is a
smaller Community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm Community but with that said
Docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you'll be able to set
up Docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment
kubernetes has extremely high voltage
tolerance again it's because kubernetes
is has been Road tested the foundation
for kubernetes is based on managing
sites such as Gmail google.com YouTube I
mean just incredibly robust environment
compared to Docker swarm which has lower
fault tolerance
um and this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee strong clusters management
just a really reliable environment Dr
swarm however is able to take containers
to deploy them into large casters very
very quickly two interesting differences
is that with kubernetes the load
balancing is still manual and be
interesting to watch how kubernetes
matures that skill set in contrast load
balancing is automatic within Docker
swarm so let's dig into the kubernetes
architecture and just kind of expose
some of those key elements um if you're
interested in actually having a very
deep dive into kubernetes architecture
we have already got another video and we
should have a link in the comments that
you can select that will take you to
that video as well but this will provide
you an overview as well um so the way
that kubernetes runs is that it uses
nodes to actually manage all the
individual Hardware within a specific
unit and so a node is really a physical
machine in a data center or a virtual
machine and when you're setting up an
environment it's on a cloud environment
such as Microsoft Azure or Google cloud
or AWS kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to match the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster and it's very very
flexible within kubernetes you can have
local storage such as an SSD card or a
traditional local storage or you can
actually connect to the cloud and use
cloud-based storage and the benefit
that's cloud-based storage offers you is
that you are increasingly Moving Your
solution into more of a hardware free
environment cloud-based architecture
where you're not reliant on a physical
piece of Hardware within your data
center and why that's important is that
it gives you the opportunity to scale up
your Solutions much more effectively so
if you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud whereas local hardware is a
little bit harder to manage great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from and so the the next
layer down is the actual management of
the application and that's within a
container and as mentioned earlier
Docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
Docker as it was a natural maturity from
using a virtual machine but kubernetes
itself will actually manage the
containers that you have within your
nodes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes will
actually manage the health of that pod
so if a container or a pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pods themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to let kubernetes do this because
it's allowing you to step away from the
manual management of Parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from Services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called Ingress and going back
earlier we talked about how security is
a key part of all the work that goes
into kubernetes and this is a great
example of where you can use an external
service but still have that layer of
security that is vital for your solution
because to be able to provide the
Ingress connection kubernetes requires
an SSL connection which automatically
allows for secure data transfer
absolutely fantastic fantastic so here
we have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master so the master itself is comprised
of a number of key components again this
is the tool that's going to manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the etcd
control manager scheduler API server and
the key for components are Etc or the
cluster or the controller manager the
scheduler and the API server the cluster
store is the tool where all the details
of the work that you're doing is stored
now it's going to manage the rules it's
going to manage all the instructions and
this is where you're going to post that
information the controller is actually
going to then perform the tasks that are
stored in the cluster store and as you'd
expect the schedule is the tool that
actually controls when instructions and
tasks are pushed out to all the pods and
nodes within your network and then
finally you have an API server which
allows you to be able to control all the
operations the actual operations
themselves are all the instructions
written as rest instructions which
allows you to take advantage of the
security that has been built into rest
and so you end up with a worker slave
architecture and slaves are all the
different nodes and pods within your
network and so upon itself will have
multiple one or more multiple containers
and then each container and then each
pod will have a Docker container a
kublet and a kubernetes proxy and the
these are tools to allow you to
communicate back up to the master layer
so the docker is the actual container
itself and this is going to actually run
your application and the instructions
here are to pull down the correct
container from the docker images that
you have within your library the cubelet
is going to manage your containers and
your container instructions that will be
deployed to the cubelet are going to be
written in either yaml or Json format
yaml is just great if you haven't had a
chance to start working with yaml I
certainly encourage you to do so it's
very easy to pick up if you know any XML
you'll pick up yaml very quickly and
finally the kubernetes proxy is the tool
that interacts with the master
environment within the kubernetes
network and allows all the instructions
from that are pushed to the cube blade
and to Docker to be able to perform
effectively so let's have a look at some
of the companies using kubernetes there
are a lot and if you're doing any work
today in the cloud and even if you're
just starting off and doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes for
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are Spotify sap eBay and of
course some of the the big companies out
there Google with their entire network
of solutions and Microsoft with offers
and their tools so let's take a a step
into aube now let's have a look at a
kubernetes use case and in this example
we're going to look at the New York
Times and how they use kubernetes to
solve a problem that their IIT
Department was struggling with so when
New York Times started working after
their data centers their their actual
deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMS but
the problem is is is that as New York
Times became more of a digital company
they started building more digital
Solutions and at some point they
realized that what they needed to do was
to embrace the cloud and move all their
solutions to the cloud however their
first step of using the cloud and this
is I think typical for a lot of
companies is that they treated like the
cloud hosted provider in the same way as
they would with a Data Center and they
at some point they realized they had to
take a change and this is where the
development team I came in and they said
look how about we stop thinking of our
Solutions as a data center even though
they're being run in Amazon I start
thinking them as Cloud first Solutions
and so what they proposed and what they
ended up doing was using Google Cloud
platform with kubernetes as servers and
to provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
Solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything the able to reduce the time
for deployment from minutes to seconds
and by doing this they were able to
increase the amount of time that uptime
for the actual infrastructure um updates
began to be deployed independently and
when required so you didn't have to
schedule an event when you do the
deployments it just happened and there
was more unified approach to deployment
from the engineering staff which just
made the whole solution more portable so
the fundamental end line for the New
York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do Solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
New York Times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take it our time
to do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through and we'll
let you uh read through this but uh we
have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers now replication controller
is used to define a pods life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources labels are key value
pairs that are attached to objects such
as pods and the key value pad or the
label can be filtered organize and
perform operations on resources
replication sense Define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
managed when you want to either replace
a pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single IP address and DNS Name
by which the pods can be accessed so
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
we're going to take you through a video
of how to actually install kubernetes
and to use some of the basic
instructions so kubernetes is the most
one of the used platform for container
management the first step is to actually
install the necessary dependencies so
let's see if there's any updates first
so the first so to check if there's any
updates we'll use the command sudo app
dash get update I'm going to enter in
our password and this looks like it's
going to take a few minutes because
we've got a few updates that need to be
running all right we're done all right
next we're going to write sudo app get
install dash
yapt.transport dash https and this will
or install all the dependencies we need
to actually start installing the
solutions needed for kubernetes all
right that was quick now we're going to
put in the docker dependency and the way
we do that is write the command sudo apt
install Docker dot IO I'll go typo
correct that quickly and put in y so vs
and we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install Docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have Docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start Docker and
enable Docker using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start enable Docker we're going to be
using so we're going to use sudo
systemctl start Docker and sudo
systemctl enable Docker this will be
quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to install the curl command and
then kubilate Cube C and then qbadm and
we're going to install all the necessary
tools we'll do the curl command cubelet
cubic C2 and Cube ADM and so let's go
ahead and put in the sudo apt-get
install curl I'm going to get a prompt
we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudocal dash s and
then we have a long URL which is https
uh packages.cloud google.com apt dark
apt-key Dot gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go I'll create my typo
there okay now we have to go ahead and
change permissions of a folder so we do
that with sudo chmod 777 slash Etc apt
slash
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit and we're going to
create a simple file and so what we're
going to type in is the the following
command DB httbt
apt-cubernetes dot IO slash kubernetes
Dash zenial Main and we're going to save
this file in the ETC folder and then
look for and then a APT which is going
to be down a little bit and there we
have it and we're going to save it in
the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as kubernetes dot list and
we'll save that and then we can close
out the notepad and go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
if there are any updates again so we're
going to go ahead and run apt-get update
and it's going to run any updates from
what we've created and we want to check
what's in the folder and so we do cat
slash X at ATT Etc apt
sources.d kubernetes dot list and there
we are it shows what we have in that
text file and so we're going to go ahead
and we're going to install cubelet cubic
cubic 2 and Cube ADM but first we're
going to have to initialize the master
I'm going to show you what an error you
would get if you were to install cubelet
and the other files too quickly you get
the fine error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm qbx2 and kubernetes cni and so
we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap up Dash a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo Cube ADM in
it and this will take a few minutes for
it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the Pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cuboo
Cube CTL apply
and we have a long Pathway to type out
which is Dash fhqbs raw githubs
content.com Korea's final Master
documentation Cube file Dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating mktr Dash p and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot Cube and
create that new directory and sudo CP
Dash I and then the path will be
Etc
kubernetes
admin.conf and then doc sign home slash
dot Cube dot slash config
and then final one will be pseudo
c-h-o-w-n dollar sign open Brain ID Dash
U closed paren colon dollar sign open ID
slash Dash G close paren dosing home
slash dot Q slash config all right now
we're going to go ahead and deploy and
uh let's see and oh yeah I think I have
a typo in my command here yep oh yeah I
did have a typo and so
um I've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an S and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic Cube CTL
apply dash dash F and then we're just
going to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
pods that we have in our Network and so
we're going to do that by writing the
commands sudo cubic TCL get pods Dash or
dash dash name spaces and it should list
all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all the content now
we're going to so there's only one node
so let's see what we have here so we're
going to use the command sudo you know
cubic TL get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
ngi and access service and we're going
to do that with the command sudo cubic
CTL run Dash Dash image equals nginx and
we're going to put this into Port 80 so
it's going to be nginx app dash dash
Port equals 80 dash dash environment EMV
equals uh ubunt open quota domain equals
cluster close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo Cube CTL exposed
deployment nginx Dash app dash dash Port
equals 80 dash dash name equals nginx
Dash HTTP and once we've done this we'll
be able to then run the command to
actually see our services and there'll
be quite a few of them
and our final command is sudo docker
ps-a
yeah we have quite a lot of lists quite
a lot of services listed so there you
are that's the instructions on how to
get Docker up and running and uh with
some basic commands and it is worth
going through a few times to get right
um but once you actually have the um the
uh kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your document environment
and containers it's extremely powerful
now the first step is to install the
necessary dependencies using two of the
commands first is sudo apt get update
which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install Docker dot IO
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system CTL
start Docker and pseudo system CTL
enabledoc
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because curl
command is used to send data using a URL
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
code
so you have to select Y and this will
take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download an add key for kubernetes
installation from a URL so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo app key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or sudo CH mode command
okay so the permission has changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a URL
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubadium cubectil and
kubernetes cni so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap of
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off
hyperly
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
qadian in it
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
that's done
so moving forward
the path uses the following command
now the parts have been replied to our
Network to see all the paths we have to
use the command pseudo cubectle get
pause
[Music]
there you can see the password has been
deployed so what will you be learning
today you learn why you should use
ansible what exactly is ansible the
ansible architecture how ansible works
the various benefits of ansible and
finally we'll have a demo on the
installation of Apache or the httpd
package on a client systems we'll also
be hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo I'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
Yaman and your inventory file so let's
begin why should you use ansible let's
consider a scenario of an organization
where Sam is a system administrator Sam
is responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator Sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task Sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where Sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
Sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes Sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for Innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible Sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct States so
now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an I.T engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically beings bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this can of an
order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next ansible automate
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired state are the tools
that automate configuration management
include puppet and Chef and finally
ansible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals now that we
know what exactly ansible is let's look
at ansible's architecture ansible has
two main components you have the local
machine and you have your node or the
client machine so the local machine is
where the system administrator sits he
or she installs ansible here and on the
other end you have your node or the
client systems so in case of ansible
there's no supporting software installed
here these are just the systems that
required to be configured and they are
completely controlled by the local
machine at your local machine you also
have a module a module is a collection
of your configuration files and in case
of ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the Playbook and the inventory is
written and that that will probably make
it clearer so of course the local
machine needs to communicate with the
client and how is this done this is done
through SSH ssh is your secure shell
which basically provides a protected
Communication in an unprotected
environment okay so we saw the various
components of ansible now how does
ansible exactly work you have your local
machine on one end this is where you
install ansible if you've gone through
any previous material on ansible you
would have come across the term
agentless often being associated with
this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or Plugin being
installed on your clients this means
that you have no agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
ansible is push configuration so since a
local machine has complete control here
it pushes The Playbook books onto the
notes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the nodes through the SSH client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it's where
the facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the Playbook is executed the tasks
mentioned in the Playbook is compared
against the current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your notes are
configured to the desired States so as I
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
various benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple in important and provides
automated reporting how does it do all
this let's have a look at that agentless
as I already mentioned before you
require no supporting software or Plugin
installed on your node or the client
system so the master has complete
control and automatically this means
that ansible is more efficient because
now we have more space in our client and
node systems for other resources and we
can get ansible up and running real
quick ansible is also flexible so an
infrastructure is prone to change very
often and ansible takes no amount of
time to adjust to these changes ansible
cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
yaml which is as close to English as you
can possibly get
it important basically means that if you
have a Playbook which needs to be run n
number of systems it would have the same
effect on all of these systems without
any side effect and finally we have
automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these tasks are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
Hands-On before we move on to the actual
Hands-On let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so I'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both Centos 7
Operating Systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
I'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the Playbook and then
simply deploy this Playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our Playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
Oracle virtual box here I have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminal is open
right now so the client machine terminal
has a black background with white text
and the Master machine terminal has a
white background with black text just so
you can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the Master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen Y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible installed the next step
we go to our host file so host file here
is basically the inventory it's where
you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so I'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the IP address
of our client machine so my client
machines IP address is
192.168.2.127 so before you come to this
it's advice that you check the IP
address on your client machine the
simple command for that is ifconfig now
once you type the IP address put a space
and here we need to mention the username
and the password for our client
so I'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is Root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our Playbook we need
to write the Playbook
so the extension for our Playbook is yml
which stands for yaml
and as you can see here I have already
written my playbook but I'll just
explain to you how this is done so a
yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire Playbook
so I have named it sample book host is
basically where this would be executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory I
mentioned client's group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called the
privilege escalation now A playbook
consists of tasks so we have here three
tasks the first task I've named it to
install httpd so what we are doing here
is we are installing our httpd package
which is basically the Apache server and
we are installing the most latest
version of it hence the state value is
latest the next task is running httpd so
for the service the name is httpd
because that's the service we need to
start running and the state is started
our next task is creating content so
this is the part where we are creating
our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome and the
destination of the file will be via
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our HTML files now as you can see
here there's quite a lot of indentation
and when it comes to yaml although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first Dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
Playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentations absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of a yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
Playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is sample
dot yml which is the name of your
playbook so our Playbook is ready to be
executed
the command to execute the Playbook is
ansible Playbook
and the name of your playbook
so playbooks executed as you can see
here Gathering facts that's where all
the facts of the know that the present
state of the note is collected and sent
to the local machine so it's basically
to check that if the configuration
changes that we are about to make is
already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay State this means that
the content is already present in the
client machine so I made it this way so
that you can at least see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on a client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your Apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
so that was very simple wasn't it
if you have any doubts about the
procedure or any other part of the
tutorial please post your doubts in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as we see them so if you
consider the case of an organization it
has a very large infrastructure which
means it has more than probably hundreds
of systems and giving one or even a
small team of people the responsibility
to configure all these systems makes
their work really tough repetitive and
as you know manual work is always prone
to errors so ansible is a tool which can
automate the configuration of all these
systems with ansible a small team of
system administrators can write simple
code in yaml and these codes are
deployed onto the hundreds and thousands
of servers which configures them to the
desired States so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an odd in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager I'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the Master System so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my Master System guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
Chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
Creator ansible tool is installed now we
need to open our ansible host file and
there we'll specify the details of our
node or client machine
so this is ansible host file as you can
see here the entire file is commented
but there's a certain syntax that you'd
observe for example here we have a group
name web servers under which we have the
IP addresses or certain host name so
this is about how we'll be adding the
details for our client system first we
need to give a group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the IP address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the IP address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your IP address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for a client machine
so all Communications between the server
or the Master System and the client or
the node system takes place through SSH
ssh basically provide a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the roots password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our host file is written the
next thing we do is we write a Playbook
so Playbook is the technical term used
for all the configuration files that we
write in ansible now playbooks are
written in yaml yaml's extremely simple
to both write and understand it's in
fact very close to English
so now we'll write our Playbook The
Playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our Playbook
so name and I'm going to name my
playbook sample book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is Root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the route to execute this
Playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation next we need to
specify our tasks so these are basically
the actions that the Playbook will be
performing so you would have noticed
everything so far is aligned that is
name host remote user become and task
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under task will be
shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a Apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task would be running our
Apache service
so name run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied to a node
system at a particular file location
that will provide
a Content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for Ola
HTML files
and that's it we are done writing our
Playbook just save this and go back to
your terminal
before we execute the Playbook or push
the Playbook onto our node system let's
check the syntax of our Playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the Playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the Syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although a system had the Apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now everything's fine here we can move
on to our node system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our Playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running State and the
webpage that we created should be hosted
so let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible so before we begin let's have a
brief look at all that you'll learn
today first we'll get to know why should
we use chef and what exactly is the chef
two of the most common terms used with
Chef configuration management and
infrastructure as code we'll have a
brief look at these we'll also have a
look at the components of chef and the
chef architecture quickly go through the
various flavors of Chef and finally
we'll wrap it up with the demo a demo on
the installation of Apache on our notes
so let's begin guys why should we use
Chef well consider a large company now
this company caters to a large number of
clients and provides a number of
services or Solutions of course to get
all of this done they need a huge number
of servers and a huge number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure now this infrastructure
needs to be continuously configured and
maintained in fact when you're dealing
with an infrastructure that size there's
a good chance systems may be failing and
in the long run as your company expands
new systems may even get added so what
do you do well you could say the company
has the best system administrator out
there but all by himself could he
possibly take care of an infrastructure
that size no he can't and that's where
Chef comes in because Chef automates
this entire process so what does Chef
provide Chef provides continuous
deployment so when you look at the
market space today you see how products
and their updates are coming out in a
map matter of days so it's very
important that a company is able to
deploy the product the minute it's ready
so that once it's out it's not already
obsolete Chef also provides increased
system robustness as we saw Chef can
automate the infrastructure but in spite
of this automation there's a good
possibility that errors do creep in Chef
can detect all these bugs and remove
them before deploying them into the Real
Environment not only this Chef also
adapts to the cloud we all know how
today the services tools Solutions
everything is revolving around the cloud
so Chef does really play along by making
itself easily integratable with the
cloud platform so now that you know why
to use Chef let's look at what exactly
is chef chef is an open source tool
developed by Ops Code
of course there are paid versions of
Chef such as Chef Enterprise but other
than that most of it is freely
accessible Chef is written in Ruby and
erlang if you would have gone through
any previous material on Chef I'm sure
you would have come across Ruby being
related to chef but not erlang so this
is why because Ruby and erlang are both
used to build chef but when it comes to
actually writing the codes in Chef it's
just Ruby and these are the codes that's
deployed onto your multiple servers and
does the automatic configuration and
maintenance and this is why Chef is a
configuration management tool so I've
used this term configuration management
a couple of times what exactly does this
mean let's start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and what
are these practices for these practices
are for managing your entities the
entities which are required for
efficient deployment so what are these
entities that you need for efficient
deployment they are code infrastructure
and people code is basically the code
the system administrators right for
configuring your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers and then
finally you have the teams that take
care of this infrastructure so codes
need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructures
configuration needs to change and
finally of course the people need
coordination so if you have a team of
system administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person B C
D and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as as to why it was
made what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
Management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes pushes these files onto the
loan so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pull against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files Chef follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with Chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's Tim Tim's system administrator
at a large company now he receives a
task he has to set up a server and he
has to install 20 software applications
over it so he begins he sets up the
server but then it hits him it would
take him the entire night to install 20
software applications wouldn't things
have been much simpler if he just had a
code to do so well of course codes do
make things much simpler codes have a
number of advantages they're easily
modifiable so if today Tim is told we
need Maya skill installed on 20 systems
Tim simply writes a code to do so and
the very next daytime is told we changed
our mind we don't need Maya's skill I
think we'll just use Oracle this does
not bothered him because now he just
opens the file he makes a few
Corrections in his code and that should
work just fine code is also testable so
if Tim had to write 10 commands to do
something and at his 10th command he
realized the very first command he wrote
there was something not right there well
that would be quite tiresome wouldn't it
with codes however you can test tested
even before running it and all the bugs
can be caught and corrected codes are
also Deployable so they're easily
Deployable and they're Deployable
multiple times so now that we saw the
various advantages of having codes let's
say what infrastructure as code exactly
is here's the definition infrastructure
as code is a type of it infrastructure
where the operation team manages the
code rather than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code allows the
operations team to take care of a code
which automatically performs various
procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
Chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of Chef are written in
Ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
notes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes or high
is a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required shift client
is another such service on your node
which is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
Chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
sauce you have simply learned three dot
Erb Erb is the extension for your Ruby
files so the cookbooks are only created
at the workstation they now need to be
sent over to the server where they are
stored and this is the task of the knife
knife is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
Dash DB where simply Dash DB is the name
of the cookbook we then move on to our
node machines at our nodes we run the
Ojai service the Ojai service will
collect all information regarding the
current state of your notes and send it
over to the shift light when you run the
chef client these informations are sent
over to the server and they are tested
against the cookbooks so if there is any
discrepancy between the current state of
your nodes and the cookbook that is if
one of the notes does not match the
configurations required The cookbook is
then fetched from the server and
executed at the node this sets the node
to the right State there are various
flavors of Chef we'll quickly go through
these first we have Chef solo with Chef
solo there's no separate server so your
cookbooks are located on the Node itself
now this kind of configuration is used
only when you have just a single node to
take care of the next flavor is a hosted
chef with hosted Chef you still have
your workstation and your node but your
server is now used as a service on the
cloud this really makes things simple
because you don't have to set up a
server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical Chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
shift line server with shift client
server you have a workstation you have
server and you have and number of nodes
now this is the traditional Chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private Chef private
Chef is also known as Enterprise Chef in
this case your workstation server and
node all are located within the
Enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between Chef client
server and private Chef in case of Chef
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the Enterprise
version of Chef also provides the
Liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the Hands-On so before we dive into our
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using two
virtual boxes both sent to S7 one will
be used as workstation while the other
will be a node so we are just using one
node to make things simple the server
will be used as a service on the cloud
now these are the steps we'll be
performing during our demo we'll first
download and install the chef DK on our
workstation we then make an empty
cookbook file and we'll write a recipe
into it we need to then set up the
server so as I mentioned earlier server
will be a service on the cloud so you'll
have to create a profile but this will
be completely free we then link the
workstation to the server and we'll
upload the recipe to the server the
nodes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo We Begin our demo here's my
Oracle VM virtualbox manager I have two
machines here I've already created my
workstation and node both of these are
sent to S7 machines just for you to
differentiate this is my terminal and
for my workstation it's a black
background with white text and as of my
note it's a black background with green
text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for Chef DK installation
go to the first link which is your
Chef's official page and under Red Hat
Enterprise because our systems a red hat
system select the link of the version
that you're using so I'm using Centos 7
so my operating system version is 7 so
I'll take this link now this is the link
for downloading your Chef DK you copy
this link and go to your terminal guys
notice I'm in the home directory of my
root user so let's install our Chef DK
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and Chef DK's downloaded next step we
need to install it
and this is the version of the chef TK
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks so first let's
make a chef repository So within that
we'll have a folder for holding all our
cookbooks and within our cookbook we'll
write our recipe so we start with the
directory for Chef Repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called cookbooks within
which we'll store each of our cookbooks
move into this folder
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our Chef DK we
have a chef repo folder here and let's
check the contents of the chef repo
and this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that we'll be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create our
first cookbook so the instruction for
creating your first cookbook is Chef
generate
cookbook
and the name of your cookbook so I'm
just giving the name a sample
yeah so our book sample is created now
when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of our cookbook
let's move into sample
and Chi is the command for checking the
hierarchy so here as you can see we have
recipes and under recipes we have
default dot RB so we'll be editing this
default.rb to create a recipe okay so
let's begin with that let's move into
our recipes folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for a recipe is for
installing the httpd package on our node
and then we'll also create a small index
file where we'll just have a simple
content such as welcome or something
like that just to check if a httpd is
working fine so let's begin typing the
code here package httpd
service
httpd
do and what must be done with this
package is that once it's installed it
needs to be enabled and it needs to be
started
and so that's our first task our next
task is creating our HTML file
so as you know all your HTML files will
follow this path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured
your node
and that's it that's a simple code
so our recipe is now ready save it and
exit back to your terminal now what we
need to do is that we need to configure
our server so go to your browser
on the search engine type manage dot
Chef dot IO
so as I mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your login page for the
chef server most of you may not have a
profile already so you go to click here
to get started and fill in the details
it's just like creating an account on
Facebook so I already have my account
I've put in the credentials here I'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there's another box for entering a short
form of your organization now my
organization name was simply learn and
the short form was slp123 so when you
come to the administration tabs under
organization you can see this
organization name Next Step click on
this arrow and you gotta download your
starter kit okay so once you click on
down start a kit you will come to this
page where there's a button for download
starter kit so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal
so you come back to your terminal and
next what you need to do is you need to
unzip your shift starter.zip so for that
first we'll move our Chef starter to the
root so it's currently present under the
downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chefstarter.zip now
let's unzip it
first let's just check the contents of
our root directory right now so we have
our Chef Repository
Chef repo fi uh folder that we created
the chef starter zip that we just moved
and of course the chef DK so now we can
unzip our Chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we
gotta move the chefstarters dot zip file
into our cookbooks which lies inside the
chef repository this is done because
we'll be executing our further commands
to connect our workstation with the
server from the cookbooks because that
is where our sample cookbook is and
that's moved so now we'll run a knife
command so what knife does is that it
uploads your recipes or your cookbooks
onto the server so here's the command
for running your knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
0.1.0 and uploading sample yeah so our
cookbook is uploaded now let's just
check this at our server how we do that
is go back to your browser where you
have open your server
so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured a node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server and you
see here our cookbooks uploaded sample
so a workstation and a server are
connected so now we need to connect our
node with the server so first we move on
to unknown machine
we need to take the IP address of our
node machine
so for the IP address we'll just type
ifconfig
[Music]
right so this is your IP address
192.168.2.190 note this down somewhere
guys
now that's done
go back to your workstation
I'll just keep it this way so I can see
both okay go back to your workstations
terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node so we have taken the IP of our
node and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.2 point the username which is
Root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node on our server I'm
just giving it shift node you can give
it whatever you like we'll just check
the command knife bootstrap the IP
address SSH user our user which is root
SSH password the password for the root
and finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to our browser open
our server service on the cloud and
we'll check the node tab so ideally your
node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here our Chef client service on
the Node has started running so let's
just check this with the server
go to your notes
and here we go so Chef node Ascent OS 7
platform this is our IP so it's all done
so now we need to add a cookbook to the
Run list of this node so come here click
on this Arrow
edit run list
here sample this is the cookbook that we
want to run on our node put on the
current run list and here we have the
Run button just click on that so this
should have transferred our cookbook
onto the node let's check that go to
your node machine
clear this
we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we're running it once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list the changes in
the Run list is updated
so in one minute 56 seconds
a cookbook has run on our node so the
configuration changes should have been
made let's check that it's pretty simple
just go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our HTML page that we created
on our workstation congrats you
configured your first note and I really
hope you did so that is the end of our
demo we have successfully installed the
httpd package on our node and we have
also executed a HTML file if you're
ready to embark on a career path
pulsating with excitement Innovation and
Limitless growth look no further than
simply lens get a postgraduate program
in devops this comprehensive program
equips you with the Knowledge and Skills
to navigate the devops landscape with
confidence explode the depth of
continuous integration delivery and
conclude the intricacies of Automation
and orchestration 45 security like a
digital Fortress and at least a full
potential of cloud Technologies don't
let this once in a lifetime opportunity
slip away ignite your career and join
the ranks of prime Dev professionals
click the link in the description box to
enable the wonders of this course now
I'm using my Oracle VM virtualbox
manager as you can see here I'll have
two machine the master and the note both
of these are sent to as seven machines
as of the server we'll be using this as
a service on the cloud so let's begin
let's have a look at our Master System
first this is my Master System the
terminals open over here and the
terminal color here it's black
background with green text and this is
my note system so the terminal here has
a black background with white text so
you can differentiate between the both
so we start at our Master System the
first thing we need to do is we need to
download the chef DK so you can write
wget which is the command for
downloading and then go to your browser
and just type Chef DK here
the first link
so here you have different versions of
Chef TK depending on the operating
system that you are using you need to
select the appropriate one I'm using the
red hat Enterprise version and that's
number seven so I'm using send to S7 so
this is my link for downloading Chef DK
just copy this link and go back to your
terminal
and paste it here
so your Chef DK is being downloaded this
will take a while right after we
download the chef DK our next step is to
install it on our system
swash fdk is downloaded now let's
install it
so guys this is the version of Chef TK
that you have downloaded so make sure
this is exactly what you type down here
too
so great our Chef DK is installed so
basically our installation for the
workstations done right now but just so
you understand how the flow is we'll
also write a sample recipe on our
workstation so before we do that let's
first create a folder
my folder name Chef repo basically the
chef Repository
and let's move into this folder okay so
we're in next what we need to do is as I
mentioned earlier all your recipes will
be within a cookbook so let's create a
folder which will hold all our cookbooks
and let's move into this too
okay so our next stage is to create the
actual cookbook within which we'll have
our recipe so the command for creating
the cookbook is Chef generate
cookbook sample quiz to sample is the
name of my cookbook so guys please
notice here cookbooks is the directory
that I created which will hold all our
cookbooks and here cookbook is the
keyword so sample is that one cookbook
that we are creating under a folder
cookbooks
and a cookbooks being created great so
that's done moving into a cookbook okay
so when a cookbook sample was created
automatically there's this hierarchical
structure associated with it so let's
have a look at this hierarchical
structure to understand what our
cookbook sample exactly is before we
move on so the command for looking at a
hierarchical structure is tree so as you
see here within our cookbook we have a
folder recipes and under this this the
default.rb recipe this is where we'll be
creating a recipe so we'll just alter
the content of default.rb so let's move
on to finally writing our recipes so
we'll move into this recipes folder
first
so now we'll open our recipe default.rb
in G edit
so the recipe for this particular demo
is to install the httpd package on our
client node that is basically your
Apache server and we'll also be hosting
a very simple web page so let's begin
so the recipes in Chef is written in
Ruby
so I'll explain you the recipe in a
while
okay so the first line is where you
install httpd the second line for
service is where you start or enable the
httpd service on the client node that's
our first task the second part where we
need to create our web page
so this is the path where your web page
will be stored
if you have written any HTML file
previously you know that this is
probably like a default path where our
web pages are created
yep that's it so this is the content
that will be displayed on your web page
if everything works right and I'm pretty
sure it will so now we can save our
recipe and that's done close your G
array so now that we have created the
recipe all our work at the workstation
is completed the next thing we do is we
move on to the server so as I mentioned
earlier we'll be using the server as a
service on the cloud
so go to your browser and here just type
manage.chef.io
so this is the home page of your Chef
server click here to get started we need
to First create an account for using the
chef server this completely free we just
need to give our email ID and a few
other details it's in fact a lot like
creating an account on Facebook or
Instagram
fill in all the details check the terms
of service box
so the next thing you need to do is go
back to your inbox and verify your email
ID so I have my inbox opened here on my
Windows machine so this is my inbox
you'd have received a mail from Chef
software just click on this link to
verify it and create your password
and that's done so let's continue this
on our workstation machine
so type in your username and password
so the first time you log into your Chef
server you'll have this pop-up appear
where you need to create a new
organization so create your organization
so this organization is basically the
name that will be associated with a
collection of the client machines first
thing you do go to your Administration
Tab and download the starter kit so guys
when you're doing this part make sure
that you're on your workstation that is
your opening your Chef server on the
workstation because you need this folder
to be installed here
you save the file so this gets
downloaded so the shift starter kit is
the key to connecting your workstation
with the server and the server with the
node so basically it has a tool called
knife which we'll come across later in
our demo this knife is what takes care
of all the communication and the
transferring of cookbooks between the
three machines in our case the two
machines the workstation and the node
and the one server so let's go back to
our root Direction so our Chef starter
zip file is within a downloads folder
what we do first is we'll move the zip
folder into our cookbooks folder and
then we'll unzip it there because our
cookbooks folder is the one that
contains the recipe and that is where we
require knife tool command to be present
so we can send this recipes over to the
server
so we'll just check the contents of our
cookbooks right now to ensure that our
chefstarter.zip file is within the
cookbooks
yep so it's here so next thing we do is
we need to unzip this folder
great so that's unzipped and this means
that our workstation and our server are
now linked so we just need to use the
knife command tool to transfer or to
upload our recipes which we created on
the workstation onto the server so
before we execute this command we need
to move into our cookbooks directory as
you know that is where we unzipped our
Chef starter kit so that is where our
knife command is present to
and now let's execute the knife command
so it's knife
cookbook upload and Sample so as you
probably recall sample is the name of
the cookbook that we created and within
sample we created our recipe which is
default.rb so we're uploading the entire
cookbook onto the server execute the
command
great so our cookbooks uploaded now
let's check this on our server so move
to your browser where you opened your
Chef server and go to policy so here you
go this is the cookbook we uploaded
sample and it's the first time we
uploaded it so the version
0.1.0 the first version now what you
would notice is if you go to the notes
tab there are no notes present so if you
have no nodes you basically have no
machine to execute your cookbooks and
the nodes are not seen right now because
we have not configured them yet so
that's the next thing we need to do all
this so far was done on your master
machine now we'll move on to the node
machine
so before moving on let's just check the
IP of our node machine
so that's our IP note this down
somewhere and now we move back to our
Workstation
as we already saw that we uploaded a
sample workbook next thing we need to
make sure that our server and node are
able to communicate with each other so
again we use the knife tool for this
tool the command here is knife bootstrap
and enter the IP address of your node
which we just checked
will be logging in there so we'll be
using the node as the root user and then
we also need to specify our root
password for the node
and we give a name to this node so this
is the name by which we'll be
identifying our node at the server
so as you have probably noticed here
we're using the term SSH which is a
secure shell so it basically provides a
Channel of secure communication between
two machines in an unsafe environment
okay so it's done so if your command has
executed right which in our case as we
can see has a chef server and a chef
node must be able to communicate with
each other so if this is so we should be
able to send the cookbook that we
previously uploaded from our workstation
onto the server now from a server to our
node so to do that before we move on to
the node machine we need to go back to
our Chef server let's refresh this page
and as you see here previously under the
notes tab we did not have any node
mentioned now we do Chef node which is
the node we wanted to identify our node
by which is a Centaurus platform and
that's our IP so it's active for two
hours that's the uptime last check-in
the last time we checked into our node
was a minute back and yeah that's pretty
much it so now we'll create a run list
and we'll add our sample to this run
list so just click on your node and
you'll see the small Arrow here in the
end click on that edit run list and
under available recipes we have a
cookbook sample present so drag and drop
this to the current run list and accept
it okay so now that we updated our run
list our recipe is sent to our node what
we next need to do is that we need to
execute this at our node so now we'll
move on to our node machine
shift line is the command to execute
your
so while this recipe is executing you
can see what exactly is happening a
recipe was to install HTTP repackage
first which is your Apache server so the
first line that's done and it's up to
date the second line it's enabled third
line the service is started and the
fourth line is where your contents
created for the web page at this very
location so by the look of this
everything should work fine so how do we
check this we can just go to our browser
and the search bar just type localhost
and there you go so our httpd package
which is the patchy server is installed
and our sample web page is also hosted
congratulations on completing the chef
demo if you have any doubts regarding
the demo please put them in the comment
section below and we'll definitely reply
to you so I hope you guys really like
the video if you did please hit the like
button also subscribe to our Channel if
you haven't so yet we have more
installation videos coming up so stay
tuned installation procedure for the
configuration management tool puppet so
what exactly is the use of puppet if you
consider the scenario of an organization
which has a very large infrastructure
it's required that all the systems and
servers in this infrastructure is
continuously maintained at a desired
State this is where puppet comes in
puppet automates this entire procedure
thus reducing the manual work so before
we move on to the demo let me tell you
what the architecture of puppet looks
like so puppet has two main components
you have the puppet master and the
puppet client the Puppet Master is where
you write the configuration files and
store them and the puppet client are
basically those client machines which
require the configuration in case of
puppet these configuration files that
you write are called manifest so let's
move on to the demo so here are my two
machines the first is the server system
which is basically a master where you'll
write your configuration files and the
others the node or the client system so
let's have a look at both of these
machines this my node system the
terminals open here and the terminal has
a black background with white text and
as of my server or the Master machine it
has a black background with green text
so we started a server machine the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
remove the firewall so in a lot of cases
there are chances that the firewall
stops the connection between your server
and your node now since I'm doing a demo
and I'm just showing you how a puppet
Works between two virtual boxes I can
safely remove the firewall without any
worries but when you're implementing
puppet in an organization or a number of
systems on a local network be careful
about the consequences of doing so
so a firewall is disabled next thing
that we do is we'll change the host name
of our server system now while using the
puppet tool it's always advisable that
you name your server's host as puppet
this because the puppet tool identifies
the hostname puppet by default as the
host name for the master or the server
system
let's just check if the host name is
changed successfully yeah so that's done
so as you see still localhost is
appearing as the host name so just close
your terminal and start it again
and you see here the host team has been
changed to puppet okay so the next thing
that we have to do is we install our
Puppet Labs make sure your system is
connected to the net
right so Puppet Labs is installed next
we need to install the puppet server
service on our server system
now that our puppet server Services
installed we need to move into the
system configurations for our puppet
server so the path for that is ATC
sysconfig puppet server
so this is a configuration file for the
puppet server now if you come down to
this line now this line here this is the
line which allocates memory for your
puppet server now you must remember that
puppet is a very resource extensive tool
so just in case to ensure that we do not
encounter any errors because of out of
memory we will reduce these sizes so as
of now we have 2GB allocated by default
we'll change to 512 MB
now in a lot of cases it may work
without doing so but just to be on the
safer side we make this change
save it
and go back to your terminal we are now
ready to start our puppet server service
the first time you start your puppet
server service it may take a while next
we need to enable this
and if your puppet server service is
started and enabled successfully this is
the output that you would get in case
you're still not sure you can always
check the status at any point of time
and as you see here it's active so
everything is fine as of now next thing
we do is we'll move on to our agent
system or a client or node system
so here too we'll have to install Puppet
Labs but before we do so we need to make
a small change in our host file so let's
open the host file
yeah so this is a host file we need to
add a single line here which specifies a
puppet master so first we put our Puppet
Masters IP address followed by the
hostname and then we'll add a DNS for
our puppet server so let's just go back
to a server system and find out its IP
address
and that's my IP address for the server
system
now the host name of our puppet server
and a DNS for it
save this file
and return to your terminal
so now we can download our Puppet Labs
on the node system is the exact same
procedure that you followed for
downloading Puppet Labs on your server
system too
so in my node system the Puppet Labs is
already downloaded so the next thing is
we need to install a puppet agent
service
so puppet is a pull type of
configuration tool what this means is
that all your configuration files that
you'll be writing on your server is
pulled by the node system as and when it
requires it so this is the
co-functionality of the agent service
which is installed on your client node
or agent system so my puppet agent
service is installed so next I'll just
check if my puppet server is reachable
from this node system
so 8140 is a port number that the puppet
server must be listening on and it's
connected to puppet so that guarantees
that your server is reachable from the
node system
so now that everything's configured
right we can start our agent service
so guys you would have noticed that the
command for starting the agent service
is a little more complex in the command
for starting your server service this is
because when you start your agent
service you're not just starting a
service but you're also creating a
certificate this is a certificate that
will be sent over to your master system
now at the Master System there's
something called the certificate
Authority this gives the master the
rights to sign a certificate if it
agrees to share information with that
particular node so let's execute this
command which does both the function of
sending the certificate and starting
your agent service so as you can see
here our services started successfully
it's in a running State now we'll move
to our Master System or This Server
system
so first we'll have a look at the
certificates that we received the
certificate should be in this location
so as you can see here this is the
certificate that we just received from
our agent service so this here within
codes is the name of our certificate so
next when we are signing the certificate
this is the name we'll provide to
specify that this is the particular
certificate that we want to sign so the
minute we sign a certificate the node
that send the certificate gets a
notification that the master has
accepted your request so after this we
can begin sharing our manifest files now
here's the command for signing this
certificate
okay so our certificate is signed which
means that the nodes request is approved
and the minute the certificate is signed
the request is removed from this list so
now if we execute the same command as we
did to check the list of all the
certificates we will not find this
certificate anymore let's just check
that so as you see now there are no more
requests pending because we have
accepted all the requests if you want to
have a look at all the certificates that
is signed or unsigned you can use the
same command with the addition of all
and all the certificates received so far
will be listed as you can see here the
plus sign indicates that the Certificate
request has already been accepted so now
that our certificate is signed the next
thing we do is we'll create a sample
manifest file
so this is the path that you create your
manifest files in
a file name is sample.pp and our files
created so right now we have no content
in this file we'll just check if the
agent is receiving it and once that's
confirmed We'll add some content to the
file so let's move to our agent system
now this is the command to execute at
the agent system to pull your
configuration files
so a catalog is applied in 0.02 seconds
so now that the communication between
our agent system and our Master system
is working perfectly fine let's add some
content to the previous placeholder file
that we created on our Master System
so now we open the same file in an
editor
okay so we are going to write a code for
installing the httpd package on our node
system which is basically a Apache
service node and then within codes
insert the hostname of your node system
so my note system Source name is client
the package you wish to install which in
our case is httpd
and the action to be performed
and that's it a very small and simple
code save this file
now let's go back to our node system
and let's pull this second version of
the same configuration file so every
time you execute this command as we did
previously to what happens is that the
agent service so the agent service
basically checks on your master system
if there's any new configuration file
added or if there's any change to the
previous configuration file made if so
then the catalog is applied once again
so now our catalogs applied in 1.55
seconds so now to check if our catalog
served its purpose let's just open a
browser
just type localhost here
and as you can see if your httpd package
has been successfully installed the
Apache testing page will appear here so
we come to an end of our installation
and configuration of the configuration
management tool puppet if you have any
doubts regarding this please post them
in the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you so what will
we learn today today you'll learn about
why we should use puppet what exactly is
puppet the puppet architecture how
puppet works and finally we'll have a
demo on the installation of Apache on
our node so let's begin why puppet so
consider the scenario of an MNC the MNC
puts together the small team of system
administrators they're responsible for
taking care of the infrastructure of
this organization now this
infrastructure could consist of data
centers server centers and many such
components fortunately for the MNC they
were doing extremely well so the number
of clients kept growing consistently and
with this came a boom in the
infrastructure size now here is where
the problem came in with such a large
infrastructure the small team that they
put together in no way could manage this
so what do we do the solution seems
pretty simple right just increase the
size of the team sure we'll increase the
size of team but when do you think we
can put an upper limit on the size when
do we get to stabilize this team so here
is where puppet comes in with puppet a
small team is enough to take care of
this large infrastructure this is
because the data center server centers
all of them can be updated in a matter
of seconds with puppet entire load of
doing so has now shifted from the team
onto the tool not only this with puppet
if servers do fail and there's a very
high chance of servers failing when
you're considering an organization the
scale of an MNC puppet can instantly
roll them back to their previous working
States and if that wasn't enough puppet
also provides the capability to deploy
servers on demand and enforce security
on them now all of this is done through
simple coding which is written in Ruby
we look at how puppet Works more so now
that we know why we should use puppet
let's have a look at what exactly is
puppet so first and foremost puppet is a
configuration management tool as I
already mentioned in the beginning of
this video so this simply means that
puppet ensures that all your systems are
maintained at a consistent state so
consider that you want to deploy a
number of servers now you require these
servers to be identical if this task is
given to a human there's a very good
chance that those systems will not be
identical or some of them may even fail
women are prone to errors you cannot
blame them so puppet ensures that all
these servers are deployed on time and
they are identical secondly puppet is
also a deployment tool this simply means
that puppet has the capability to deploy
your applications your services your
softwares all of this on your notes or
automatically and finally puppet
implements infrastructure as code now
this term infrastructure as code is a
very important one when it comes to the
devops approach you would have noticed
this term being used in a previous video
on Chef 2. if not you can always click
the top right corner to know more so
what is this term infrastructure as code
mean infrastructure's code simply means
that all your policies your tasks your
instructions everything is written in
coded format so in case of puppet
specifically all of this is written in
the Ruby language so now that we know
what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
Master Slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and Below we have the puppet
clients so the Puppet Master is a system
where your system administrator sits the
clients are those systems which require
configuration you can have n number of
clients connected to the puppet master
so don't worry we look into each each of
these components in detail firstly we
have the puppet master so the Puppet
Master is where the system administrator
sits and he or she types in the codes
here so the codes are not only written
in the system but they are also stored
here and whenever the client requires
these codes for their configuration they
simply request it so manifest is the
first sub-competent of the Puppet Master
these are the actual files where the
codes are written so in case of puppet
these are Ruby files modules tie
manifest templates and files into a
single unit now these codes dictate the
instructions for performing various
tasks on your client the next component
is templates so if manifest are your
code templates are the data so let me
explain this to you with an example
consider you want to create a file
called index.html on one of your client
machines so what you do is you write the
code for creating this file in your
manifest and the content of this file is
written in your templates then you
simply link them but here's the thing
when you divide your code and data in
this way it's a very clean structure so
it's preferred to do it in this manner
files are your static contents so the
files are basically sent to your client
and they are simply downloaded at the
client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the passer at the master itself
modules ties the Manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
Puppet Master CA which stands for
certificate Authority now as we will see
later in this video The Puppet Master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of SSL certificates
so when the client sends over the
certificate to the master CA provides
the master the authority to sign these
certificates the minute the master signs
a certificate the master is basically
saying that yes this client is
registered with me and I agree to
exchange data with this client a next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have Factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our clients
and sending this data over to the Puppet
Master at the master this data is
compared against the Manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
Master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the SSL
certificates SSL stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted Channel between two components
what this encrypted Channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete Security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the Puppet Master the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with Master Slave lecture
so the client so far is not a client it
is just a system and we will refer to
the system as system a so system a sends
over a client certificate to the master
associated with this client certificate
is the host name of system a now Master
goes through the certificate it's easy
host name and then it decides whether it
wants to form a communication link with
the system a if it does it signs the
certificate and the signed certificate
is sent back to system a now the system
a is officially a client the minute the
master signed the client certificate it
said that yes I am willing to exchange
information with this system and I do
take the system as one of my clients so
now that the system is officially a
client it can request for data from the
master and the master will simply send
over the data now we are here to talk
about puppet so if this was a puppet
master and this was a puppet client then
the first three stages will be the same
so the puppet client sent over the
certificate to the master the master
Sciences certificate sends it back and
the client request for data now by data
here of course we mean the configuration
data those are the Manifest or even
could be your files so what happens
after this request after this request
the factor service which is present on
your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
the software now all this information is
collected it's called the fact and it's
sent over to the master at the master
this information that is the fax is
compared against the Manifest so why
does the master do this the master
basically compares the facts against the
Manifest to know if what the Manifest is
about to perform is already performed on
these systems so if the Manifest has
some additional functionality they are
compiled into catalogs and then these
catalogs are sent over to the client now
remember those agent Services which
existed in your clients here's where
they come in the agents take the catalog
and execute them on the client once
executed these catalogs make the
required changes on the client and a
report is generated this report is then
sent back to the master so the master
keeps record of all the changes that's
made in the system and this comes very
handy when one of the systems fail and
it's required to be rolled back to its
previous working state so this entire
procedure can be repeated n number of
times and can be repeated at regular
intervals so if you have a scenario
where a system needs to be configured
every 30 minutes what you can do is you
can set your interval and automatically
every 30 minutes your systems will be
configured and we reach the final and
the most exciting part of our video
which is the Hands-On so today I'll be
showing you how you can use puppet to
install Apache on one of your client
machines so we'll be using two machines
here we'll have a server and we'll have
a node machine the server is essentially
your master the node is your client I'm
just using the term server and note
instead because I want to keep it very
close to as they are used in the command
now both these machines are going to be
sent to as seven machines and I have
Oracle VM virtualbox installed on my
machine so on that I've simply created
two virtual boxes both Center S7 of
course so before we move on to the
actual demo I'll just take you through
the various steps so first we'll install
the puppet server on our server or
Master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start the service to and the minute
you start the puppet agent service and
SSL certificate is created so this
certificate will have the host name of
your node attached to it and this is how
the master or the server will recognize
this certificate and then it'll sign
this certificate so once your master or
the server signs the certificate you can
write your manifest so the Manifest has
just the codes for configuration and
once that 2 is done you shift back to
your client or the node system and you
run the Asian service so once you run
the agent service your manifest or your
catalogs because as you know the
manifests are compiled into catalogs
these are executed on your node and this
will make the required changes so that's
how this entire process is going to work
now let's move on to the actual demo
this is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course it's the client
so let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the Master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our Master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you missed this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the host
name the last word you see there that's
the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our host
name is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the IP of this
machine so for that you just type if
config
enter
so this is your IP guys
under enp 0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the IP will
differ for you guys needless to say
okay
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is sudo because
we want the root permission
system
CTL
top
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the Puppet
Labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net also you won't
be getting an IP if it's not for the
first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lab
let's see
foreign
again
okay so the Puppet Labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppets server on the
Master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so I just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change in
our system config puppet server file so
let's just move to the file first
this file will open in VI editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2GB
so we are going to reduce the size
512 MB should be enough
so guys notice here I did not type the B
okay so I just changed this to XMS
512 m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite Troublesome okay so
now we can start our puppet server
service
foreign
okay so that's done so basically a
puppet server service has started it's
running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our Etc
host file with sudo because you need to
make a few changes and save it open this
in the vi terminal
foreign
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the IP for your puppet server
machine
puppet
Dash master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading Puppet
Labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
okay
foreign
Labs is downloaded now we need to
install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent Services
installed we'll start this service so
I'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
foreign
as you can see here ensure changed stop
to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an SSL certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the
hostname of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's localhost.local domain so a
certificate should have this attached to
it so guys the first time your client
sends a certificate the name of the
certificate itself is usually the host
name of the machine so a certificate's
name should be localhost.local domain
we'll check this on our Master System
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client and we just started the
client we should have technically just
one certificate and it will be so
foreign
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
yeah as you can see here the certificate
is signed
signed Certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
This is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we are just checking here we are just
creating this file and then we'll go to
our client machine and just check there
if we can access this file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on a client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our Master server put some
content into this file and see how the
execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the host name of our client
machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the Apache service package on Centos
is called the httpd
so this line that I just typed in is the
action it'll ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so the suckline machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so I just cleared the screen now we'll
start the Apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and add localhost you must have the
testing page for your Apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
Apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
Apache service on our puppet line
what is that you should be expecting
from this video let's say what is
selenium whenever we are learning about
any tool it's good to know a little bit
brief history of it so we will look into
how selenium has evolved over years to
become the most popular web application
automation tool and why use Webdriver
and then we will understand what a
selenium driver while we learn this I
will also be touching upon some
drawbacks of manual testing and how
automation helps and then a deep dive
into architecture of Webdriver as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the limitations of
selenium Webdriver and how we work
around this and then I will demonstrate
the web driver in action for which I
will use a simple web application use
case to automate so let's get started so
before we talk about selenium let's
understand a few drawbacks of manual
testing let's take an example of a very
simple use case as a user I want to
login to my web application using
username and password a very simple use
case and it's a very common use case for
any kind of web application you're
working so as a tester what do I do I
need to write multiple test case to test
this use case so I can use multiple data
sets like valid credentials invalid
credentials null values and so on to
test this particular use case and then
what you do you start executing the test
cases one by one you find bugs then your
developers fixes them and then you will
need to rerun all the test cases again
and again until all the bugs offer this
use case are fixed and your application
is ready to ship now look into this now
this brings us to the First Merit
demerit of the manual testing which is
what if one has to run test cases with
100 transactions and repeat them again
and again this is going to be a very
time consuming process and very boring
also it is more error prone since it's
done manually and human mistakes are
bound to happen the third challenge is
the scope of manual testing itself is
very limited for example say regression
testing ideally you would want to run
all the test cases which you have
written but since it's a manual process
this is going to be very tedious to do
and also you would not have all the
luxury of time to execute all test cases
so what do you do you start picking up
those test cases which are very
important to be run and that way you are
kind of limiting the scope of your
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is going to be
impractical what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measures as a part
of your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on your
application under test and all these
things manually it is very difficult to
perform and it's not feasible also and
to submit all this creating manual test
reports after running all the tests who
wants to really do that and again
another level of challenge here is say
if you're working on an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers the testers are building the
test cases executing them as and when
the bills are available to them this
happens iteratively and hence you will
need to run all those test cases which
you have written multiple times during
your development cycle and doing this
manually definitely is going to be very
tedious and boring and is this effective
of doing it no so what do we do we
automate it so this tells us why we want
to automate one for faster execution two
to be less error prone three to help
frequent execution of our tests so there
were many tools available in the market
for automation one such tool was
selenium and that brings us to the slide
Advent of selenium so much before
selenium the various tools in the market
like rft qtp just to name a few popular
ones so selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called Jason Huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was kind of working on a
web application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
in doing manual testing of his
application repeatedly so what he did
was he wrote a JavaScript program that
automatically control the browser
actions and then he named that as
JavaScript test Runner he made this open
source which was later renamed selenium
core and this is how the selenium came
into existence so with this brief
history of selenium let's understand
what is selenium and what are its main
features selenium is the most popular
and widely used automation tool for
automatic web applications it enables us
to test web application on different
kind of process like Internet Explorer
Chrome Firefox Safari Opera and so on
and also they introduced support for
edge browser after Microsoft introduced
it selenium is a set of tools and
libraries to facilitate automation of
web application it is not a single tool
it has multiple components and those we
will be seeing in some time all these
tools together help us test the web
application so selenium is open source
and it is platform independent this is
the biggest reason why people are
preferring this tool because it is free
of cost qtp and rft which I just talked
about are rechargeable one selenium
scripts can run on any platform because
selenium is primarily developed in
JavaScript so it is platform independent
well as you know it's common for manual
testers not to have in-depth programming
background so selenium has a record and
replay back tool called the selenium IDE
which can be used to create a set of
actions as a script and to replay that
script but this is mainly used for demo
purpose why because selenium is such a
powerful tool that you should be able to
take advantage of all its features and
not just be with a record and replay
tool right so that way there are a lot
of record and replay tool anyway
available in the market the selenium
provides support for different
programming language Java python C sharp
Ruby PHP and so on you can write your
test scripts in any language you prefer
or you like and again as I said one need
not really no in-depth or Advanced
knowledge of these languages you would
still be able to write the selenium
scripts with a basic knowledge of this
programming language and also selenium
supports various operating systems you
can run selenium test on Windows Mac or
Linux or even say if you have a Ubuntu
machine you can always run your selenium
test on Ubuntu machines so of you can
run the test on any platform of your
choice okay so let's go now a little
more deeper into selenium so I said that
selenium is not a single tool but it is
a suite of tools right so now let's look
at what are those major components which
comprises of the selenium Suite first
one is the selenium ID so selenium ID is
the most simplest tool in the whole
Suite of the selenium it is nothing but
it's an integrated development
environment earlier this IDE was simply
a Firefox extension and it offered a
recorded playback functionality it was a
very simple and easy to use and as I
said mainly this is used for prototyping
or for only the demo purposes right and
not creating automation for your
real-time projects because you know of
its own limitation of being a simple
record and replay tool however selenium
what happens selenium IDE it died at
Firefox 55 so that means the support for
IDE was stopped from Firefox 55 version
but the good news is very recently all
new brand new selenium idea has been
launched and also what they have done is
they've made this cross browser that
means you can install the extension on
Chrome the ID extension on Chrome or as
an add-on on Firefox so it is supported
on both the browsers Firefox and Chrome
on it so while we are talking of this
IDE let me also show you uh how the
latest ID on the Chrome looks okay for
that let me go and launch my Chrome
browser so let me just open a new tab
and what I'll do is I'll search for
selenium ID for Chrome download then I
go to this website and then you can see
here selenium ID offered by
seleniumhq.org so what I simply need to
do is like you install any extension on
your Chrome browsers I just say add to
Chrome and this adds this extension on
your Chrome browser now it has added so
selenium IDE has been added to Chrome
use this extension by clicking the size
so can you see the site icon here which
is selenium ID that's it so once you
have installed this you are free to
start using the ID on this Chrome
browser similarly you can do adding of
this add-on which is called as add-on on
Firefox so go to the Firefox browser
search for the selenium ID and just
install that Adder so let's get back to
our presentation so that's about the ID
so what's our next component our next
component is selenium RC which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium RC is used to write web
application test in different
programming languages it interacts with
the browser with the help of RC server
it has an RC server through which only
it can interact with the web browser and
how does it communicate it uses a simple
HTTP get and post request and this is
what was called as selenium 1.0 version
but it got deprecated in 2.0 version and
it was completely removed in 3.0 and was
replaced with something called as web
driver so we will be talking in detail
about why this happened what were the
drawbacks of RC which led to replacing
with a web driver so now that brings us
to third component which is the selenium
Webdriver this is the most important
component it is just a programming
interface to create and execute our test
cases of course it's a successor of RC
because there were certain drawbacks
which I just mentioned and we will be
going in detail of what it were so
Webdriver what the major difference what
we see with the web driver is the
architecture of the web driver is much
simpler than RC for the reason that
Webdriver interacts with the browser
directly unlike your RC where it meets
an RCA server to interact with the
browser so this gave a lot of Advantage
an edge over the RC the fourth component
selenium grid selenium grid is used to
run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with selenium
driver you can only do the sequential
execution however in real time
environment you know that there is
always a need to run tests on
distributed environment for example say
you have a web application and say you
have autumn committed around hundreds of
thousands of test cases and you need to
run them as a regression suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
OS why since you have automated them and
your application supports multiple
browsers and Os now imagine the time
taken to run these thousand test cases
sequentially with the web driver right
it's going to take quite a bit of time
so what you need is to run this parallel
on multiple machines Matrix across the
browsers and operating system and that
is where the grid helps you in achieving
that so grid has this Hub and node
concept and it helps in achieving the
parallel execution which I just talked
about so you can check out our detailed
video on selenium credit on Central all
right so now we've talked about the
components of the selenium so let's look
at the different versions it evolved
into so when I talked about RC I
mentioned that this was selenium one
version so now let's understand how this
evolved over years and what it offers
today so when Jason Huggins introduced
selenium the tool was called JavaScript
program he called it as JavaScript test
Runner it had one major issue now that
is something called as same origin
policy so what does the same origin
policy it says that a JavaScript when
executed in a domain can access web
pages in that domain only and it cannot
access any web pages in another domain I
will repeat it same origin policies
dictates that a JavaScript is executed
in a domain can access web pages in that
domain only and it cannot access web
pages in another domain for example say
every web page inside google.com domain
like search email Drive can be
accessible but nothing outside of
google.com like say if you want to
access a web page inside Amazon or Yahoo
is possible to access why because of the
simple reason which is a security
reasons now to overcome this Paul Homan
created something called a selenium
remote control server and why did he
create that he wanted to trick the
browser in believing that the selenium
core through which you're going to run
your scripts and your web application
under test are in the same domain with
which you are able to achieve run your
test on your web application without
having to get into this issue of same
origin policy so this is what was a
version one of selenium and we called it
as selenium remote control and then what
happened in 2007 Simon Stewart okay he
invented this web driver now why did he
invent this because the architecture of
selenium RC was little complicated RC
required a separate server to talk to
your browsers so what he did was he
removed the requirement of having a
separate server in the RC and this was
the selenium 2 version now since it was
a transition phase both the selenium RC
and the web driver coexisted in selenium
2. while the Webdriver was still under
development and then what happened in
3.0 selenium is the selenium core which
is the RC was completely deprecated and
only the web driver was made available
so in this series of videos we will be
working with selenium 3.0 and now
selenium 4 is already around the corner
so Alpha is already released as of the
day when this video was met and I
believe some of the features what the
selenium 4 is going to offer is they are
moving towards w3c Webdriver
standardization one and also there is
going to be an improved ID the ID which
I just talked about that it's a improved
version of the previous ID and then an
improved version of selenium grid also
so they might be doing a GUI based grid
right so these are some of the major
features expected in this version while
selenium Webdriver so let's look at what
led to replacement of selenium RC with
this web driver for that first we need
to understand the selenium RC and its
shortcoming as I said selenium RC is a
simple tool to write tests for web
applications in various supported
programming languages like Java python
rupee and C sharp and this is the
architecture of the selenium RC at a
very high level first you need to write
test scripts in any of the supported
languages of your church so if you're
more favoring a little bit Java you
would be writing your test scripts all
your commands in the Java so before we
start writing the test one of the major
requirement right required for the RC to
run is your RC server so first you need
to start this RC server before you run
even a single line of code and this RC
server is a separate application and now
what is the function of this RC server
the selenium server or the RC server is
responsible for receiving Cellini's
commands from your test script it
interprets them and then reports the
result back to your selenium test now
what are the selenis commands these
commands are nothing but the commands
written in your test script these are
called as selenis command that is what
the selenium server does now after the
selenium servers function let's look at
how the browser interaction happens the
browser interaction happens through this
RC server this RC server uses a simple
HTTP post and get request to communicate
and how does this communication happen
this RC server acts like a proxy say for
example your test scripts asks for
launching a browser this command from
your test script goes to the server and
then this RC server launches the browser
injects its JavaScript into the browser
once this is done all the subsequent
calls that is all the subsequent causes
all the rest of the commands which you
have written after launching the browser
go to this RC server and then to the
actual web server so it routes all the
commands are getting routed through your
RC server to your web browser upon
receiving this instruction so what does
a core do it executes these commands as
the JavaScript commands on your browser
so once these are executed the response
from the browser or the results what you
say are sent back to the RC server and
RC server is responsible for sending it
back to your test and then the test
results are displayed here now if you
see this complete cycle from starting
your command from your test script
talking to the RC server then RC server
talks to the web browser it injects the
JavaScript here runs your command takes
back the results sends it to RC server
and then back to this test script this
whole cycle gets repeated for every
command which is written in your test
script and this is how your test case
gets executed all right so now
everything is fine so great we are
unable to run the scripts we are able to
launch the browser we are able to
execute all the commands so what was the
problem here why was still RC not good
enough for the reason why the RC was
still not good enough was one the
architecture of RC is very complicated
because of that intermediate RC server
to communicate with the browser so there
is no direct interaction with the
browser this RC server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts that means it has an additional
setup because that is RC server is a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser the execution of the
commands takes very long time it is very
slow why because because we saw that
every command written in our test
scripts needs to make a full trip from
your test script to the RC server to the
core to the browser and then back which
makes your overall automation test
execution very very slow so how does
selenium Webdriver now overcomes this
this is a simple architecture of
selenium Webdriver even in Webdriver we
have test scripts we have a web browser
and a web server however we do not have
an additional server for communication
like the RC server which we saw in the
selenium RC this makes the architecture
of web driver very simple the selenium
Webdriver that's one of the biggest
advantages the selenium Webdriver does
not use an additional server then
secondly it makes direct cost to your
browser using your browser's native
support automation so since there is no
intermediate server there the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level itself now due to this
direct communication the overall the
trips what we saw from the RC server to
the browser and from the browser back to
the RC server and to the test script
right this was an indirect communication
since this whole thing was avoided the
speed of test execution is much faster
in RC and this overall architecture of
the web driver if you see is much much
simpler than what the RC provides so
this was the major drawback from the RC
and this is where web driver replaced RC
now was that all because of the
architecture no there were a few other
shortcomings with the RC apis and
selenium RC a single function has
several commands redundant and confusing
API RCA is less object oriented API
though there are good set of apis to
work with they are pretty redundant and
confusing for example how and when to
use a type key or a type command another
example is a mouse commands click or to
use click add or when to use Mouse at or
Mouse top so this was getting pretty
confusing for the developers and to top
it all this every browser interprets the
command differently which makes your
test cases brittle when it has to work
on the multiple process developers had a
tough time making their scripts cross
browser and they had to add
browser-specific code whereas selenium
driver comes with a set of more matured
and simpler apis which are pretty
straightforward to use for example a
simple click to simulate a click action
on any web element send Keys which
simply means send the text to any web
element on your web page scroll up or
down on the web page and so on so we
will see more of these commands when we
actually start working with the web
driver another difference is the browser
support though both RC and Webdriver
supports multiple browser RC does not
have support for HTML unit which is a
headless browser whereas the web driver
supports testing on headless browser now
what is this headless browser headless
browser is a browser which does not have
a UI it makes testing much faster
because it does not need a real browser
for testing now to summarize all this so
if you look at the RC and the Webdriver
comparison which we talked about as is a
complex architecture whereas web driver
has a simple architecture for the main
reason that Webdriver removed the need
of having an intermediate server RC the
execution of your test cases or your
automation scripts it's much slower than
the web driver RCA requires a RC server
to interact with the browser whereas the
selenium web driver interacts with the
browser directly using the web drivers
also we saw the apis which RC provides
which are pretty confusing and web
drivers we have much easier and easy to
use apis no support for HTML unit
browser which is a headlight browser
selenium driver also provides support
for HDMI unit browser now that we have
understood what selenium RC is and why
Webdriver replaced RC let's go another
level deeper into web driver so what is
selenium Webdriver we know that the web
driver in its simplest term is a tool or
a programming interface to create and
execute test cases on a web application
it supports multiple browsers IE Firefox
Chrome Opera Safari Edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what is in headless
browser some of the features of
Webdriver so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver got introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. web driver can run on
any platform of your choice Linux
Windows Mac and even if you have a
Ubuntu machine you can run your selenium
webcraft and what does this actual web
driver is it an ID no it is a simply and
programming interface to run your test
cases and how does it work the test
cases are created and executed using web
elements or the objects using web
locators and Webdriver methods so once
we get into the demo or once you start
understanding how selenium works you
will understand what are these web
driver methods and the locating
techniques which are used to perform
these actions on web element selenium
Webdriver is pretty fast why since the
the web driver interacts directly with
the browser and does not have an
intermediate server like RC each browser
with which you want to work with has its
own driver on which your application
runs and this driver is responsible to
make the browser understand the command
which are being passed from your script
like a click of button or entering some
text in any of the input Fields through
your scripts you tell which browser you
want to work with say you want to do all
this action say on the Chrome browser if
you want to work with Chrome browser
then the Chrome driver is responsible
for interpreting your instructions from
your test case and executing them on the
web application which is launch.chrome
browser only so like RC Webdriver also
supports multi-programming languages in
which you can write your test scripts
like the ones which are listed here also
web driver supports different Frameworks
like test NG junit and N unit when we
talk about the limitations of Webdriver
you will appreciate how this support for
various is Frameworks and tools help in
making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
now let's try to know what is the
architecture of selenium Webdriver
Webdriver has four different components
in it one we have the client libraries
or what is also called as language
binding since I said selenium supports
multiple languages and you're free to
use any of the supported languages to
create your automation script there are
libraries available on selenium website
which you need to download and use them
let me show you that so let's go to my
Chrome browser so I have the selenium HQ
website already launched here so guys if
you're working on selenium this website
seleniumhq.org is going to be Bible so
everything and whatever you need to know
and work with selenium is available here
for now we want to see the client
Library so the language binding so for
that what you need to do is if you go to
the download section here can you see
here the selenium client and Webdriver
language binding so for each of the
languages which is supported you have a
a client Library which you can download
from here so if you're working on Java
you need to download the Java libraries
if you're working on python you need to
download the python libraries right so
these are called as language bindings so
selenium provides lot of apis for us to
interact with the browsers and when we
do the demo I will be showing some of
those apis now what are these abs these
apis are the rest apis rest is
representational stateful APS and
everything for selenium happens to this
rest calls the second component is the
Json wire protocol so what is Json
JavaScript object notation and it's a
standard for exchanging data over the
web so for example you want to launch a
web application through your script so
what selenium does is it creates a Json
payload and posts the request to the
browser driver right and where are this
browser driver these are here right and
what are these browser drivers these are
a driver specific to each browser so if
you see here you can see drivers for
Chrome Firefox Opera Safari and Edge
rate so so we interact with the actual
browsers here using these drivers and
how does this happen this driver
establishes connection with the real
browser without revealing the internal
logic of browser functionality right
that's exactly the function of this
browser driver now what does that mean
let's say we want to execute a test
script so what happens when the script
is executed is an HTTP request is
generated and sent to browser driver for
each command in the script and then the
driver receives the request through this
HTTP server and does all the execution
on the actual browser once the execution
is done the execution results are just
sent back over the same HTTP server to
your test scripts so this is the
simplest form of the architecture of the
selenium Webdriver well now as every
tool has its own advantages and its
limitations so let's look at what
selenium limited web driver limitations
are cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like APM selling M is
for automating web application it cannot
handle mobile right mobile applications
are different and they have its own set
of automation tools however what
selenium provides is the support for
integrating this APM tool APM tool is
one of the popular tools for mobile
application automation right so it
provides a support for integrating APM
tools so using APM and selenium you can
still achieve mobile application
automation now when do you usually use
this in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices so that means you need a
mechanism to run your test cases on your
web browser as well as your mobile
process right and this is how you
achieve it using selenium when we talked
about components of selenium I said that
the web driver can achieve only
sequential execution but in real time we
know that we just cannot live with this
we need to have a parallel execution on
multiple machines and on multiple
process so this limitation of web driver
is replaced by having the grid which
helps us in achieve the parallel
execution and do check out our video on
more details on selenium grid selenium
Webdriver has limited reporting
capability it can help create basic
reports but definitely we need more
especially when we are working on a big
project we need good reports to be
created so what it does is we have a
support for multiple tools like test NG
report NG and even the extent reports
which you can integrate with selenium
and generate beautiful reports isn't it
really powerful all right there's
another challenge what we have these are
amongst few of the challenges what I
have put across here there are other
challenges also but always there is a
workaround to get through those
challenge so another challenge which we
have mentioned here is selenium is not
very good with image testing especially
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like Auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate APM so selenium also provides
a way for integrating autoite and the
securely tools so if you look at all
this selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium that makes
it most powerful tool today for
automation okay so let's look at
Webdriver in action so before we do that
let's understand some of the basic
browser commands and functions that we
will be using in our demo today the get
commands so there are six get commands
to perform various actions on the
browser driver dot get this is used to
launch any website application it takes
a string argument and this needs to be a
fully formed URL which you want to
launch driver dot get title so this
method fetches the title of the web page
which you are working with so for
example let's go to eBay so if you just
hover your mouse here can you see the
text there electronics cars fashion
Collectibles coupons and more eBay so
this is nothing but title of this
current pitch and this command helps us
to get the title get current URL so to
get the URL of any page is when you want
to use this command so this will be used
especially when you're working with
multiple web pages and you want to say
print whatever the current URL you're
working on on the console get paid
Source this method dumps the complete
HTML page Source on your console
actually this is not really much used
unless you really need to look at
anything in your HTML pages and then
there are two more get commands related
to Windows handles these are used for
handling multiple tabs and multiple
windows on the browser now we will not
be dealing with this in today's demo
however if you want to know the details
of this command these are available in
our video tutorials for this commands
the next set of commands are the
navigational commands so these are
self-explanatory and basically are used
to navigate between the multiple pages
of your web application the first one
the
driver.navigate.2 is very similar to
driver.get so both does the same
function and then you have navigate dot
pack navigate or forward and navigate
dot refresh so this is used for
refreshing your browser page and then
there are two commands browser commands
which we use one is the driver.close so
this closes the current browser window
so if you've got multiple tabs opened in
the window and you want to close a
particular tab so that is when you use
driver.close and Driver dot quit what it
does it creates the entire browser
session then there are few other
commands and these some of the commands
are listed here however if you see there
is a huge list of commands available in
selenium and since we'll be using just a
few of them in today's demo I have
listed here so let's just understand
these very basic commands which we will
be using driver dot find element now
when you want to work with any
application what is that you need to do
you need to perform actions on the
elements of the web page and these are
called as web elements for example let's
go to our ebay.in so on this website say
you want to search for JBL speakers and
what do you do when you want to search
for this you would identify the search
box and you will enter the text JBL
speakers right and then you go ahead and
click on the search button so this is
the set of operations which you will do
now for us to write this and this is
exactly what you need to do through your
commands for us to really write this
text as JBL speakers I need to know what
this particular element is okay so this
particular input box is my web element
which I need to identify similarly if I
want to click on the search button I
need to identify what this button is and
that's exactly is done by using driver
dot find element selenium has multiple
ways of finding this element it has
eight element locating techniques and
our future videos on selenium do cover
these eight element locating techniques
very much in detail so for us right now
we'll be using couple of them so one is
with ID and one is with a link text the
next one the send keys so as the name
indicates it is used to send a certain
text to any web element you have
identified or you want to work with like
in this example as I said since we want
to search for JBL speakers right I would
be basically sending the text JBL
speakers to this web element using send
Keys click so after entering the text
what we need to do I said we need to
click on the search button so for all
such actions we have methods defined in
selling and one of them is this click
what this does is it just clicks on the
web element or the button which we want
to work with so now with these basic
commands let's go ahead and start
writing our code for our test case so
what is the test case we are going to
write today so this is my use case today
so use case one as a user I want to log
into eBay application search for JBL
speakers and then I want to check the
today's tip so there is something called
as the days D we will go and click on
that and see what are the deals
available I have another use case here
what says is from this website from
wherever we are right navigate to the
simply learn website and navigate back
to the ebay.in so this using this use
case to what I want to show you how do
we use the navigation commands and my
third use case is from the ebay.in I
want to print the page title and close
the browser so with this we are trying
to demonstrate at least few commands
from each of the categories which we
talked about so I will be using eclipse
for writing or test scripts and if you
want to know how to get started with
selenium how do we install selenium you
can refer to our videos on installation
of selenium by simply done okay let me
go to my Eclipse so in eclipse what I
have done is I have already created a
project called selenium demo and in this
project I've gone ahead and created a
Java class in which we will be writing
our test case so the Java class which I
have created is eBay search dot Java and
also what I have done is if you look at
few import statements here I have
imported all the required selenium jars
here so if you look here in the
referenced libraries the way after we
work with Java here right so Java is the
prereq for your Eclipse so you already
have the Java libraries available here
so what I need to do is I also need to
import the selenium jar face and this is
the list of seldium Jar files which you
will need to work with the salinity and
this I've already imported for you then
another thing what I do as a following a
best practice is instead of writing all
my code under this main function here
what I do is I create methods for each
of the use case or the test case which
I'm writing so same thing I am going to
do that today for all the use cases
which we have taken for this demo now
let's get started so what is the first
thing which we need to do the first
thing what we need to do is you need to
declare your web driver so which I've
already done here I've said Webdriver
drive and then I need to launch the
browser before even I go into eBay DOT
in and start performing the other test
now for me to launch browser this is one
method which I've already written here
so let me walk you through this so there
are multiple steps we need to follow for
launching the browser the first thing is
set system property so let's understand
this particular command here the one
which I have highlighted so this is used
to set the property for your gecko
driver now what is a gecko driver if you
remember while we are talking of
Webdriver architecture I said for
whichever browser you want to work with
you need to tell the web driver as which
browser is what you're going to test
with and in my case here I am going to
be using Firefox browser and also if you
remember while explaining the
architecture I said every browser every
browser has its own driver which you
need to download and install and where
is this driver let's go ahead and see
that on the seleniumhq.org so let me go
to my Chrome browser I already have a
seleniumhq.org website open here now on
this website in the download section if
you go down you can see something called
as third party drivers binding and
plugins and here you would see a list of
all browsers gecko driver Chrome Opera
Edge right and HTML unit which is
headless browser so all this browsers
with selenium supports listed and for
each of this browser we have have a
driver associated with it which we can
download so if I want a record driver
what I need to do is I need to click on
this latest link this will take me to
the latest web driver which is available
so depending on the operating system
which you are using right now I'm using
a Mac so I've already downloaded it so
once you download you need to place it
in a particular direct okay so let's go
back to this and now if you see this
path here what I'm highlighting this is
where I have kept my gecko driver so
this gecko driver what you see is my
executable so if you're using using a
Windows machine it will be giggle
driver.exe so this is the driver which
should be working with now coming back
to the system.set property this
particular method or this particular
command is used to set your driver
property it is a key value pair and you
will need to know which Keys depending
on which browsers you're working with
since I'm working on the Firefox browser
the key which I need to set is the
Webdriver gecko dot driver if I am using
Chrome what I simply do is I have a key
called Chrome and then I would set this
path to Chrome driver and this is
exactly you need to do so for you to
even before launch the browser you need
to do this set property so let me change
this back to gecko so now we are clear
till here now what is the next command
which we need to after setting the
property is after setting the property
you have to instantiate the web driver
which is done by using this particular
command driver is equal to new Firefox
driver so once you do this your browser
is going to get launched then once your
browser is launched what is the next
step you do you would be launching the
application on which you want to perform
your test and that is done by using the
command which we just saw now driver dot
get now since I'm going to be working
with ebay.in I have just said driver.get
and the URL fully formed URL so this
particular method is going to help me
launch the Firefox browser and also
launch the eBay application now
advantage of using methods like this is
you can reuse this methods in every test
case which you're going to write or you
can make a common function of this and
just call this function in any of your
test cases now for me to call this
method what am I going to do I am going
to create an object of this class let's
do that object is equal to Newton and
then I need to call this method obj dot
launch browser good so far all right so
now let's get to the first use case so
let's go back to our presentation and
see what was our first use case our
first use case was that we want to
launch the eBay application which we
have already done in the launch browser
method and then we want to search for
JBL speakers now for that what we will
do let me create a method here so I will
call this method I'll say public void
say search product That's My Method name
so I have created a method called search
product now what I need to do is I need
to search for JB speaker so for that let
me go to my Firefox browser and I need
to First identify the search box element
so for identifying what I do I go to
this website I go to this element and
then I say inspect element so now I know
that there is already an ID which is
unique to this particular web element
available so I'm going to make use of
this ID I need to go to my Eclipse so
now here I'm going to use the find
element method so for that I'll say
driver dot find element I'll say by dot
ID and it's a string argument I'll just
copy the ID which I copied from the
Firefox browser and then what is the
operation I need to do here I need to
send keys and what is the keys I need to
set the product which I'm searching for
I am searching for say JBL speakers done
so with this command what it will do is
it will enter the text JBL speakers in
the search box after doing this I need
to click on the search button now
similarly I need to identify what is the
web element search for this again I
already have a unique ID here which I'm
just going to Simply copy from here and
use it in the find elements so same
thing I will do driver dot find element
by dot ID and this is the ID of the
button button and here what is my
operation I need to click done good so
far now other thing what we also need to
understand here is so what happens
sometimes depending on the website some
websites are pretty slow even while
loading the page and some are pretty
fast now for the selenium to work
without having to fail or without having
to create exception of not finding the
elements it is good to use certain
weights so why we need to use weights
and say for example when I after
entering the JBL speakers and after
clicking the button it's going to take a
while for it to search for JBL speakers
and give us that web page with the list
of jpu speakers and even before we start
doing the First Command like searching
once we load the page it takes time for
the complete page to get loaded okay so
selenium provides lot of synchronization
commands right and it's a very big topic
on its own which needs to be used
especially when you're working with any
kind of website okay so there is a step
since it's a separate topic there's a
separate video which will help you you
understand how to use the
synchronization now for the demo purpose
we have certain weight commands which
can be used and that is exactly which
I'm going to use here so that is called
as thread.sleep so what this does is say
I'm going to give 2000 here what this
does is this basically this script waits
for two seconds right after the previous
command is executed and then it executes
your next command which is our find
element now this is showing us an
exception because it wants us to add a
exception here add throws declaration
which is interrupted exception okay we
need to do this so once we are done okay
we have done the click so let's see what
is the first use case which we had have
we covered everything in the first use
case okay we said login to eBay done
search for JBL speakers and then I want
to check on the days D okay we need to
do this also so for that again what we
need to do is we need to go and identify
so what I will do I'll use the inspector
here and look for this daily deals now
this is a link text it's an anchor tag
so what I will do I'll copy this link
text daily deals I'll go to my Eclipse
now after this I will give another
thread.sleep of say two seconds that
should be more than enough and then I'll
say driver dot find element now this
time I will be using something called as
link text and here as an argument as a
parameter I'm going to paste the daily
deals which I just copied and then what
do I need to do on this web element I
just need to do a click operation done
so the complete first use case we have
covered so what we will do is let's go
ahead and execute this first use case
now I have launched the browser here I
also need to call this method which is
search product now again here since we
are doing that add through Declaration
on the method we also need to do it for
the main function exception add it I'll
save this and for me to run this what I
do is I simply right click on that and I
say run as Java application now we see
that our Firefox browser is launched the
eBay application is also launched and
JBL speakers entered and search clicked
so we have a list of JBL speakers here
and now as per our test case it has to
go on the daily deals which is just
great all right so we have our first use
case working so right now I have not
used the browser.flow so what I will do
is I'll just manually go and close this
browser so we are done with our first
use case now let's move to our Second
Use case so what Second Use case says is
from wherever you are right now we are
on the eBay ebay.in navigate to Simply
learn website and then navigate back to
ebay.in so let's see how to handle that
so let's go back to my Eclipse here now
let's create another method instead of
saying test case to our use case 2 we'll
give a more meaningful name I'll say
navigate since we are exercising the
navigates command navigate commands here
I'll just use this method now so we have
done the click so I need a quick
thread.sleep here because I want it to
wait so that we can see otherwise it's
going to be so fast we will not be able
to see what are the operations it did so
I'll just add a thread dot slip before
we start navigating to the new website
thread dot sleep and I guess two seconds
should be good enough even here so same
thing we need to add the exception so
add throws declaration and interrupted
exception all right done so now what we
need to do is we need to navigate to the
simplelearn.com so for that first I need
a fully formed URL of the website which
I want to launch okay so let me go to
and here instead of ebay.in I would say
let's search for simply learn I have it
here and I just pick this from here
https
www.simplylearn.com so let me go to my
eclipse and here we saw another command
like get we said navigate dot two so
let's use the same command so I'll say
driver dot navigate dot two and I'm
going to use two URL because or you can
just use a string because this is going
to be a string variable now what does
this command do this will simply
navigate to the URL which we have
specified here now here again I'm going
to give a quick sleep here so that we
are able to see the website before we
navigate back to the ebay.in so I'll use
a thread.sleep this time probably I'll
give a three second wait then what does
our use case say let's go back to use
case once and check and it says and
navigate back to ebay.in so that means I
need to use a driver dot navigate dot
can you see the list of commands here
which provide for which the navigate
class provides okay and the back is what
we need to use so that it comes back to
the eBay document done so far so good
now let's do one thing before even we go
to the use case three let's execute our
test case still here so what I'll do
I'll save this program and after search
product I will call navigate method okay
I will save this and then right click
run as Java application so our Firefox
is getting launched it has launched the
eBay application is on so it's going to
first find the JBL speakers click on the
search we have a list of JBL speakers
then it will click on the daily deals
yes it is doing that we got the deals of
the day yes it is now navigating to
simplylearn.com now after three seconds
it should take me back to the ebay.in or
code so this was the last page where we
left before we navigated to Simply right
and that is where we have come back
using the back camera so now let me
close this again because I have still
not Incorporated the driver.loos now
let's look at the use case three now use
case 3 says once you're back to ebay.in
print the page title and then close the
browser code very simple so we'll go
back to Eclipse probably in the same
method what I can do is once I'm back
here I will say so I have to use driver
dot get title that was a spelling
mistake driver dot get title okay this
is the method which we are going to use
to get the title of the page now we also
said that once we get the page title we
want to print it on the console now how
do you print it on Console you just use
a Swiss out statement so instead of just
writing this what I will do is I'll
directly write a Swiss out statement
system.out.println and I'll write a text
as the title of this page is and then we
will concatenate with driver dot get
title as simple as that and after I do
this I will simply call it's actually I
want to call the driver dot list but
it's always good to create a separate
method so I'll say public word close
browser method and here I'll simply say
driver dot quit you can use close or you
can use quit so let me demonstrate how
do we use quit here now I need to call
the closed browser so simply what I'll
do I'll say obj dot close browser method
okay so this completes our all three use
cases so now let's execute all these
three use cases now and we should be
able to see the title of this page on
the console so same thing what I do is
right click run as Java application okay
same thing our eBay is launched now send
Keys the JBL speakers click on search
button executed and then it has to click
on the daily deals that it is done most
of Simply learn website now it has to
come back to ebay.in and we should be
able to see the closed process which
just happened at the snap of the finger
right so now for us to know whether it
really happened what we have done is we
have printed the page title okay now can
you see here we have the complete page
title printed here all right selenium
installation is a three-step process so
it has certain prereqs the first prereq
is you need to have Java on your system
so we will be installing Java first and
then we will be working with Eclipse ID
so we will be installing eclipse and
then we will install selenium for Java
we will install the version Java 8 and
for Eclipse we have a version 4.10 this
was the last stable version which was
released in December last year so I'll
be using that version and selenium we
will download the latest 3.14 version
okay so let's get started with our first
step which is the Java installation so
to install Java let's go to the browser
and simply just search for Java 8
download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your Java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the Oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdkits and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the Oracle log into that
account and then you can just download
the Java it so since I already have an
account and I have already downloaded
the package but I'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this Java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
Windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as I said I've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what I've done is
I've just created a directory called
installers and I'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here I have
a folder called Java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install Java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can change
the directory to the choice of whatever
drive and the folder structure you want
to I would like to leave it as default
here and we just go and click on next
and then the Java installation is in
progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we'll leave the destination
folder as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what I'll do is I'll go to my
command prompt and I'll suggest say Java
minus version so it says Java version
1.8 and this tells us that the Java is
installed successfully now after this
installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
we are also going to set a Java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the Java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the Java got
installed was in program files Java I
have there are certain previous versions
which are installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here that's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what I have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what I
will do is I'll just copy this path and
then go to your control panel here go to
your where is my system yeah so click on
the system go to Advanced system setting
and here in the environment variables
find the PATH variable okay and then say
edit now what are we doing here in the
path variable is we are going to add the
Java bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say Ctrl V
paste the path which you have just
copied from the Explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the Java now
what I'll do for that is I just say new
I just type Java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the print directory so we just
need to set the path till your Java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say Okay click on Okay
click on OK here and we are done so
again let's go to our Command Prompt and
just say Java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed Java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
Eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was
20906. so especially with Eclipse since
it's an open source I prefer to work
with the last stable version and so does
most of the developers do and hence that
is the reason why I have picked up the
version which is like last year's
version which is 4.10 which was released
in last December so you can always
choose to go with the latest version but
then if there are any issues and if you
are like first time working with the
eclipse you're going to get confused as
where these issues are coming from right
so I would still recommend that you use
the last stable version which is
available with your Eclipse so now to
get the last stable version what you
need to do is go and click on this
download packages and here if to scroll
down this page you can see here more
downloads so there is a list of all the
previous releases of app Clips which is
available and this is what we need to
download so just click on that 4.10
version and then click on the OS on
which you want to install eclipse for us
it is Windows so I'll just click here on
the 64-bit windows and then click on the
download and you will be downloading the
complete package so once you download
this is what it will look like so let's
go back to our directory of installers
so this is the installer for the Eclipse
which I got now what's the next step I
need to do just launch this installer
and install Eclipse so I'll just say
double click on this I'll say run
so here you will see multiple options
here for Eclipse installation so
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and install any of these packages
so for us we just need an eclipse ID for
Java developer so I'll select this and
I'll say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so I have chosen D drive here
this is a default directory name it
takes which is okay we can leave it as
it is and then also you have an option
to create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
just say select all you can close this
window just say select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this works fix directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
Java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you're going to create
through Eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is I'll go to the D drive and I
already have a directory so here I'll
create I'll just create select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace I'll say my workspace and then
I'll say launch so every time I open the
eclipse right so if this is going to
take as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain Windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so I'll
say file new and since I'm going to be
using Java with selenia I'll say create
Java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the JRE which
you want to use so we just install this
jdk 1.8 okay so I'm going to click on
use default JRE otherwise you also have
an option to use a Project Specific gr
for example I could have two different
projects where one project I'm going to
be working with GRE 1.8 and there is
another project which I want to work
with the latest Java maybe Java 12 and I
can have more than one Java installed on
the machine so this gives me an option
to select whichever Java I want to work
with so if you have another Java
installed here it will show up in this
list so and you can just go ahead and
select that now since we have only one
Java installed on our machine which is
Java 1.8 I will say use default gra
which is 1.8 and I will click on finish
now if You observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
Java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install Selena so
let me go to my browser and here I will
be going to the
seleniumhq.org so if you are working
with selenium this particular website
the seleniumhq.org is going to be a
Bible everything and anything related to
selenium is available in this website
whether you want to download the files
whether you want to refer to the
documentation anything regarding to
selenium is available here so what we
want now is the installables for
selenium so here go to the the download
tab now for you to install selenium and
start working with selenium there are
three things which are required for you
to download one is a standalone selenium
server so this is not required
immediately when you get started with
selenium however when you start working
with remote selenium Webdriver you would
be requiring this when you have a grid
setup you will be requiring the
Standalone server so for that what you
can do is you can just download the
latest version available here so when
you click on that it'll download the
file into your download folder so this
is one particular file which you need to
keep next selenium client and Webdriver
language mine takes now in today's demo
we will be looking at selenium with Java
so that means my client package of java
is what I need to download so whatever
programming language selenium supports
we have respective downloadables
available with that so if you're working
with python then you need to download
your client library for Python and since
we are working with Java you need to
download this package so simply what you
need to do click on this link and it
will download the Java package file
which are basically the jar files so we
have client libraries now and then there
is another component what we need now
with a linear you are going to be
automating your web browser applications
correct and you also want your
applications to run on multiple browsers
so that means your scripts the
automation scripts which you create
should be able to run on any browser
selenium works with multiple browsers
like Edge Safari Chrome Firefox and
other browsers even it has a support for
headless browser now every browser which
it supports comes with its own driver
file now say for example we want to say
work with Firefox driver so that means
for us to start working with Firefox
browser we need to download something
called as a gecko driver here and if you
want to work with Chrome browser you
need to install the Chrome driver so
depending on what browsers you'll be
testing with go ahead Click on each of
this link and download the latest driver
files now since we are going to be
working with Firefox in this demo what I
need to do is I just need to click here
on the latest link so when I click on
the latest link it is going to take me
to this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for Linux for mac and for
Windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file I need because
we are working on Windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq.org for us to install
sending so let me show you the folder
where I have already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium Java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client Library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once I download this this is a
ZIP file after I unzip the file this is
the folder structure I see and let's see
what is there in this folder selector so
there are two jar files here and then in
the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selenium and then we also downloaded the
driver files so what I did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser I created a directory here
called drivers and have kept all my
browser drivers here so I have a driver
file downloaded for Chrome I want to
work with Firefox so I have a gecko
driver here and then for Internet
Explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this JRE libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium Jazz to
this library and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jars click on ADD external jars go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so I
have two jar files here I'll just say
click open again I will click on ADD
external jars now from the lips folder I
will select all this five so select all
the five jars and click on open so you
should see all the seven jar files here
so once you have this just say apply and
close now if you look into your project
directory here you'll see some a folder
called referenced library and this is
where you will see all the selenium
charts here this is a very simple
installation in Eclipse when you want to
install selenium you just need to export
all the jars of the selenium into
eclipse and now your system is ready to
start working with selenium scripts all
right so now let's just test our
installation by writing a small selenium
test script so for that what I will do
is I'll go to the source folder right
click new and I'll say Java class so
let's name this as say first selenium
test and I will select this public
static white Main and I will click on
finish all right so now let's create a
use case say we want to launch a Firefox
browser and then we want to launch the
Amazon site so this will be just two
simple things which we will be doing in
this test script so for me to do that
what I usually do is I create a method
for any functionality which I want to
create here so now I want to do a launch
browser so I'll create a method here
called launch browser now whenever you
start writing your selenium scripts the
first line what you need to do is you
need to declare an object of Webdriver
class so here I'll say
Webdriver driver driver so now if you
hover over this error what it is showing
it says import web driver from or dot
open QA dot selling it so if you
remember when we installed the selenium
we imported all these jars right so that
means what whenever we want to use a web
driver we need to import this class from
these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import State done now next
step now for us to launch a Firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that I'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value pair now
what is the key I'm going to mention
here I am going to be mentioning the
gecko driver and the path for the gecko
driver okay because since I'm working
with the Firefox so in double quotes
I'll say
webdriver.geco.driver this is my key and
the value is going to be sorry the fully
qualified path for your driver files and
you know know where we have kept our
driver files let's go to that driver
files in D colon I have selenium
tutorial in installers I have driver
folder okay so I'm just going to copy
the complete path from here Ctrl C and I
paste it here Ctrl V along with this I
need to provide the file name for the
gecko driver which is gecko driver dot
exe and let's complete this step next so
once I've set the property I need to
provide a command for launching my
Firefox driver and how do I do that I
simply use this driver object which I
have created driver equal to
new Firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for Webdriver
we also need to import the package for
Firefox driver so just hover over the
mouse over that and select import
Firefox tracker with these two
statements we will be able to launch the
Firefox browser and as I said in our use
case what is the next thing we want to
do we want to launch say amazon.in
website for that there is a command in
selenium which says driver dot get and
you pass the URL here so for me to write
the URL what I usually do is I go to my
browser I open the website which I want
to work with in our case it's amazon.in
and I just simply copy this fully formed
URL go to my eclipse and just paste it
here now this ensures that I don't make
any mistakes in typing out the URL let's
complete this statement and we are done
and now in the main function I'll just
create an object of this and we will
call this method so I'll copy this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now I'll say say
obj dot this is a function launch
process so let's save this and execute
this Ctrl C right click run as Java
application okay so the Mozilla Firefox
has been launched now it should launch
your amazon.bingo so selenium
installation on Mac is a three-step
installation one we need to install Java
which is a prereq and then we need an ID
to work with so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium and these are the versions of
the installers which we are going to use
so we will be using Java 8 Eclipse
version 4.10 which was released in 2018
December and then selenium version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the Java installation
so for us to install Java let us go to
our browser
and simply what I'll do is I'll just
Google for Java 8 download
so we would select the Oracle site for
downloading the SD
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as Java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since I
already have one I have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the Java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so I'll be downloading this
package for that I need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on Mac this
is the package which I'm going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since I have
already downloaded the package and I
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what I have
done is I have created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what I have
downloaded it and kept it here so we'll
go step by step so that you understand
what each of these packages are so as
you see here I have the jdk 8 which I've
already downloaded so let's go ahead and
install jtk so how do we install jdk so
you have the DMG file here you just go
ahead and double click on that
okay and then I'll double click on this
package
and then we will say continue and
install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay I've given my password and I'll say
install the software
pop up it will just take a couple of
minutes to install Java
there you go so now the Java has been
installed so let me close this window
let me close this window too and then
now I'll go to my terminal window so
let's open my terminal and here
let's say Java minus version bingo so
there we have Java 1.8 installed on our
system now there are couple of other
things which you need to do apart from
installation of your jdk you also need
to set some system variables right so in
Mac how do you set the system variables
or the environment variables you do that
in your bash profile so let's see how we
do that all right so what I will do is
I'll use an editor which is my VI okay
and then I'll open my bash profile so
what is Bash profile it's a config file
for your bash cell this is mainly used
to export variables in your shell like
in Windows we are going to do the system
variable setting from the advanced
setting right so similarly we are going
to do that here so I'll say VI Dot Dash
underscore profile so this is the file
where I will be adding Java home path
okay now I have other parts here already
written because I'm working with other
multiple software on this machine and
now I'll go to the end of this file and
I'll say
export
Java home
equal to now what is the path we need to
give for Java home we need to give the
path where the Java has been installed
on your system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then I have a folder called Library
here so here
there is a Java and then there is
something called as Java virtual
machines so if you have a single Java or
multiple Java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is Java
virtual machines and Java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your JRE and Bin folder so
that means I need to give my Java Home
Path until here till this home directory
so simply what I'm going to do is I'll
just go here say get info because I want
to just copy the path and what you can
do is you copy this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here I'm going to paste this path
plus I want to tell the home directory
so I'm just going to type out homie home
that is it so you have now set your Java
home environment variable so simply you
do
save the file Escape colon WQ and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile to be activated
you just exit out of this terminal
okay close this terminal window and I'll
go ahead and open another terminal so
let me close this info text so here let
me again give Java minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our Java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your Java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences okay here you
will see this Java control panel okay
this is another way of finding out that
your Java has been installed
successfully on the machine so you can
just open this Java control panel and if
there is any settings which you want to
do here you can do it through your
control panel also
on it
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder Windows
so we have successfully done our step
one so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what I will do I'll go to my
browser
okay and now I'll open another tab here
and I'll say
Eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you're working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
I would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what we are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions I just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that on this
page if you scroll down you will see
something called as more downloads right
in this you will see all the bills of
Eclipse which is available all your
previous versions So since today I'll be
working with 4.10 version I will go
ahead and click on this 4.10 this 4.10
was released last year this is 28 in
December okay and now when you look at
this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what I would be using is Eclipse ID
for Java developers
so since we are going to be working on
Mac I will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then I'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me I've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this Eclipse Java 2018 12
are
blah blah blah dot DMG so this is the
file which we're going to be using to
install Eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk I'm going to double click on
this and install the eclipse let's see
how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now I'll just move this
folder into applications
done so my eclipse is ready now so
simply let's go ahead and launch so what
I'll do I'll just simply search for that
on my system Eclipse there you go and
I'll just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package and
just installing it on your Mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you are going to keep all your folders
all your Java code or whatever you're
going to do in Eclipse all under that
particular directory
um so right now it gives me a default
directory rather what I will do is since
I have created a separate folder for our
demos I will go ahead and select that
folder which is why simply demo
and then in this I will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files I'm going to
create whatever code I'm going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then I'll go ahead and
say launch so it will take a minute to
load your workbench yeah there it goes
so when you launch your Eclipse right so
let me just make this window bigger the
first screen what you are going to see
is the welcome screen just go ahead and
close the welcome screen and this is the
first view of your eclipse what you're
going to get so let's close out all the
windows which we are not going to be
working today and I just need this main
screen here now what is the first step
you're going to do once you have the
eclipse I would go ahead and create a
project first I'll simply say open find
new Java project let's give a nice name
to this since this is our first project
which is going to be created so I'll say
selenium
first project
now if You observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
Eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while I create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution GRE which
you already have in the system okay
that's why it is already chosen Java one
dot it in case you have multiple Javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the Java of your choice so
say if you've got the latest Java which
is Java 12 installed on your system it
will give you an option here along with
Java software 8 it will give you Java 12
here so you can go ahead and select that
for this particular project that option
is also available now since we have only
one jtk installed here I will go ahead
and create this project so I'll just
click on finish and it's going to create
a projection so there are few default
things which it creates created one is
definitely the Jr system libraries right
this is what we told Eclipse when we
created project that my Java is 1.8 so
what it has done is it has imported all
this jar file which it requires for our
Java programs to work in our Eclipse ID
and then it creates a SRC which is your
Source directory wherein where we'll be
creating all our Java code or our
selenium test scripts okay good so far
so this is a simple way of installing
your eclipse and getting your Eclipse
ready to work with your Selena all right
so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
HQ Dot
so this is going to be a Bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what I do is
I go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with Selena
one is the selenium Standalone server
right so when you're going to be working
with remote selenium Webdriver is when
you would require this however I would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what I just need
to do is I need to click on this and
it's going to download This Server form
okay so I have already downloaded it and
I'll show you that and then what we need
is the selenium client and Webdriver
language findings okay we need a client
so what is the client which you are
going to work in we are going to working
with Java client with the serenade and
for that I need to go ahead and download
this if you are working on say C sharp
or a ruby or python then you have the
respective packages which you can go and
download now since we are going to be
working with Java here I would go ahead
and click on this and this is going to
download the Java client form now as I
said since I've already downloaded it so
let's go ahead and look at what are
those downloadables what we have so
let's close out this window now if you
see here one is the selenium server
Standalone which we just downloaded and
then when you download the client
libraries what it does it it creates a
zip file it downloads a zip file and it
unzips it and what is contained in that
particular folder so if you look here
selenium Java 3 in this folder you have
multiple jar files with which is what
will be working with Selena so here you
have two jar files here and then under
the folder Labs you have other jar files
now these are the files which we will
need and now let's see how do we utilize
this file in our Eclipse so for that
let's go back to our Eclipse okay so let
me maximize this window so in Eclipse
first thing what you need to do is click
on your project okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
build path now here in this configure
build path what you need to do is go to
your libraries okay go to add external
jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium Java 3. so what I'll do I'll
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
file so what we have is in lips so
select all the jar files in the list
say open okay you have all the jar files
what we need identified it go ahead and
click on apply and close once you do
that how do you know whether all those
jars have been imported correctly go to
the reference libraries here you should
be able to see all the selenium jars
which we have downloaded to be listed
out here and so it lists here so that
means we have successfully imported
selling to test our installation let's
go ahead and write a small test script
so for that I'll go to my source folder
right click new and we'll create a Java
class so let's name it
selenium
first test and I will also use a public
static word menu and I'll click on
finish
let's remove all this commands here
which we do not need so before even we
write a first line of code first what we
need to do is create an object of web
driver so I'll say web driver driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to import this particular
Webdriver class from a package and that
packages
org.openq.selling okay so now you can
see this import statement
now let's go ahead and write our test
case now for this test case what we will
do is we will simply launch a browser
say Firefox browser and we will also
launch a website now I'll create a
method for that I'll say public void
launch browser
so if you have looked at our previous
videos on selenium Webdriver Basics I
have explained there that every browser
which you want to work with in selenium
comes with its own driver and this
driver is what we need to download from
the website of selenium and I'll show
you how to do that so if we go to that
seleniumhq.org under the downloads tab
if you go down you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins so all the browsers
supported by selenium are listed here
and their corresponding driver files are
available so now since we are going to
be working with Firefox in this demo I
will go ahead and click on this latest
release of Mozilla gecko driver so gecko
driver is the one which will be using
for launching or Firefox so just click
on this and this will take you to the
latest version of the gecko driver
available so just scroll down and
depending on the OS which you're working
with in our case it is a Mac OS so just
click on this file and download this
file
similarly
say if you are working with the Chrome
driver what you need to do is go to this
chrome driver go to the latest click on
that and select the release which you
want to work with and just download it
now I've already downloaded this file
and I'll just show you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory I have another
directory created called as drivers and
what I do is usually I keep all my
driver files under this folder
okay so I have a chrome driver and gecko
driver already downloaded and capture
now let's go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to launch our
browser so there are two steps which we
need to do for launching any browser
which you want to work with right first
is you need to set a system property so
for that what I do is
system
dot set property
and this accepts a key and value pair
now key for this is gecko driver is what
I need to provide here and now that is
in the course because it's a string
argument I say Webdriver Dot
driver
and the value is nothing but the path to
your gecko driver which you have just
downloaded okay let's go to my finder so
that's here so what I do is I simply
right click on this file get info and I
copy this complete path
go to my eclipse paste this path here
and then the file name which is gecko
driver
done so this sets a path to my gecko
driver now next step is actually
launching the web browser and how do I
do that I say driver
equal to new
Firefox driver
now we need to do the same thing again
we need to import this class so I say
import Firefox driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
Firefox browser and then let's go ahead
and also launch a website say amazon.in
so for that I have a command called
driver.get
which accepts a URL
now this URL needs to be a fully formed
URL so for that what I do first is I go
to my any browser I launch the amazon.in
website
okay and then I copy this complete URL
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.in so let's
quickly create a class here or object
here of this class so selenium first
test
obj equal to new selenium first test
done and then I need to call the method
which is launch browser
okay so now I save this file I do a
right click on this and I say run as
Java application now this should launch
our browser
okay which it just did and then it
should take us to amazon.in bingo there
goes our first script so we have
successfully executed our first script
so that means your selenium is up and
running if you're ready to embark on a
career path pulsating with excitement
Innovation and Limitless growth look no
further than simply landscape
postgraduate program in devops this
comprehensive program equips you with
the Knowledge and Skills to navigate the
devops landscape with confidence explode
the depth of continuous integration
delivery and conclude the entry cases of
Automation and orchestration fortify
security like a digital Fortress and a
list of full potential of cloud
Technologies don't let this once in a
lifetime opportunity slip away ignite
your career and join the ranks of prime
Dev professionals click the link in the
description box to enable the wonders of
this course you first understanding that
what exactly is incredible all about
now griddle is in kind of a bell tool
which can be used for the build
automation performance and it can be
used for various programming languages
primarily it's being used for the Java
based applications it's some kind of
build tool which can help you to see
that how exactly automatically you can
prepare the builds you can perform the
automations earlier we used to do the
build activity from the eclipse and we
used to do it manually right but with
the help of this build tool we are going
to do it like automatically without any
manual efforts as such here they're not
like a lot of activities which we will
be doing during the build process
primarily there are different activities
like compilations linkage packaging
these are the different tasks which we
perform during the build process so that
we can understand that how the build can
be done and we can perform the
automations uh this uh process also it's
kind of a standardized because again if
you want to automate something standards
or a standard process is something which
we require for that before we been going
ahead with that part so that's the
reason why we are getting this build
tool because this build tool helps us to
do a standardization process to see that
how the standards can be met and how we
can proceed further with that part
also it's something which can be used
for variety of languages programming
languages Java is the primary language
for which we use the Gradle but again
other languages like Scala Android CC
plus plus Ruby these are some of the
languages for which we can use the same
tool now it's actually using like it's
referring to as an trophy based domain
specific language rather than XML
because ant and Maven these are the XML
based build tools but this one is not
that uh dependent on XML it's using The
Groovy based domain specific language
DSL language is being used here right
now um again it's something which can be
used to do the build it can further on
be used to perform the test cases
automations also there and then further
on you can deploy to the artifactory
also that okay I want to push the
artificial artifactory so that also that
part also you can get it done over here
so uh primary this tool is known for
doing the build automations for the big
and large projects the projects in which
the source code the amount of source
code and the efforts is more so in that
case is this particular tool makes sense
now Gradle includes both the pros of
Maven and ant but it removes the
drawbacks or whatever the issues which
we face during these two build tools so
it's helping us to remove all the cons
which we face during the implementation
of ant and Maven and again again all the
pros of ADD and Maven is implemented
with this cradle tool
now let's see that why exactly this
griddle is used because that's a very
valid question that what is the activity
like what is the reason why we use the
Gradle because
um the first one is that it resolves
issues faced on other build tools that's
a primary reason because we all already
having the tools like Maven and and
which is available there but primarily
this griddle tool is something which is
removing all the issues which we are
facing with the implementation of other
tools so these issues are getting uh
removed as such second one is that it
focuses on maintainability performance
and flexibility so it's giving the focus
on that how exactly we can manage the
big large projects and uh we can have
flexibility that what different kind of
approaches I want to build today I want
to build in different ways tomorrow the
source code modifies gets added up so I
have the flexibility that I can change
this build script so I can perform the
automations so a lot of flexibility is
available which is being supported by
this tool and then the last one is like
it provides a lot of features a lot of
plugins now this is one of the benefit
which we get in the case of Maven also
that we get a lot of features but again
when we talk about cradle then it
provides a lot of plugins like let's say
that normally in a build process we do
the compilation of the source code but
sometimes let's say that we want to
build an angular or a node.js
application now in that case we may be
involved in running some command line
executions some command line commands
just to make sure that yes we are
running the commands and we are getting
the output so there are a lot of
features which we can use like uh there
are a lot of plugins which is available
there and we will be using those plugins
in order to go ahead and in order to
execute those builds process and doing
the automations now let's talk about the
cradle and Maven because again when we
talk about mav1 like it was like
something which was primary used for the
Java but again when we are talking about
cradle so again it's just uh being used
primary for the Java here but what is
the reason that we prefer Gradle over
the create me one so what are the
different reason for that let's talk
about that part because this is very
important we need to understand that
what is the reason that Gradle is
preferred as a better tool for the Java
as compared to Maven when we talk about
for the build automation name
now the first one is that the Gradle
using The Groovy DSL language domain
specific language whereas the maven is
considered as a project management tool
which is uh creating the palms or XML
file format files so it's being used for
the Java project but XML format is being
used here and on the other hand griddle
is something which is not using the XML
formats and whatever the build scripts
you are creating that is something which
is there in the groupie based DSL
language and on the other hand in the
pump we have to create the xmls
dependencies whatever the attributes you
are putting up in the May one that's
something which is available there in
the format of XML the overall goal of
the griddle is to add functionality to a
project whereas the goal of the maven is
to you know to complete a project phase
like to work on different different
project phase like compilation test
executions uh then uh packaging so then
deploying to artifactory so these are
all different phases which is available
there into the maven but on the other
hand griddle is all about about adding
the functionality that how you want to
have some particular features added up
into the build scripts in griddle there
are like we usually specify that what
are the different tasks we want to
manage so different different tasks we
can add up into the case of Gradle and
we can override those tasks also in case
of Maven it's all about the different
phases which has been happening over
here and it's in sequence manner so
these phases happens in the sequence
order that how exactly you can build up
the sequence there but in case of
griddle you can have your own tasks
custom tasks also and you can disrupt
the sequence and you can see that how
the different steps can be executed in a
different order so Maven is something
which is a phase mechanism there but
Gradle is something which is according
to the features or the flexibilities now
griddle works on the tasks whatever the
task you want to perform you uh it works
directly on those tasks there on the
other hand uh Maven is something does
not have any kind of inbuilt cache so
every time you're running the build so
separate uh things or the the plugins
and all this information gets loaded up
which takes definitely a lot of time on
the other hand gradually something which
is uh using its own internal cache so
that it can make the builds a little bit
faster because it's not something which
is doing the things from the scratch
whatever the uh things is already being
available in the cache so it's just pick
that part and from there it will proceed
further on the build Automation and
that's the reason why cradle performance
is much faster as compared to Maven
because it uses some kind of a cache in
there and then helps to improve the
overall performance now let's talk about
the Gradle installation because this is
a very important aspect to be done
because when we are doing the
installation we have to download the
Cradle executables right so let's see
that what are the different steps is
involved in the process of the Gradle
installation
so when we talk about the Gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
Java is installed now if the Java is not
installed so you can go to the open jdk
or you can go for the Oracle Java so you
can do the installation of the jdk on
your system so jdk8 is something you can
most commonly use nowadays so you can
install that once the Java is downloaded
and installed then you have to do the
Cradle uh download cradle there now once
the Gradle boundaries are executable uh
or the user file gets downloaded so you
can add the environment variables and
then you can validate if the critical
installation is working fine as expected
not so we will be doing the Gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that how exactly we can go for the
installation of cradle and we'll see
that what are the different version we
are going to install here so let's go
back to the system and see that how we
can go for the Gradle installation so
this is the website of the jdk of a Java
Oracle Java now here you have different
jdk so from there you can do whatever
the option you want to select you can go
with that so jdk8 is something which is
most commonly used nowadays like it's
most comfortable or compatible version
which is available so in case you want
to see that if the jdk is installed into
your system all you have to do is that
you have to just say like Java hyphen
version and that will give you the uh
put it whether the Java is installed
into your system or not so in case my
system the Java is installed but if you
really want to do the installation you
have to download the jdk installer from
this website from this Oracle website
and then you can proceed further on that
part now once the jdk is installed so
you have to go for the Cradle
installation because Gradle is something
the which will be performing at the
build automations and all that stuff so
you have to download the bindies like uh
the zip file probably in which we have
the executables and all and then we have
to have have some particular environment
variables configured so that we will be
able to have the System modified over
there so right now we have got like the
prerequests as in Java version installed
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables so
uh in order to download the latest
Gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one right now over here there
are different options like uh you want
to go for 6.7 now it's there having like
binary only or complete we'll go for the
binary only is because we don't want to
have the source we just want the
binaries and the executables now it's
getting downloaded it's around close to
100 MB of the installer which is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same path we need
to configure into the environment
variable so that in that way we will be
able to see that how the uh Gradle
executables will be running and it will
give the complete output to us over here
in this case so it may take some time
and once the particular modifications
and the download is done then we have to
extract it and once the extraction is
done so we will be able to go back and
have some particular version or have the
configurations established over there so
that let's just wait for some time and
then we will be continuing with the
environment variables like this one so
once the installation and the extraction
is done now we just have to go to the
downloads where this one is downloaded
we have to extract it now extraction is
required so that we can have the setup
like we can set up this path into our
environment variables and once the path
is configured and established we will be
able to start further on that part on
the execution so meanwhile these the
files are getting started let's see so
we already the folder structure over
here and we will see like we will give
this path here there is two environment
variables we have to configure one is
the Gradle underscore home and one is
the
um in the path variable so we'll copy
this path here so meanwhile this is
getting a
strutted we can save our time and we can
go to the environment variable so we can
right click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings then environment
variables
now here we have to give it like cradle
underscore home now in this one we will
not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the griddle is extracted so we'll
say okay
and then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry in this one we will be putting
up till the pin directory here because
the Cradle executable should be there
when I am running the Cradle command so
these two variables I have to configure
then okay okay
and okay
so this one is done so now you have to
just open the command prompt and see
that whether the execution or the
commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like CMD
Java iPhone version to check the version
of the Java and then the Gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see that you see check the version of
the Cradle which is installed and now
you can see that it saves that 6.7
version is being installed over here in
this case so that's the way that how we
are going to have the Cradle
installation performed into our
particular system so let's go back to
the content let's talk about the Cradle
Core Concepts here now in this one we
are going to talk about what are the
different Core Concepts of cradle are
all about the very first one is the
projects here now a project represents a
item to be performed over here to be
done like deploying an application to a
staging environment performing some
build so Gradle is something which is
required uh the projects
um the Gradle project which you prepare
is not having multiple tasks which is
available there which is configured and
all these tasks all these different
tasks needs to be executed into a
sequence now sequences again is a very
important part because again if the
sequence is not meant properly then the
execution will not be done in a proper
order so that's the very important
aspect here
tasks is the one in which is a kind of a
identity in which we will be performing
a series of steps these tasks may be
like compilation of a source code
preparing a jar file preparing a web
application archive file or ER file also
we can have like in some tasks we can
even publish our artifacts to the
artifact we so that we can store those
artifacts into a shared location so
there are different ways in which we can
have this uh particular tasks executed
now build scripts is the one in which we
will be storing all this information
what are the dependencies what are the
different tasks we want to refer it's
all going to be present in the
build.gradle file there build.gradle
file will be having the information
related to what are the different
dependencies you want to download and
you want to store there so all these
things will be a part of the build
Scripts
now let's talk about the features of
cradle what are the different features
which we can use in case of cradle here
there are different type of features
which is available there so let's talk
about them one by one so the very first
one over here is the high performance
then high performance is something which
we can see that we already discussed
that in case you are using a large
projects so Gradle is something which is
in better approach as compared to Maven
because of the high performance which we
are getting it uses an internal cache
which makes sure that you are using like
you are doing the builds faster and that
can give you a higher performance over
there second one is the support it
provides the support so it yes
definitely provides a lot of support on
how you can perform the builds and it's
being the latest tool which is available
there so the support is also quite good
in terms of how you want to prepare the
build how you want to download the
plugins different plugin supports and
the dependencies uh information also
there next one is multi-project build
software so using this one you can have
multiple projects in case in your
repository you have multiple projects
say so all of them can be easily built
up with the help of this particular tool
so it supports multiple projects to be
built up using the same Gradle project
and Gradle scripts so that support is
also available with this cradle a build
Tool uh incremental builds are also
something which you can do with the help
of Gradle so if you have done only the
incremental changes and you want to
perform only the incremental build so
that can also be possible with the help
of a griddle here the uh build scans so
we can also perform the build scans so
we can use some Integrations with sonar
Cube and all where we can have the scans
down to the source code on understand on
how the build happens or how the source
code really happens over there so that
code scan or the build scans can also be
performed with this one and then it's a
familiarity with Java so for Java it's
something which is considered as in by
default not even Java in fact Android
which is also using the Java programming
language is using the particular cradle
over here so that the build can be done
and it can gain uh benefits out of that
so in in all the manners in all the
different ways it's basically helping us
to see that how we can make sure that
this tool can help us in providing a lot
of features and that can help us to make
a reliable build tool for our Java based
projects or any other programming based
project here right now let's see that
how we can invert a Java project with a
griddle here and for that we have to go
back and readily something which is
already installed we just have to create
a directory where we can have like how
we can perform some executions we can
prepare some build scripts and we can
have a particular execution of a Gradle
build happened over there so let's go
back to the machine okay so we are going
to open the terminal here and we'll see
that how we can create it so first of
all I have to create a directory
structure let's say that we'll say like
Gradle
hyphen project now once the project is
created so we can go inside this
directory so to create some critical
related projects and preparing the files
now uh in this one we'll let's first
create a particular one so we will be
saying like VI build dot Gradle so in
this one we are going to put like a two
plugins we are going to use so we are
going to say like apply
for again
Java and then we are going to say like
apply
plugin
application
so these two plugins we are going to use
and when we got this file over here in
this one so it shows like build.gradle
which is available there in this case so
two these files are available now if you
want to learn like you know what are the
different tasks you can run like griddle
tasks command over there so griddle task
will help you know that what are the
different tasks which is available over
here by processing the build scripts and
all so um this will definitely help you
to understand on giving you the output
so here all the different tasks are
being given and it will help you to
understand that what are the different
tasks you can configure and you can work
over here just like jar files clean and
all that stuff build compile then uh in
it is there then all these different
executions assemble then Java dog then
build then check test all these
different tasks are there and if you
really want to run the Gradle build so
you can run like Gradle clean to perform
the clean activity because right now you
are doing like alpha build so before
that you can have a clean and then you
can run a specific command or you can
run the Gradle clean build which will
perform the cleanup also and it will at
the same time will have the build
process also performed over there so
build and clean up both will be executed
over here and what is the status whether
it's the success or the failure that
will be given back to you now in this
case in the previous one if you see that
when you run the clean the Cradle clean
it was only running one task but when
you go for the build uh process when you
run the Cradle clean build it's going to
give you a much more information in fact
you can also give me uh further
information like you can have the hyphen
iPhone Info flag also there so that if
you want to get the details about the uh
different uh tasks which we which is
being executed over here so that also
you're going to get over here in this
one so you just have to put like hyphen
iPhone Info and then all these steps
will be given back to you that how these
tasks will be executed and the response
will be there so that's the way that how
you can provide a pretty much simple
straightforward project in form of
Gradle which can definitely help you to
run some couple of creative commands and
then you can understand that what are
the basic commands you can run and how
the configurations really works on there
right let's go back to the main content
right now let's move on to the next one
so in the next one we are going to see
that how we can prepare a griddle build
project in case of eclipse now we are
now using the local system we are not
directly creating the folders and the
files here we are actually using the
eclipse for performing the creating a
new Gradle project over here so let's
move on that part okay so now the
eclipse is open and I have open in this
one the very first thing is that we have
to do the Gradle plugin installation so
that we can create new projects on
cradle and then we have to configure the
path that's how the Gradle plugin can be
configured on the previous uh
preferences and all that stuff and then
we will be doing the build process so
the very first thing is that we have to
go to the eclipse Marketplace
in there we have to search for griddle
so once the search is done
it will show us the plugins we have to
go for build ship Gradle integration so
we'll click on the install
it will proceed with installation it
will download it in some cases maybe
it's part of the eclipse as in uh in the
ID so you can go to the install Tab and
you can see that also that if this
plugin is already installed or not but
in this case we are installing it and uh
once the installation is done we just
have to restart the uh specific uh once
we have to restart this Eclipse so that
the changes can be reflected
so it's downloading
it's downloading the Cradle here and
once that is installed we will be able
to use it over here in this case in this
scenario so we have to just wait for
that part so still downloading the jar
files so once the jar file is done it's
now over the areas and download it so
after that we will be able to proceed
further on that download aspect so it's
going to take some time to download it
and once it's done we will be able to
proceed further now once the progress is
done so it's asking us for the restart
now so uh before that uh we just have to
click on restart now and then the
eclipse will be restarted all together
again here so you can do it manually or
you can go for that options you just
require a restart so that the new
changes can be reflected over here so
the plugins can be activated and can be
referenced here now we have to just uh
put up like the you know the
configuration where we can have the
system so we can go for the Gradle
configuration so we can go for Windows
and then preferences
now in this case we have to go for the
uh for the ones in which the Cradle
option is available there so cradle is
what we are going to select now user
home the Gradle user home is what we
need to use right so you want to go for
the Gradle you want to go for local
installation so so all these options you
can use you can if if you go for the
griddle wrapper then it will be
downloading the Cradle locally and it is
going to use the Cradle W or griddlew
dot bat file but if you already have an
installation locally so you can prefer
that also right now in the previous demo
we have already got the Gradle uh
extracted so we just have to go for the
downloads in the downloads already
Gradle is available so we are going to
select that part here so this is what we
are going to select
right so this represents that this is
the directory structure in which we are
having the mechanism so you can either
go for the build scan so you can select
the build scan also so once this is
enabled then all the projects will be
scanned and will be you know published
and uh it's in kind of an additional
option which is available if you really
want to disable it you can disable it
also and you can go with this
configuration also so uh this is where
the particular Gradle folder is being
put over here in this case and then we
have to just click on apply
and we just have to click on apply and
close so with this one the particular
execution is done now we will be going
for the project creation so you can
right click over here or you can go to
the file also so here we are going to go
for the job project and in this we are
going to have a Gradle project so Gradle
project is what we are going to create
here
and next
so we are going to say like cradle
project
and then next
so once that is done so finish
so uh with this one when you create the
project so what will happen that uh
automatically there will be a folder
structure will be available there right
and uh there are some uh Gradle scripts
which will also be created there so we
will be doing the modifications there
and we'll see that how the uh particular
Gradle build script looks like and how
we can we will be adding some couple of
uh selenium related dependencies and
we'll see that how we can have more and
more dependencies added and what will be
the impact of those dependencies on the
overall project so that also it's very
important aspect to be considered so let
this processing be happen over there
just creating and uh some plugins and
binaries are getting installed and
getting downloaded so we'll see that
once the project is uh imported
completely executed over here and got
created we can extract that now if you
see here the particular option is
available about the Gradle tasks so you
can extract it also and you will be able
to know that what are the different
tasks which is available there let's see
that in the build they are running like
build these are the different tasks
which is happening inside the build
process so Gradle executions will be
also available over here in this case
and greater tasks will be different it
will be represented over here in this
one so you just have to extract on the
Gradle project okay so this is the
library which is available now uh what
happens that you will be able to have
like settings.gradle in this one you
will be able to have like okay Gradle
hyphen project is something which is
available there in this one so that's
what you're being aren't referring then
we have over here as in these folder
structures which is created like Source
main Java this is the one source test
Java is the one which is available as an
on the folder structure and so test
resources are also available here so the
main source main resources are also
available now in this case what happens
that these are the dependencies project
and external these are the different
dependencies are available there so
let's see let's add a dependency over
here in this one in the Bell dot uh
griddle script and see that how we can
do that if we open build.gradle file so
you can see that these dependencies are
there like test implementation junit is
available there right and then we have
implementations of this one which is
available now these jar files which you
put up it it will automatically be added
up as in part of this one as in part of
the particular dependencies over here
and which means that you don't have to
store them as a now within the
repository and automatically they can be
happened over there so let's open a
dependency page so we will be going to
mbn repository where we will be opening
a dependency link so this is the
dependency link here so selenium iPhone
Java is available and it can give you
the dependency for all the different
options now we have for Maven this is
the one and for Kettle this is the one
here so we have to just copy this one
and we have to use it as independency so
this is a group and this is the name and
the version which we are using here now
we have copied this one so we will go
back to the Eclipse so here we have to
just put that dependency
and we have to just save it so uh this
is something which is providing like
selenium defenses which is available so
now we have to just refresh the project
so right click over here then you will
be able to see the options in the Gradle
saying that refresh gradual project now
once the moment you do that so you will
be able to do like for the first time
maybe it will take some time to download
all the dependencies which is related to
selenium but after that you will be able
to select the dependencies will be
simply added up over here in this case
so you can see that all the selenium
related dependencies are added up for
any reason if you comment these ones
and you say like
synchronize again
so you will see that all the
dependencies which you are adding up
from this selenium represent uh from the
selenium perspective will be gone back
again
so this is the way that how you can keep
on adding the dependencies which is
required for preparing your bill for
your source code and from there you will
be able to proceed further on the
execution part so that's the best part
about this cradle here so that's the way
that how we are going to prepare a
Gradle project within the eclipse and
now you can keep on adding like the
source code in this one and that's the
way that how the code base will be added
up over here right so that's the way
that how the particular executions or
this Gradle project is being prepared in
case of eclipse or the zip file gets
downloaded so you can add the
environment variables and then you can
validate if the Gradle installation is
working fine as expected not so we will
be doing the Gradle installation into
our local systems and uh into the
windows platform and we'll see that how
exactly we can go for the installation
of cradle and we will see that what are
the different version we are going to
install here so let's go back to the
system and see that how we can go for
the Gradle installation so this is the
website of the jdk of a Java Oracle Java
now here you have different jdk so from
there you can do whatever the option you
want to select you can go with that so
jdk8 is something which is most commonly
used nowadays like it's most comfortable
or compatible version which is available
so in case you want to see that if the
jdk is installed into your system all
you have to do is that you have to just
say like Java hyphen version and that
will give you the output at whether the
Java is installed into your system or
not so in case my system the Java is
installed but if you really want to do
the installation you have to download
the jdk installer from this website from
this Oracle website and then you can
proceed further on that part now once
the jdk is installed so you have to go
for the Cradle installation because
Gradle is something the which will be
performing at the build automations and
all that stuff so you have to download
the bindies like the zip file probably
in which we have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the System modified over there so
right now we have got like the
prerequests as in Java version installed
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables so
uh in order to download the latest
Gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one right now over here there
are different options like uh you want
to go for 6.7 now it's there having like
binary only or complete we'll go for the
binary only is because we don't want to
have the source we just want the
binaries and the executables now it's
getting downloaded it's around close to
100 MB of the installer which is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same path we need
to configure into the environment
variable so that in that way we will be
able to see that how the uh Gradle
executables will be running and it will
give the complete output to us over here
in this case so it may take some time
and once the uh particular modifications
and the download is done then we have to
extract it and once the extraction is
done so we will be able to go back and
have some particular version or have the
configurations established over there so
that let's just wait for some time and
then we will be continuing with the
environment variables this one so once
the installation and the extraction is
done now we just have to go to the
downloads where this one is downloaded
we have to extract it now extraction is
required so that we can have the setup
like we can set up this path into our
environment variables and once the path
is configured and established we will be
able to start further on that part on
the execution so meanwhile these files
are getting started let's see so we
already got the folder structure over
here and we will see like we will give
this path here there is two environment
variables we have to configure one is
the Gradle underscore home and one is
the
um in the path variable so we'll copy
this path here so meanwhile this is
getting a
strutted we can save our time and we can
go to the environment variable so we can
right click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables
now here we have to give it like cradle
underscore home now in this one we will
not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the griddle is extracted so we'll
say okay
and then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry in this one we will be putting
up till the pin directory here because
the Cradle executable should be there
when I am running the Cradle command so
these two variables I have to configure
then okay okay
and okay
so this one is done so now you have to
just open the command prompt and see
that whether the execution or the
commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like CMD
Java iPhone version to check the version
of the Java and then the Gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see check the version of the Cradle
which is installed and now you can see
that it saves that 6.7 version is being
installed over here in this case so
that's the way that how we are going to
have the Cradle installation as part the
of the installation of change unit you
don't require to install any exe file or
any kind of program there there are a
couple of Jar files which is required
which needs to be there into the a class
path so that every time when you write
some junit test cases you should be able
to refer those jar files because without
having those jar files into your class
path of your project you will not be
able to run the change in test cases so
that's the only dependency you require
if you are running a maven build then
these dependencies will be added up into
the palm.xml file if you are referring
or doing the build from the eclipse or
doing the development from the eclipse
then you have to put up these Char files
into the class path of the project so
that these jar files can be loaded up
and DJ unit can be referred over here so
the installation is pretty
straightforward but let's see like uh
what are the different steps we need to
follow now as a pre-request of
understanding the demo about J unit the
first initial two things is like you
require JK to be installed now you can
download the jdk8 over here from this
Oracle website and this is something
which you can download for the windows
or whatever platform you have you can
pretty much install it for whatever
platform is there so for Windows
platform you can download for 32-bit and
the 64-bit both option over here and
once it's installed so you should be
able to use the eclipse latest tool now
all you need to do is that you need to
go to eclipse.org and there you can
download the latest version of the
eclipse now these two main things which
you require because Eclipse will be
required for creating the change in a
test cases and of course how a kind of
ID where you can run some test cases
changing test cases and all and then
Oracle is something which is required as
a runtime for running the jdk also and
the J unit test case is also an eclipse
app
so that's a pre-request which we got
over here to this one so I have already
got these two things installed into my
system and I have Eclipse there so let's
move on to the eclipse and see that how
it goes on there but before that you
also require the junit jar files because
in order to have a particular junit
framework loaded up we require some
particular files jar files over here in
this case so I can just search for junit
4 over here and when you search for J
unit 4 so what happens like this
particular page
will help you or give you all the
details about the change unit 4. now you
can go for the version notes of the
different different versions but uh if
you want to download all you need to do
is like you can say like download and
install and the moment you go there so
it will give you the details now there
are two jar files which is required
junit dot jar file is required over here
jar file these two jar files are
required here if you want to download it
into the test class path if you feel
that you want to uh use a maven based
project then in that case you have to
specifically go for this dependency into
pump file and according to that that
particular version will be downloaded
and will be referred over there so these
are the ways that how you can get the
particular softwares the required things
into the place so I'm going to put up
these jar files into a location so that
I should be able to get uh the
particular details
uh stored and I can refer to them into
my Eclipse so I'm going to download this
one here from the maven Central
so I'm going to download this jar file
and then I'm going to go back
I'm Crest hyphen core so that also I
want to download
chart
so these two jar files I have downloaded
and I will be referring these ones into
my project because these are the ones
which has been required into my project
as such so let's go back to the eclipse
and let's place these jar files into a
location so that into my class path I
can refer the complete folder with all
these two jar files inside that so let's
go ahead with that so let's create a
particular new project over here so
we'll go for new
Java project
and here I can give it like a simple one
a simple project name I can provide here
and jdk I'm using like 1.8 so that's the
jdk version which I have utilized over
here
finish
so this is the project which I have got
like in the source directory now I'm
going to create a simple file over here
a new class file over here so I'll
create it like
G
unit class so I'm going to create a
class over here in this one and of
course I need to have a particular white
main also over here in this specific
class over here because this is the
initial class I'm trying to create over
here in this one I can create a custom
particular methods also over here but
let's see like if we can execute or we
can run some particular functions as
such over here now I'm going to declare
a function over here public
void
junit
method
so I'm just going to create a method
over here
I'm just going to run a particular
print
statement over here
executing
J unit test
cases right now this is a kind of a
method which is there which of course I
can run into my uh public void Main and
this function will be executed uh will
be called upon over here now the thing
is that uh right now uh since it's just
a normal function but the moment I
convert it like I have uh at the rate
test mentioned over here so what will
happen like this will be converted into
the form of a test cases now of course
like right now there is no Imports which
is available there as part of this one
so you can see that the uh the the time
I have added this annotation at the rate
test I will be able to see like yes add
junit 4 library to the build path is
something which is coming up over here
or it's saying like add junit 5. so
whatever the library you feel that you
want to add you can do that and that
particular Library will be added up over
okay now let's go for the junit 4
Library here the moment I do that what
we will happen you will see some changes
first you will see the changes in the
top saying that import
orj.junit.test that's a first import and
second import will be like junit 4 you
will see like these two jar files is
automatically being picked up by the
eclipse now even if you don't download
these jar files this is the main benefit
of the eclipse that these are already a
part of the plugins you can see their
paths that these are already installed
in the if getting your learning started
it's half the battle what if you could
do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
[Music]
want to use the junit these will be
automatically imported over here into
your system now you can just simply call
this method into the main void Main and
then the specific method will be
executed as a form of test cases so this
is a mechanism that how you will be
setting up the project initially you got
the Imports you got the uh particular
annotations configured and with that the
specific jar files will be automatically
being added up into your class path
whatever the Java files we add up we
downloaded previously we can also have
that added up into the custom class path
we can modify this build path of junit 4
which is coming up automatically we can
just simply say right click
build path and configure so this JF unit
4 we can actually import we can remove
it from our system and we can add our
external jar files also into the uh
build path or the class path over here
so that depends upon you that how you
want to perform the customizations
around that part but yes the particular
main benefit of using the eclipse is
that it's already having the junit
plugin installed both 4 and 5 version is
installed whatever version you feel that
you want to include it will be included
and the plugins are already installed so
you don't even have to download the jar
files manually so that's how you will be
able to do a very basic initial setup of
J unit and how a basic project can be
created over here in case of change unit
J meter or Apache jmeter is an open
source software which is a hundred
percent pure Java application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic it was originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users what would be the first thing
that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter Rises
so what jmeta actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers Network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that Java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having Java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as Linux
Windows Mac us or even Ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
Java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type Java hyphen
version we can see that Java is present
in our system here it will show the
version of java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to Google Chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official Apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections in
the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting jmeter
now it's time for us to launch a meter
but before we launch a meter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which jmeter can be launched
the GUI mode and the non-gui mode the
non-gui mode May refer to two types the
first being running jmeter in the server
mode and the second refers to running
jmeter in the command line
and if we talk about the GUI mode then
the GUI mode has a limitation which
slows down the CPU utilization while
running the recorded script but GUI mode
of jmeter is perfect for adding and
editing new configuration elements
thread groups and Samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the GUI mode so to open the GUI mode
inside this bin folder select the
jmeter.bat file double click on this
file this may take a while and then the
jmeter window will open up on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configuration
of that element are added as we see on
the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here the test
plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests listeners and everything will
be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first J meter now when you click outside
this window section you can see the
element name will change otherwise you
can just save this and also the name
will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first J meter here and select the add
option then in this option select the
threads option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test so let's name this thread
group to be jmeter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want then there is this number of
threads where you can choose the number
of users you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to Run infinite number
of times
there is also a scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests and time for now let's leave
everything to be one only
the next step is to go to First J meter
and again to go to add in the boxer
appears select Samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the HTTP request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the URL from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box since
we have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our HTTP test is ready we'll
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first J meter go to
The Listener options then in the Box we
can check the different type of reports
that jmeter provides us for now we shall
select two of these let's choose view
results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the Third Way is you can
right click on first J meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be 1 there's just one entry
in both the results now let's try one
more thing we shall go to jmeter and
change the number of threads and the
loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10. and now run the test after running
the test we shall see the results in the
table and see the testing being
performed and the same happens in the
case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since a loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link let's get started
with what is performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base the
main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload the main purpose of performance
testing is to identify and eliminate
performance bottlenecks in the software
application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed here it
identifies whether the response of the
application is fast or not then comes
scalability where the maximum user load
is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads now we know what is
performance testing let us understand
why if we need performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and poor usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application means speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads application
sent to Market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals now we know the
relevance and need for performance
testing let's look at the typescript
performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing let's have a look at all the six
types of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and Peak usage and
applications performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently within accepted Endurance
on different user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly then another consideration is
regarding how much data the database can
handle before the system crashes the
second type of performance testing is
stress testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test is started with a
load for which the application has
already been tested then more load is
added slowly to stress the system the
point at which we start seeing servers
not responding to the request as
considered the breaking point here the
major considerations are the maximum
load to a system can sustain before it
breaks down then how is the system
broken down and how will the system be
able to recover once it has crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forth the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or study
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after 5 to 10 years the data stored
in the database of the website is much
more and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing so capacity
testing is a type of testing where the
application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects here the main concerns
are if the application would be able to
support the future load if the
environment is capable of standing the
upcoming increased load and what are the
additional resources required to make
the environment capable enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or transactions of a given
web application is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources such as processor
capacity
Network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity Etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal to consider an
excellent example of capacity testing we
can see the case of online banking
moving forward the next type of testing
is the reliability testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal State the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement Gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
Gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the application's
architecture Technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements Etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools after the previous step POC or
proof of concept is done with the
available tools the proof of concept is
a sort of demonstration of real-time
activity but in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tools cost the protocol that the
application is using the technology is
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
Etc now the third step the third step is
the performance test plan in reference
to the above two steps test planning and
designing are conducted the process of
test planning involves information on
how the performance test is going to
take place like the test environment
workload Hardware
Etc moving forth the fourth step is
performance test development in this
step the use cases for the identified
functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval once the
clients approve the use case the script
development begins these scripts are
validated against several different
users and parallel to script creation
the performance Team sets up the test
environment the performance team also
takes care of metadata through scripts
if the client does not take up that
activity so the next step is performance
test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution this step aims to
validate whether the given performance
metrics are achieved during the test or
not then the sixth step is execution of
tests the scenario is designed according
to the load model in controller or
performance center initially the tests
are not executed with maximum users that
are in the load model the test execution
is done in incremental order let's say
there are thousand users then the
scenario will begin testing from 100
then go to 250 then 350 and so on it
will gradually increase and go up to
1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis
the test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred then the
final and the last step in performance
testing process is the report the test
results should be simplified so that
conclusion is clearer and should not
create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point now that we
know the performance testing the next
important topic to discuss is the
understanding of performance testing
metrics the first is processor usage
which refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threats second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is test
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving forth
the next metric is the private bytes it
is the number of bytes a process has
allocated that can be shared amongst the
other processes these are used to
measure memory leaks and usage then
comes the committed memory this is the
amount of virtual memory used then the
next metric we have is the response time
it is the time between when the user
enters a request to time to the first
character of the response is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forth the next metric is the hit ratios
the hit ratios are concerned with the
number of SQL statements that are
handled by cached data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts hits per second
CPU Interruption per second this queue
length Etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
Runner or HP load Runner as the name
suggests the load Runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing the second tool in our
list is web load web load is one of the
best testing tools for stress and load
testing the next tool in our list is
load UI load UI is a great testing tool
to map the scalability and speed of the
target product the fourth tool in our
list is new load it is one of the
fastest testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our existing software with a wide
array of tests the last tool in our list
is the Apache jmeter Apache jmeter is
one of the best and most used testing
tools in the market right now it is
highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users working on web
server moving forward we shall talk
about jmeter and understand why jmeter
is preferred over all the other
performance testing tools in the market
so moving forth let's see what J meter
is J meter or Apache jmeter is an open
source software that has 100 pure Java
application the application is designed
to load or test functional behavior and
measure performance jmeter is originally
designed for testing web applications
but has since expanded to other test
functions to understand the concept of
jmeter let us assume that someday your
team leads tell you to perform
performance testing on some website like
Facebook or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to Internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for 10
000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises so what
jmeter does is it actually simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers Network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why geometer is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts the first one is it's
free of cost second one is performance
testing of applications next one
platform independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
Playback and finally six is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here jmeter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
HTTP and https database via jdbc ldap
and JMS the third reason is
platform Independence
jmeter is written and developed using
Java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts Java virtual
machine for example Windows Linux Mac
Etc the next reason we have is that
jmeter is customizable since jmeta is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize whenever needed
jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding in defining elements
as more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis these Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request to be sent to the host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions and moving forth
the following reason is recording and
Playback
the application provides record and
Playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
Community Support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on J meter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with user's needs and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of jmeter so the
first step is we shall go to the Apache
jmeter folder in that folder go inside
the bin folder and select the jmeter dot
path file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
I have rename this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add then go to thread or users and
select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
and seconds option that states the time
gap between the user hits third there is
a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to run in finite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time let's make the number of threads to
B2 and let's make the loop count to be
100. the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to add option and go to
the sampler option in the menu that
appears select the HTTP request option
here on the screen there is a server
name or IP Box we have to give the
server name or the IP in that let's pick
up a website and place the link in the
box which will use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
onto the server name box keep in mind we
don't need to give the HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page and let's
rename this HTTP request as simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jmeter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the ad select listener option
and go to the view results entry option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results and for
the third listener again right click and
select the view results in the table
option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the Run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first J
meter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this jmeter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count to 100 so the
test will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency and in the tree option when we
click on the test we can see a lot of
information appearing on the screen
these are again several performance
testing metrics and in the graph results
we can see the graph coming up on the
screen now which represents the test
taking place with respect to the IP
address thread and loop counts so what
geometer exactly does is creates a
request and sends it to the server once
it receives the service response it
collects them and visualizes those
details in a chart or graph after that
it processes the service response and
finally it generates the test results in
several formats such as text XML Json so
that the tester can analyze the data
let's get started with what is load
testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines A System's performance
according to real life conditions to
give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to Hardware like CPU
maximization Network bottleneck memory
limitation Etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configurations
such as web server application server
database server Etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction several
tools make load testing possible such as
Apache jmeter web load load UI load
Runner new load load ninja Etc
here in this session we shall be using
jmeter for load testing so jmeta or
Apache geometer is open source software
that is 100 pure Java application the
application is designed to load or test
functional behavior and measure
performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic it was
originally designed for testing web
applications but has since expanded to
other test functions to simplify let's
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing for
some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users what would be
the first thing that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with 100 computers
and access the internet and accessing
the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers Network or object next let's
have a look at some reasons why jmeter
is used for load testing we have divided
these reasons into six parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications platform independent
customizable recording and Playback and
Community Support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost one of
the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here jmeter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
test for many different server types
like web HTTP and https database via
jdbc ldap and JMS the third important
reason is its platform independent in
nature jmeter is written and developed
using Java programming language to run
on any environment or workstation that
accepts a Java virtual machine for
example Windows Linux Mac Etc
the next reason we have is jmeter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
you everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis the Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request is to be sent to a host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions moving forward
the following reason is recording and
Playback the application provides record
and Playback options enabled with the
drag and drop features making the
application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible Community Support jmeta is
an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems this ensures new users always
have someone to answer their questions
and long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter also having an open
source tool ensures it keeps getting
better and always in line with users
needs and requirements now after we know
about jmeter and the reasons to use shea
meter let's understand the process to
perform load testing with a Hands-On
demo the only thing that is kept in mind
before this demo is we must have a fully
functional jmet on our system and by now
we know that jmeter can be used in any
operating system like Linux Windows Mac
OS and Ubuntu in this demo we should
look into both graphical user and
non-graphical user interface mode of
load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter.pat file double click on this
file this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of the element that are added as we are
on the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the scene here the
test plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests the listeners and everything
will be stored here so the first step is
to add listeners for that go to test
plan right click on the test plan go to
add then go to threads users and select
a thread group the test group refers to
the users that are used or created or
needed to run this test it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period in seconds
option that states the time gap between
the user's hits then the third one there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to Run infinite times there is also
a scheduler here to help you schedule
the start time and the test and time for
now let's leave everything to be only
one
the next step is to add the HTTP request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option and go to the HTTP
request option here on the screen there
is a server name or IP Box we have to
give the server name or the IP in that
let's pick a website and place the link
in that box we should use the simply
learns website here go to Simply learns
website and copy the URL from there now
we have copied the simply learns URL now
let's come back to the jmeter window and
paste it in the server name box keep in
mind that we don't need to give up the
HTTP or https since these are protocols
which will come in the other box and
they will be automatically taken in the
HTTP request case
so this is what I was talking about now
let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
HTTP request for that again right click
on the thread group select samples and
select HTTP request and go to Simply
launch website again and there we have
the resource linked go to that link and
copy the URL then place that URL in the
server or IP address box
we shall remove the HTTP from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the HTTP request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more HTTP
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the HTTP request option again to
add one more link to the server and IP
address go to Simply learns website go
to the corporate training link now copy
the URL and go back to the jmeter window
and paste that URL in the IP Box now cut
the corporate training part from the
link and paste it to the other path box
we shall again rename this HTTP request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
loadtesting.jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins The Listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option now
it's time to run the test and check the
load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the Run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
jmeter and then choose run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
after we run the test we shall go to the
check the results of the test in the
view results entry section we can see
the green symbol that states the test
has successfully completed since we had
left all the values to be one in the
beginning that's why there is just one
test for each HTTP request now let's
increase the load and let's change some
numbers let's make the number of threads
to be 10 ramp up the periods to V2 and
the loop going to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test and
non-graphical user mode which will
remove the listener so let's remove the
view results entry
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt we
shall put the pin folder path in the
Apache jmeter folder let's go to the bin
folder and copy the location from here
and now paste the path in the command
prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is The Hyphen n hyphen T
and hyphen L here The Hyphen n
represents the known graphical user
interface mode hyphen T is used to
specify the location of the test script
hyphen L is used to specify the location
of our output result now go to the
location where our jmx file is stored
let's search for the load testing.jmx
file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the filebit.jmx
now go back to the folder and make a DOT
CSV file make an Excel spreadsheet and
rename it with DOT CSV extension now
copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the CSV file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the Run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the load
testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing and graphical user
interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the HTTP request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter its default behavior
is to read and process samples from a
CSV file to generate HTML files it
generates the report and at the end of
the load test are on demand the
dashboard reports provide metrics like
the APD ex or application performance
index the dashboard also provides a
statistics table response time over time
response times percentiles over time
active threads over time and response
times and percentiles we shall learn
about dashboards and more in the
forthcoming videos in this video we
learned how critical is load testing in
the software testing process and how it
ensures High user satisfaction a
successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an API is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an API or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other to understand API even better
let's take an example for example you
are booking a flight
for that you will begin with search and
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airlines website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those States and what
the cost might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you are doing that
with the help of an API to simplify it
even more it can be said that whenever
we use an application on our mobile
phone the application connects to the
internet and sends data to the server
the server then retrieves the data in
the preset performs necessary actions
and sends it back to our phone the
application then interprets the data and
presents the information we wanted in a
readable way
this is what an API is so that means
each time we use an application like
Facebook send an instant image check
whether on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an API now when we have a good
idea about what an API is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the Hands-On demo that is why we use
jmeter for API testing Apache G meter is
an open source software and it is used
to simulate loads of various scenarios
and output performance data in several
ways including CSP and XML files and
graphs
we know that the Apache jmeter is 100
pure Java application so it is available
on every OS that supports Java 6 or
later
some of these specific reasons what
makes J meter a perfect fit for API
testing are
jmeter enables fast API testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing
then as we know it is an open source
tool and supports load testing and
stress testing it has a lot of plugins
and extensions jmeter can be used across
several platforms and can use various
programming languages now we know about
API Basics and why we use jmeter for its
testing
it is the right time to see the process
of API testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
Apache jmeta website and download the
file to know the entire downloading
process and install in jmeter you can
check our jmeta download and
installation video in our jmeter
playlist
moving on I have my geometer installed I
will go to the Apache jmeter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
geometer window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of that element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first J meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period and
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits third there is a
loop count where you can choose how many
times the test will run for the number
of users you can also choose the test to
run in finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
API for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is r e q r e s dot n or
requestresponse Dot N
we will create and run get post put and
delete rest API request in jmeter in the
demo here in this link we have all get
post put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request open this
link in the new tab
then we have got the URL for this API
copy this URL and go to the jmeter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
HTTP request here you will have to give
the address to some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
so here we shall paste the get API
request URL
in the protocol box we shall put the
https if in the URL the protocol would
have been HTTP then we would have left
this box empty
in the URL we shall put the URL link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the URL
would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the URL and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get API we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value as 2.
in this HTTP request drop down we can
see all the different types of HTTP
requests that jmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get API and also let's name
this HTTP request as get API
now when our HTTP request is ready we
will perform the test on it
to determine what the results of the
test will be we need to add some more
test elements we shall again right click
on the thread group go to The Listener
options then in the Box we can check the
different types of reports that jmeter
provides us for now we shall select two
of these let's choose view results tree
and the view results in the table
now save the test I will save the test
with the name API testing
finally let's run it for running the
test there are three simple ways first
you can simply click the green button on
the Run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the Third Way is you can right click
on the first jmeter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test let's go to
the view results stream here we can see
the green status that shows the test was
successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and looped to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to the thread
group and change the number of threads
to be 10 and run the test again after
running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and same happens in the
case of view results in table now in the
view results tree we can click on a
request and see different information
here we can see the sample start load
time latency error Etc
same in the view results and table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format you can also see the
response data here this is the same data
as it was there when we copied the URL
from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get API request
let's add the second request that is the
post request again add a HTTP request by
going to the sampler in the thread group
then come back to the browser window and
click on the post API option
then open the request URL in the new
window
then go to this window copy the URL and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this HTTP request as
post API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box
address in the server or IP address box
and path in the path box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option and we shall
have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
you can check some advanced settings
also in case you need them for now since
this is just a demo we shall keep it
really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test run in a required number of times
that is 20 times again I can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors Etc
now let's move on to our third API
request that is the put request go back
to the browser and click on put request
open the request in the new tab
copy the URL and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
put API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box
again let's put HTTP in the protocol box
address the server or IP address box and
path in the path box
and in the HTTP request drop down select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here we
shall go to our two listeners and clear
the previous output make the thread
count to be 1 and then we shall save the
test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the API request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format let's make
the thread count to bit 10 and again see
what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test running a required number of times
and here I can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last API request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
URL and come back to the jmeter window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
delete API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box address in the server
or IP address box and path in the path
box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the delete option this time here
there is nothing to be added in the
parameter section so let's go to the two
listeners and clear what all is there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any API
request by just clicking on it
let's get started with what is script
recording record testing in jmeter helps
testers to record and run their activity
against test targets it is a type of
automated testing but for multiple users
the test script is designed to record
such scenarios the proxy server allows
jmeter to watch and record user activity
while browsing web applications with a
normal web browser when we talk about
proxy it is a component that is present
between you and the remote server let us
say that you want to record web browser
interactions when jmica starts acting
like a proxy this is when jmeter's
script recording is used script
recording is one of the advanced and
impressive ways to figure out and
eliminate the complexity of browser
interactions and software testing now
when we know what script recording is
and how it is relevant let's look into
how to do it in jmeter but before that
let's check the prerequisites of script
recording in J Meetup there are three
major prerequisites first is having J
meter installed in your system the
second requirement is having Java
installed in your system the third and
final requirement is having Mozilla
Firefox in your system now let us have a
look at the Hands-On demo of how to
perform script recording in jmetup so
the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder we
will go into bin folder and then select
the jmeter.bat folder let us double
click on that this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen the home window is divided
into two sections on the left side all
the test plan elements are added and on
the right side all the configurations of
the elements are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and and everything will be
stored here now the first step is to add
thread group so for that right click on
the thread group select add and from add
go to threads or users and in that
select thread group here the thread
group refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test end
time the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
HTTP request option here there is a
server name or IP Box we have to give
this server name or IP in that let us
pick a website and place the link in the
Box we shall use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
in the server name box keep in mind that
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols that will come
in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box we will
leave a forward slash there since we
have to access the root page now the
next step is to add the HTTP test script
recorder for that right click on the
test plan then go to non-test elements
and select the HTTP test script recorder
option the window on the screen shows
several options here we can see the
start option to begin the test then
there is a box that has the port number
you can make this number whatever you
like I'll put this number as one two
three four for now then let's go back to
the simply learns website and go go to
the resources page then come back to the
jmeters window and rename the recording
controller as resources now let us add
another recording controller so that
jmeter works like a proxy with the help
of https test script recorder then again
go back to the resources page that we
just opened and scroll down a little bit
here we can see several Technologies and
several other links in those links you
can select any one of the links I will
select digital marketing here then go
back to the jmeter window and rename the
recording controller as digital
marketing then finally let's add a
recording controller for the home page
and rename it as simply learns home page
so now we can see that we have a thread
group here then there is a HTTP request
where we have simply learned website in
the server name then there are three
recording controllers one for the
resources the second for digital
marketing and a third one for home page
and last we have a HTTP test script
recorder here I will rearrange the
recording controllers in sequence
putting the simply launch home page
controller on the top and then placing
the resources finally digital marketing
recording controller now let us open
Mozilla Firefox in our system go to the
general option here and scroll down to
the network settings in the network
settings option select settings in the
window that appears select the manual
proxy configuration here we shall put
the port number for now I will put the
port number as one two three four in
this box
here in the HTTP proxy we have localhost
and we have selected to use this proxy
for FTP and https and then click on ok
now go back to the Apache jmeter folder
and now we shall use this Apache jmeter
temporary root CA file which is a
security certificate file so coming back
to the Mozilla Firefox window go to the
options Tab and in this tab I will type
certificates and here we shall select
view certificates in the window that
opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeta folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select OK coming back to the gym
meter window let us add some listeners
to get the results listeners are
something that are used to provide the
outputs of a test there are different
types of listeners present in jmeter and
many may be added using plugins for
adding listeners right click on HTTP
test recorder for adding listeners right
click on the HTTP test script recorder
then go to add option and then go to
listeners option and then add view
results tree now let us add one more
listener in the same way we shall add
view results entry now in the HTTP test
script recorder in the Target controller
option save the target controller here
in the drop down select the simply learn
home page option as we will begin the
script recording for the home page
finally let's start the test by clicking
here click on ok now go back to the
Mozilla browser and here let us open the
simply learns home page now come back to
the jmeter window go to the home page
recording controller you can see the
home page controller has started as you
can see the home page controller has
started recording the scripts that are
being performed these are the tasks that
are performed on the client side to the
server side now we can check both the
listeners that we have put to see what
all functions are working fine and what
all are not all the tasks from the time
that we have entered to simplylearn.com
in our browser are recorded in this home
page controller to take the test further
go to the test script recorder and stop
the test now here in the Target
controller select the second controller
that is the resources controller now
start the test again select ok go to
Simply learns website select resources
after opening the resources link go back
to the jmeter window and now in the
resources controller you can see what
all events are recorded from the client
side to the server side once we click on
the resources link now again in the tool
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test tip recorder and stop
the test now here in the Target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
Target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the Mozilla Firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link I guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the two
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is RJ meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeta script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings if you're ready to embark
on a career path pulsating with x
excitement Innovation and Limitless
growth look no further than simply
landscape post-graduate program in
devops this comprehensive program equips
you with the Knowledge and Skills to
navigate the devops landscape with
confidence explore the depth of
continuous integration delivery and
convert the entry cases of Automation
and orchestration fortify security like
a digital Fortress and unleash the full
potential of cloud Technologies don't
let this once in a lifetime opportunity
slip away ignite your career and join
the ranks of prime Dev professionals
click the link in the description box to
enable the wonders of this course moving
further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that Java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having Java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as Linux
Windows Mac us or even Ubuntu
now that we know the basics of J meter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
first let's check if you have Java
installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type Java hyphen
version we can see that Java is present
in our system here it will show the
version of java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to Google Chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official Apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections in
the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting jmeter
now it's time for us to launch a meter
but before we launch jmeter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which jmeter can be launched
the GUI mode and the non-gui mode the
non-gui mode May refer to two types the
first being running jmeter in the server
mode and the second refers to running
jmeter in the command line
and if we talk about the GUI mode then
the GUI mode has a limitation which
slows down the CPU utilization while
running the recorded script but GUI mode
of jmeter is perfect for adding and
editing new configuration elements
thread groups and Samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the GUI mode
so to open the GUI mode inside this bin
folder select the jmeter.bat file double
click on this file this may take a while
and then the jmeter window will open up
on the screen the home window is divided
into two sections on the left side all
the elements of the test plan are added
and on the right side all the
configuration of that element are added
as we see on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first J meter now when you click outside
this window section you can see the
element name will change otherwise you
can just save this and also the name
will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first J meter here and select the add
option then in this option select the
threads option and then thread scrub the
thread group refers to the users that
are used or created or needed to run
this test so let's name this thread
group to be jmeter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want then there is this number of
threads where you can choose the number
of users you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to Run infinite number
of times
there is also a scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests and time
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
the next step is to go to First J meter
and again to go to add in the box set of
peers select Samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the HTTP request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
let's pick our website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the URL from
here
come back to the J meter window and
paste it in the server name box keep in
mind we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case
then in the path dialog box since we
have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our HTTP test is ready we'll
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first J meter go to
The Listener options then in the Box we
can check the different type of reports
that jmeter provides us for now we shall
select two of these let's choose view
results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the Third Way is you can
right click on first J meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be 1 there's just one entry
in both the results now let's try one
more thing we shall go to J meter and
change the number of threads and the
loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10. and now run the test after running
the test we shall see the results in the
table and see the testing being
performed and the same happens in the
case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since a loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link here we wrap up
with devops tools if you like this video
hit the like button consider subscribing
to our Channel hit the Bell icon to
never miss updates from Simply learn
till then keep watching and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here